I'm really stupid.
Welcome back to Ultra Wild's Echoes of the Eye.
You guys, my brain is so small!
Oh no!
The illustration is too dang cute.
I thought so too.
I'm back.
Why do you say that?
Because I've been thinking...
Okay, I'll be honest.
I haven't been thinking about it all week.
But I've been thinking pretty consistently like...
How do I solve this?
Next puzzle...
I have no idea!
I don't know!
So...
We're getting endurance today.
Let's see how far we can get.
Hopefully finish.
We'll see.
As long as my brain is...
Capable.
Probably.
Does Mint have the ability to think?
Maybe with help from the Baxators?
Yeah, but you guys will probably say no Elp.
You guys will probably say no Elp!
Oh my goodness, my voice is a little hoarse.
That's an elephant.
I was supposed to...
Record the podcast.
Usually stuff like that will help warm up my voice.
Omatara overslept because she's not feeling well.
No Elp.
Please, just a little Elp.
Just a little, little Elp.
Please.
A little Elp.
Yippee!
Okay, let's just get started.
Because we can...
Go over some stuff that...
That...
The...
Stuff from last...
Week.
Why am I lagging?
Okay, I think I'm okay.
No Elf?
No Elf.
Just Elp.
Just a little bit of Elp.
Like, tiny bit.
Okay.
So we're here at the Stranger for our little recap.
It's been...
It's been a week.
So the Stranger is this ring world hidden with a cloaking field.
It's also like trying to get away from the sun.
I think that they know something bad's gonna happen.
And it's not Hearthian or Nomayan.
It's scary.
That's all that it is.
We have the reservoir.
There's more to explore here.
We...
We got inside the house eventually.
Wait.
Is it the...
More to explore here.
Enjoy your artist giving you buffs.
I know, right?
Feels like you're rubbing it in Doki's face.
You know.
It's all an illusion.
Basically.
You know.
Attractive.
A trick of the eye.
A ghostly apparition.
A ghost trick if you will.
I don't know what jumbly dumblies means, Archer.
But I think it's pretty apt to this.
I think.
She shifted the ectoplasm around.
There's the house with the projector and the reservoir.
You didn't use it.
There it is.
We're back.
Okay.
Huh?
I found a projection showing the stranger's current trajectory and the sun's predicted supernova rate.
It's in the summary.
Oh my gosh.
I can't read the summary.
I'm feeling summary FOMO.
AI summary FOMO.
Okay.
This thing is what I was thinking of.
The sum...
Wait.
Hold on.
What does this say?
I found a diagram of a hollow metal structure suspended by chains.
There is a round hole underneath that appears to be only one end...
Only...
The only entrance.
Yeah.
And it's this sealed vault that takes us to the lake.
And we're trying to unlock it.
Maybe?
I guess so.
Poor doki board.
Do...
Doki board?
Holy moly.
That is so good.
Did you come up with that yourself?
Oh.
Wow.
I'm missing context.
Why is doki bird aboard?
Because she's flat.
That's...
That's all.
You know.
Okay.
Let's see.
The sealed vault.
Which is...
The...
These things.
And then the things that show how to make it appear and disappear.
You just go to those things and they'll light it up, baby.
And then...
I guess we gotta go to them and blow them out?
Maybe?
We'll see.
What's this?
Side reel.
Yeah.
Okay.
River...
Hold on.
Which one is the...
The...
Okay.
This is the reservoir.
We're gonna go back there since there's more to explore.
River lowlands.
This stinking tower is the bane of my existence right now.
I found a side...
No.
Not the secret passage.
It's this one.
This...
This has been haunting me.
The ghost is being haunted.
This has been haunting me for...
For...
For a week?
Two.
Thank you.
Wait.
Hold on.
Sorry.
I just realized.
I cannot read.
Oh.
I meant I'm ashamed for missing first two streams.
What?
Don't even be worried about that.
But thank you, Samu.
Thank you.
I just watched the VOD.
So let's go with this knife and knife.
Mary, love you.
Bye.
Thank you so much.
This game expands your brain big time.
I...
Oh, gosh.
It's this puzzle that's really making me...
Making me scratch my head a lot.
Oh.
So that is what we're gonna...
I mean, we're gonna focus on everything because we're trying to...
Cliffside building.
We haven't been here yet either.
We haven't been able to go because the bridge...
It rotted away.
Hidden Gorge.
But there's nothing else.
I guess this is the only...
Wait.
Yeah.
This is the only place that still has stuff to explore.
So let's go there.
Before we...
Oh, wait.
And obviously in the unknown.
In the unknown places.
There's stuff to explore.
Which I really don't want to.
But, you know.
Oh.
But we still have a place that we can go to that is safe.
Good luck!
Thank you!
I just realized...
Where's the map?
Here.
Yes.
Wait.
Where is it?
I locked onto it.
It didn't work.
Why did it get locked?
Wait.
Oh, wait.
I'm getting out.
I'm going over here.
Gopar!
Thank you for the 50gift!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Oh, stranger.
You guys spoil me.
I'm coming in!
Oh!
Hot... maybe.
I'm not locked onto it, what do you mean?
Wait, what happened?
Oh, I forgot to lock onto it!
Who's on the thumbnail?
What do you mean,
who's on the thumbnail?
What do you mean by that?
Is it so unbelievable?
Is it so unbelievable that that could not be me on the thumbnail?
It's called artistic liberties.
Everybody.
It's called artistic liberty.
Also, Ducky, thanks for the five...
Okay, we already wasted some time.
That's okay.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Coming in hot again.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, I don't want to run into the chandelier.
We're gonna roll?
This is a foolproof plan.
You roll and then that's it.
It's the easiest thing ever.
To the reservoir.
Another masterful somersault landing.
Thank you.
Goodness.
I'm already getting nervous.
I'm already nervous.
Wait.
Oh, we're here.
Okay, nice.
Oh, we're in this entrance.
Never mind.
We're in a completely different place than I thought we were.
That's okay, though.
We'll be quiet thanks to the bomb.
Reservoir shortcut to the left of the hangar.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
There's a shortcut?
Oh.
I don't think so.
Oh, the elevator, but not here.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
No worries.
It's all good.
We can just kind of get there.
I like taking the river.
Down, down, down by the river.
Does anyone still remember that game?
Whatever happened to Baldur's Gate?
Okay, we're just going all the way to the end, everybody.
Are we going down or up?
Yes.
I think we're going up.
I don't know.
Yeah, it's still big, is it?
I never finished it.
I don't know, maybe I think it was because like, for me, I didn't understand so much because I'm not into, uh, what do you call, into D&D so much.
So there was like a lot that I felt like I kind of missed out on because I was like, I don't understand some of this lore.
They kind of throw you into the game and expect you to kind of understand like, you know, certain roles and certain...
Okay, over here, right?
Let's go over this way.
It's a pretty long game.
Yeah, whoa, why is this version of...
Wait, have I not heard this song?
This version of the song?
It sounds kind of different.
Okay.
Oh, wait, no, we went in here.
We can't read.
We did go in here.
Was it over here?
Did I not go in here?
Can't read.
No, we did go in here.
Wait, what am I missing?
Now that...
Oh, I'm kind of confused.
Taking your lantern?
In here, maybe?
This projector room?
Okay...
Maybe in here?
There's a slideshow in there.
Hello?
Oh no!
No!
Oh, it's okay though.
We'll just open it back up.
No biggie.
Oh, maybe... here?
No, I remember getting baited by this before.
Oh gosh, so scary.
The door to nowhere.
I think that was our first time seeing it.
Actually...
Why does it flicker like that?
Uh oh.
We don't have much time.
Well, we have time, but we don't have time.
Let's see.
Maybe down below?
Wait, is there a down below?
Where could be?
The projector?
Or the slide?
I can't... sorry.
If you guys...
If I forget something and you're just like It's at this place.
That's totally okay.
Don't tell me, because it's me forgetting.
If you remember.
Sometimes.
My brain is small.
K R Z!
Welcome to the bamboo ship.
Thank you!
I can't remember what this was.
I think it was like...
No, I can't remember at all.
But we went in here.
This is where the password is.
They write it on the walls, because they're just you know, really silly about it.
Right there!
She's traded brains for thumbnail booba.
I'm like that meme of the girl that picks up the book or whatever.
I'm the opposite of that meme.
Sun, I fire, I fire.
Sun,
I fire, I fire.
Sun, I fire, I fire.
Now I do remember this room.
K R Z!
Thanks for the gift!
So you turned bimbo?
I guess so.
What am I missing in this area?
What am I missing in here?
Is it in the other house that we had to go break into?
No, shoot.
Mike Tyson!
Thank you for the gift!
Over yonder.
It's near the bait door?
I'm not kidding?
Okay.
I'm trusting you.
I'm trusting you Superfly Dan Fry.
I'm calling you by your full legal name.
Right now.
I thought that there would be something to do with the bait door, right?
Because it's like, Why else would they- I mean, I don't know why else they would have it.
Just to make you feel a little goofy.
But I don't see anything over there.
I see something hanging.
Okay, I'm going to the bait door.
To troll.
Down from the bait door.
No way.
Like in the water?
Like down, down?
Down, down, down by the river?
No help.
Give him credit if he's right then.
I absolutely will.
Here we go.
I think I should bring my...
I saw!
I see!
You were right!
Superfly Dan Fry!
That was it, right?
You were right!
Oh my gosh.
I think maybe they could have had it like kind of glinting in the water for dummies like me, you know?
But also dummies like me should not be playing this game.
Because, you know...
Oh my gosh, Matorakon!
Oh.
That was fast.
I can see fire.
More fire.
Something's going on in there.
I swear, if this is all that it was...
If this is all that it is...
Oh, the guys.
The deer people.
Oh!
They show up.
They're walking.
They're coming real close.
They're coming close!
Um...
Oh!
Wait, in the thumbnail of Gengar is a ghost like meant to take over Gengar's body?
Wish that was me.
No, I just dressed up as Gengar, obviously.
Okay.
Oh, yes, yes.
We knew that.
That...
So they built the thing around Matorakon.
Wow, they imprisoned her.
And sunk her in the water.
They were like, see ya!
That's it.
Ship log updated.
Okay.
Hmm.
I think it's because we already kind of knew that that was in there.
So it wasn't like so...
You know, we already knew...
About the entrance in there.
We already knew about...
This being a thing.
So...
Now to explore the scary place.
I don't...
I don't wanna...
Wait.
We're going in.
We'll go in through here, I guess.
Wait.
This is the one...
This is actually probably the area that we need to explore the least.
Now that I think about it.
But...
Um...
Oh, yeah.
I am gonna...
I am...
Wait.
Does this take us to the tower, though?
Doesn't it?
I don't know.
Hello.
I'm just gonna...
Yeah.
We need to unleash this.
Do we?
No!
Do we need to unleash it?
You know what?
I'm just gonna doze off.
Good night.
Wake up.
Oh!
Oh.
Good night.
No.
Oh.
Did I wake up too soon?
Oh, I don't have the artifact!
Oh shoot.
I don't even remember where to get one.
Maybe...
Sheep or gore.
I truly did.
I truly forgot about that part.
I'm thinking... You know what?
I'm just gonna meditate in the next loop and then we'll go...
We'll start from...
We'll start from scratch.
Near the egg.
So...
Since we already had the bridge explode...
I think we'll start over.
We got what we needed there.
And we shall...
Come back.
Let's continue onward.
I can't believe my eyes played such a trick on me.
I really thought it was something disappearing.
But it was just... I really thought it was an egg.
That was like dancing around.
But it was...
Just a water droplet.
How could I...
How could I gaslight myself so much?
The egg.
Okay.
Slideshow that shows a strange vault being encased in a large metal structure and lowered under water.
Nearly all the slides have been burned and cannot be viewed.
Yeah, it was so useless.
Thank you.
According to the slide, real strange vault...
OK.
Which we know.
That's what that is.
I feel like they expected you to find this...
Way sooner.
I'm sorry, I'm not playing Subnautica here.
I'm not diving underwater all the time.
The real egg was the friends we made along the way.
Pro-gast lighter.
I don't remember how to get to which one.
I don't remember how we get to the Shrouded Woodlands...
versus how we get to the Starlit Cove.
But this cave is very intriguing.
Kindlelit Tower sits atop a nearby island.
And then the Endless Canyon.
I can't remember how we get to...
Woodlands is the first one.
I wonder...
if we're able to get to the cliffside building...
by somehow waking up...
when...
we're in this building...
in the other world.
If that's how we get to it.
That's what I'm thinking.
But I...
Hidden Vault Seals!
Impossible.
But we need to find this cliffside building, I suppose.
I'm imagining it would maybe be in the Endless Canyon.
The Endless Eighth Canyon.
Want Elp or no Elp?
I will ask for Elp...
when I'm like truly desperate.
But I appreciate it.
Shrouded Woodlands...
Okay, so this is the first one.
Uhh...
Is this the...
This looks to be the tower?
When we come out of the tower?
Is this...
the tower...
the...
the one...
and then...
Let's go...
to the Endless Canyon.
What a thumbnail.
I'm successfully...
playing YouTube, you guys.
I'm...
I'm clickbaiting.
you know...
doing all that good stuff.
So...
Say the word if need Elp.
Thank you.
Please clickbait more.
You dirty dirties.
Okay, so where we need to go...
is...
do a little somersault.
Foolproof plan.
We need to go to...
the right side.
I believe.
Perfect landing.
She knows us so well.
The chat reflects the streamer.
Cute ball.
Thanks for the five.
I'm gifted.
Thank you.
Push, push.
Yesterday's thumbnail was top tier.
Stummy and...
Stop.
Oh my goodness.
So easy.
Sometimes less is more you guys.
You know.
Don't ever forget that.
Happy Outer Wilds.
Thank you.
Come on.
Okay, to the right.
To the right.
This way.
Okay, nice.
But I don't want to get... I don't want to get sucked up.
Unless it's this one.
No, no.
That's not one.
It needs the symbol.
Love Outer Wilds.
Hope you're enjoying the DLC.
I am!
Thank you!
Grimy?
Grim?
Grimy.
Gr I guess it's all good.
Now I gotta remember where to get an artifact.
Stick.
Let's go to the other side.
Wait, wait, how do I... how did I get up there before?
Because this doesn't work, right?
Yeah, this one's broken.
The other one is not broken.
Oh!
I thought this was one for the boat.
My bad.
I thought this was... I thought it was one for the boat.
Like I thought it was one to pick up your boat.
My bad.
Up please.
Up, up, up please.
You guys, it's fine.
It's all good.
Everything is fine.
This is definitely like a game though that can be really difficult to orient yourself.
I only haven't played it in a week.
You know?
Like if you haven't played it for even longer, I can't even imagine how...
like difficult it might be to remember things, you know?
Oh, so this is the entrance.
Ah!
This is the entrance through the hole.
We know this entrance.
But we don't have to go back in there.
I think we're pretty good.
The DLC is much harder.
I am...
So far.
I think there's a few things that have been stumping me.
But I've gotten some of the other puzzles.
This is the room where they burn...
They have to burn the...
This is all...
Has all the ghost matter though.
Also, can we reverse burn?
Let's see.
Is there anything in here?
Oh wait.
We have to go down here, right?
I don't remember where the artifact is.
But we'll find it, I'm sure.
We go here.
No!
Wait.
Artifact?
Oh, there's a real in here.
I don't think...
Maybe we...
Maybe it's in the...
In the projector room.
Oh, look!
Look!
Ouch.
I think it's usually in like the projector basement, right?
I believe...
What is that?
There's one in here.
Yes!
Okay.
All right, let's get going.
Like the panels flicker.
So either makes me think it's like they're...
They're like a screen of some sort.
It's not really a view of the outside or something.
I don't know.
I have no idea.
And open up, please.
Thank you.
Wait.
Oh lee...
Oh gosh.
I'm all...
I'm so
scared!
I'm so scared.
Oh gosh.
Sleepover party...
I miss when we were just...
We were just a weird cult.
We were a weird cult, man.
I miss those days.
Now here, we do know that there's a guy.
Okay, so maybe...
I thought I saw something walking.
What is that down there?
There must be some more text, right?
Okay.
Oh gosh.
No wonder.
You know what?
When people were like, the DLC got too spooky for me.
Too spooky for me.
I couldn't complete it.
I get it.
I really get it.
Before, I was just like, I don't know.
How spooky will this get?
The game... wait, this isn't where the person was singing though, right?
I was like, how spooky can this get?
I was like... you know.
The whole game before, like the original game, was definitely eerie.
But like, scary?
I didn't think so.
It gets worse!
My stomach hurts.
This is the first area we came into.
When I first...
When we first came to the other world.
I can't quite remember where all we went.
I remember being too afraid to continue in certain areas.
There is a baby mode if it's too scary.
But I don't want to be a baby!
Oh, we haven't seen this area.
See, look, they seem pretty friendly, right?
They have their own little music shows.
And stuff.
They don't seem so bad.
This is where they perform.
And stuff.
And when...
Oh, extinguish.
Bad people don't like music.
What are the instruments made of?
Wood?
Right?
Is that an antler?
Maybe they are bad.
I'm curious though.
What...
You can say it's a spoiler if you...
If I can't know.
But what does...
Turning on baby mode do?
Because if it's like a huge imp...
It's a spoiler?
Dang it!
Okay, I'll believe you.
We have to get in there somehow.
Because this...
Goes to here.
And makes a bridge.
Okay.
I remember getting grabby grabbed over here.
Right there, I believe.
Or...
Somewhere.
Oh my god.
That tree just scared the heck out of me!
Okay.
Yeah, we were there before but time ran out.
Yes, yes.
Oh, wait.
This is where we get grabby grabbed.
Maybe.
Turning on baby mode drastically reduces...
Your speed.
Pussy.
To the ground.
As babies crawl.
Uh oh.
I think that was...
Okay, so we do have to go downstairs.
Everything's okay.
Don't worry about it, man.
No need to scream.
Or anything.
Okay, he's still there.
Have to be a little quicker.
Okay.
Alright.
Is this area fine though?
I think I'll be safe.
I think.
From the water is what I mean.
I think I'll be safe from...
From the water.
Um...
Oh god!
Not from anything else!
I'm...
Okay.
I think I've went through all of this area.
But...
It doesn't hurt to...
To...
Try again, I'd say.
Doesn't hurt to try again.
What was that?
I wanna go to baby mode.
Okay.
Now that you guys have reminded me, I'm like...
Sounds like a pretty good option.
Not gonna lie.
Which is open.
Thought I just heard a door open.
Oh!
Oh shit!
There's an actual guy there!
Is it a friendly guy?
Surely.
That's why I'm able to conceal my, uh...
Can he hear footsteps?
That's a good question, I wonder.
He's just pacing.
Waiting for death...
Probably.
Only one way to find out.
Is he gonna, like...
Run out the door if he sees me?
Be like...
I wanna
see him.
But I also...
I'm so scared!
I
want to see him.
Okay.
Let's just continue onwards.
Oh, here we go.
He won't notice me.
He's not gonna come out.
Right.
Okay.
We gotta go back to the grabby grab.
I gotta make a little bit of progress.
Come on.
Uh...
Can't see anything anymore.
There we go.
Just, uh...
Just act like you belong!
Oh, wait!
Oh, no!
The grabby grab is up there!
I made a...
I made a fatal mistake.
My bad.
It's, uh...
Here.
Grabby grab?
Wait, where is it?
Grabby!
Where is it?
Oh?
Is it here?
I saw it though!
What do you mean?
Do I do it from... oh my god.
Keep walking?
What do you mean, keep walking?
He's gonna... he's gonna see me.
So eerie and all, right?
Oh my gosh, I really wanna see him.
I'm so curious!
What does he look like?
Maybe over here.
Found it!
I found it.
Oh good, it's even like a shortcut, so... awesome.
Okay... let's see what else can we find in here.
Okay, there's some more stuff over here.
Okay, stuff over here, stuff over here.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Is this a horror game?
It might as well be, right?
Where are we going?
Glad I didn't miss the excitement!
I thought... for some reason I read OW is Overwatch.
Skelem, thank you!
Yeah!
Oh, wait!
This is the place where the... okay, we know where this is, because when I do this, the boat appears!
Ah, this is another way to get on the boat!
Okay, that's good to know, actually.
Because it's not... I mean, well...
It's a little annoying to get here, but it's not so far out of the way if we ever need to get back on the boat.
Well...
Overwatch is not the most wonderful game.
I mean, to each their own.
I agree with you, but...
This isn't Overwatch?
So that means the tower fell, right?
I believe.
And so we're about out of time.
Hahaha!
Wait, but I just made it here!
Wait,
what's this?
The tree...
The base of a tree...
Is an entrance?
Okay...
I really like music.
Okay, what else can I find in here?
Before...
Before our demise...
Hmm...
I think there's something in here, but...
Time's up.
Yup, time's up.
Do you think they know that they're in a time loop as well?
These alien creatures?
Their chairs look like toilets.
They look like toilet seats.
Maybe that's how we know we cannot trust them.
Go ask them.
Hey, do you know that you're about to die in like two seconds?
I think they know.
Open up!
Wonder what this means.
Well, we at least found some stuff.
I think this is the end of the road for this area at least, so...
We're about to...
Hmm...
It's crooked.
Wish I could fix it.
Oh my gosh, it's so quiet.
It's so...
Eerie.
Just...
We'll just, uh...
Wait for your...
Death to take us...
Now.
Hmm...
I prefer it to be quiet.
No way!
It's too scary!
Can we go back to the boat?
I'm scared.
Hmm...
I wonder what else it's gonna say about this area...
Your yapping got me through my master's!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you for the super chat!
Congratulations!
Here's to four more years!
Four more years!
Angel, thanks for the gift!
Masters...
Literally... wait.
I found a mural of a large tree at the bottom floor of the lodge.
Oh!
That really is everything there!
Nice!
I'm so curious though.
What if I go back and I have my lantern on right by the guy?
Oh!
I want him to see me!
I'm so curious.
Okay, but that area has been explored.
So very cool, very cool.
Do it?
You want to trigger alert 100?
I kind of do.
Okay, we're going to go do it?
What's the easiest way to get there?
Oh.
I'm trying to think of the easiest way to get there.
What's the worst that could happen?
But it's also kind of a pain in the butt to get all the way over there, isn't it?
Hmm...
Nah, we'll just go to the other areas.
It's fine.
We'll go to the other areas.
The hole gets you straight to that area.
Oh, you're right!
Oh, but the hole is such a pain in the butt to get into.
Oh!
Where's...
Ah!
Oh!
My bad.
Which hole?
It's like a...
It's like a little hole in the ship.
Yeah, I literally was just like, the hole brings us there.
Perfect!
I'm sure it's fine.
I'm sure it doesn't need any... I think it's okay.
It's just a little scratch.
Raiders?
Oh my gosh, thank you!
Thanks for the raid!
I didn't see who raided.
Raymac, thanks for the gifted!
Wait, thank you so much!
Sorry.
I've been... gaming.
Hello, hello.
We're playing Outer Wilds, which is a spooky...
Well, it's not a spooky game, but this is a very spooky DLC.
So if you're not good with spooky things...
Uh...
Oh, I remember what to do here.
If you're not good with spooky things...
Viewer discretion.
Happy Tuesday.
Happy... Happy Tuesday.
Murphy, thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you!
Thank you, guys!
Tomorrow, I have... um...
I have karaoke.
If you... want to watch that.
I'll have karaoke, and then right after, I'm going to play Doom.
Early, early in the morning...
I'm kind of nervous, or worried, because early, early in the morning, I have to...
I'm taking my cat to the vet.
I'm getting him an ultrasound.
So, I'm going to be up super duper early to do that.
And then...
Oh, artifact.
And then streaming two times.
And then I have stuff that I'm doing at night.
So, it's just a lot of craziness.
Tomorrow.
This whole week has been a little crazy busy for me.
This is the one...
No, this is not the one that's missing a person.
Look how creepy!
This is our... This is our cult friends.
This guy is even like...
You can't be hiding.
Stop.
Get your fingers off of there.
Don't hide the light.
Okay, let's take... Let's doze off.
Hope it turns out to be a good day, Mint.
Thank you.
Give our thank you!
Got my postcard today.
I'm happy to say both of your faces were in mint condition.
Who's the boing boing mint cosplayer in the thumbnail?
Stop!
What are you talking about?
They're average!
This is the one where we get on the boat, isn't it?
Am I... Am I...
I think we can get on the boat or we can go somewhere else.
But somewhere else sounds really scary.
And the boat sounds like a lovely location to be in.
The boat sounds like a really lovely location.
And everywhere else sounds not so lovely and nice.
The boat sounds really comfortable.
And everywhere else sounds really scary.
And I don't like it.
Which... I know this is not the direction of the boat.
So I'm a little frightened.
What is this?
Oh.
Where is this going?
Actually...
Now that I think about it, I have no idea.
Is this where... I think...
I was gonna say, I think this is where we saw someone walking around.
And there... they were down there!
I saw a light moving!
I don't know!
Is that where we're headed?
Please say no.
This is an egg.
No, it is very much...
Not a figment of my imagination.
It is very much real.
I'm most afraid that it allows you to extinguish the lights here.
That's what terrifies me the most.
I'm
brave.
I'm brave.
I'm...
Oh, that's the electricity.
Oh!
The controller just vibrated a little bit.
Okay, so this doesn't really lead to anywhere, actually.
Unless it's this direction.
I'm being brave.
I'm being...
It's to save the candle.
Yeah!
Oh!
Wait, what is this?
Guys, I don't think I'm as brave as I think I am.
I don't think I'm as brave as I think I am.
I'm just scoping out the area.
I think I'm actually gonna...
I think I'm actually gonna pee myself.
Is true happiness throwing bricks at me?
What are you talking about?
He's down there.
You see him?
Oh, that's close.
Wait, is he a zombie?
No way.
Wait, this is where the show is.
Wait, I kinda wanna go see the show.
I can't see anything.
I don't know, like...
Oh my god, there's two of them!
Are they zombie guys?
Hold on.
There's two of them.
I don't know, like, what their range is, is what I meant to say.
I think I almost said hitbox.
I don't know what their range is.
I can't tell where the other guy went.
Oh, there's a chair.
Oh no, wait, they're gonna see me.
Where'd he go?
Where'd the other guy go?
We saw him.
There were two of them.
Extinguish.
I literally can't see anything, though.
Holy cow, it's so dark.
Just watching his oshi.
Don't disturb him.
Okay.
I don't see anyone else, so...
Whoa, just kidding.
I just...
Unless it was a star.
Unless it was a shining star in the sky.
There he is!
There's one guy, and I think the other guy is leaving.
I love hearing Mint in the background with screams.
Maybe the artifact is just an alien penlight.
Oh, Jesus.
I'm further away from the place, but I think we have to go...
I heard a whistle.
I'm gonna get caught for sure, you guys.
I'm gonna get so caught.
I'm gonna get caught for sure.
I just got grabby-grabbed.
And I think I...
Actually, I think I need to go back over there.
Wait, so I've been here because these candles are lit up.
Right?
Or am I crazy?
Have I been here?
No.
Maybe?
Huh?
Where am I?
Shortcut!
Okay.
Oh!
Wait.
Oh my god!
There's so many of them!
They're all going for... the show is ended though.
You guys are late.
Nah, they're going for Bupan.
They're going to go see their Oshi.
They're gonna go get goods merch and stuff.
But I know that if I don't...
If I don't hurry up...
If the bridge is gonna break and...
I won't be able to get there at all.
There it is!
Our flame's gonna go out!
Oh no!
I was too slow, but can you blame me?
Okay, I'm gonna run up to him.
Dang.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
Well, we know where we need to go there.
It's just...
Yikes.
Oh gosh.
Sorry for being so slow, you guys!
I'm just scared!
I'm scared!
So close.
Isn't that right?
Okay.
Let's go to the tower.
Oh, dang it.
I thought I made it.
Oh.
Up, up, up, up.
Okay.
Whew.
Small steps.
You've got this.
I just don't know how far away they'll notice me at all.
So that's why I'm...
I'm such an...
I'm overly cautious all the time, you guys.
Because if I'm not overly cautious, it never works in my favor.
I'm such a...
Okay.
I just came here from ERB Stream.
Hello!
I was watching her stream earlier too.
Gosh, she is such a...
Oh my god.
Her singing...
I was like thinking...
The first time I heard her sing...
I was like, all I want to hear...
Is her do a cover of...
Of...
What's it called?
Woh, ho!
Oh!
No, that's Snake Eater.
But that too.
She's got such an amazing, incredible voice.
This is so awesome.
Sins of the Father!
Yes, thank you.
Yes, I want to hear her cover Sins of the Father.
This is where... like this area is.
Down there.
But the boat doesn't go over there.
You think we can make it if we jump?
I don't think so.
I have such tiny legs.
I'm a small, small alien.
But yeah, if anybody's coming in...
This is DLC of a game and we're kind of like in the middle of it.
So if you don't stick around, that's all good.
But if you want to watch from the beginning...
That's good too.
Yes, this is it!
This is where the hole is.
I'm going to jump.
That was like the eggs and bacon alarm.
For real.
I guess I'll go back in.
I don't think we have so much time left, but...
I'll try again.
I think we can make it this time.
Something's a skill issue, right?
But we know...
We know that there are guys walking around in here as well.
Thanks for...
Over two months may help your well.
Thank you!
Thank you...
Gin?
Jin?
Thank you so much.
We know they're walking around in here.
Oh, why aren't you going to the show, huh?
Wait, so this...
This...
We know this one has an alarm down here.
I remember the alarm down here.
But I think if I just keep my thing off...
Wait, is it over here?
I think if I...
Okay,
here we go.
I literally can't see anything.
I can see the night sky and that's about it.
I can see black.
You can see the night sky?
The...
That planet?
I think I'm going the right way.
Oh.
This way?
I can't tell if I turned around or not.
I can't tell anything.
What's that?
Whoosh.
Oh.
I'm right next to it.
I thought I was across.
Oh.
Hello.
Hmm.
Cool.
Uh...
What's this way?
Maybe it's a bad idea to head towards the light, but...
A steerable boat.
Yeah, you're...
Whoa.
This place is really...
Is this like...
The...
What's it called?
Place?
Where they had all the worship of the eye.
Oh.
Ooh.
Don't fall in.
So it's...
There's also an equivalent here.
What's this?
Oh.
No.
Please.
I just got here.
Oh my goodness.
How do I get out of here?
Let me out, please.
Oh.
We're just about...
I didn't hear a screech there.
What is this time?
What the...
What is this?
Oh, wait.
This is to get inside.
Just kidding.
There is a screech.
Just kind of faded.
Ah, okay.
Hello?
There we go.
Hmm.
Okay.
So we were over there, technically.
Kind of.
We...
Trying to think of where...
Is this the...
This is the place...
That...
I'm trying to wake up in.
Right here.
I believe.
I believe...
That is what I think I have to do.
Because I think I...
Have to wake up here.
Lord Dredd, welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
Oh.
Because I'm assuming this is like a one-to-one creation of their world.
Right?
I mean...
That would make sense.
And so...
You...
We were here.
Because we came from here.
We went this...
Here.
Right?
Maybe?
I don't know.
Why?
Is everyone saluting?
You'll see...
In like...
Maybe one minute.
Oh.
Some stuff is the same.
Yeah.
Where is the sun anyway?
Uh...
Hello?
You could have definitely given me more time in there, tower.
The AI summary just called you blind.
What?
Nandato.
Hmm.
Oh.
I know you can see the sun.
Actually...
Okay.
Hold on.
You can see the sun and stuff at the very beginning when you enter it.
But remember we got that diagram of the planet thing moving away?
So I wonder if we've been moving this whole time like away from the sun.
But then why do we die?
A dense forest along the banks of a river.
I heard music coming from a camera.
A man who's trying to handle it building across the water.
Found a covered bridge leading to the darkest part of the forest.
Wait.
It doesn't say...
That there's like...
Anything else to see here.
So...
But I'm so curious what's going on in the...
In the building.
Because the ash twin project sends the information back in time and gets destroyed.
Hmmm.
Yes.
Okay, yes.
Ash Twin Project always sends your memory back.
Okay.
That makes... that... yes.
Oh, whoop.
This one.
There's more to explore here.
But there's not more to explore here.
So...
Don't trust the logs.
There are a bunch of logs that don't trigger more to explore.
Dang it.
So you're telling me I have to go to the show?
I have to... be brave.
Is that what you're saying?
But... let's go back here.
To the tower.
Because I'm quite curious about...
Whoop.
Wait.
How did... hold on.
How did we get there?
I'm already losing it.
Okay.
I'm curious what you just missed.
I'm curious about so many things.
I'm curious about everything that's going on.
Ahem.
There's more to explore here.
It's very scary though.
Okay.
Maybe I should go back.
I'm gonna try the show.
Oh god.
You guys!
I'm scared though!
I'm scared!
But I'm scared.
I'm scared to try the show.
Oh.
There we go.
See?
We can see the sun right now.
I think we're moving.
I think this thing is like... saying sayonara to everywhere.
Be brave, Minto.
Can I turn on baby mode?
How is turning on baby mode a spoiler?
If...
Oh.
Oops.
If...
You could do it from the very beginning.
You know?
That's all my questions.
No babies here.
There is!
I'm a big baby!
Cuckoo!
Cuckoo Gaga.
I've returned the baby.
Knowing what it does is a spoiler.
This is so messed up.
This is so messed up of you all.
This is so messed up!
You can't know what the baby mode does because it's a spoiler.
Too bad you're so afraid.
Then how do I know what I'm turning?
I wouldn't even know what I'm turning off.
Thank
you.
Chu.
Thank you.
My mantra to be brave is what's the worst that can happen?
And it'll be less scary the second time.
That is true.
It'll be less scary the second time.
I don't believe in what's the worst that can happen though.
Because... I don't know.
I don't want to get jumpscared.
Jeffrey!
We needed to make people aware of it.
So that they knew what they were getting into.
Okay.
Also yes, the way it works is a spoiler.
Stop!
Jeffrey!
Gosh, I'm so...
I'm so scared.
No!
Okay.
Um...
There was like a hand.
There was a grabby grab.
Is it this way that we...
That goes to the grabby grab?
No.
This is...
Wait, I went to the right place, right?
Yeah.
Say hi to them.
What's the worst?
You die?
That's alright.
I've already...
I've already gone through that once.
We'll tell you once you're ready to know.
Okay, okay.
No, don't open that.
Because we're not going on the boat.
Oh wait!
I could go on the boat.
No.
I don't think I can.
I don't think I can go on the boat actually.
Because it doesn't stop.
By...
Yeah, there it is over there.
Okay.
Where's the grabby grab?
But we'll start seeing them.
We'll start seeing them.
Alright.
Be brave, Minto.
I'm not really that brave, you guys.
You seem to mostly fear the unknown.
I fear a lot of the...
I just...
I fear Murphy.
I fear.
I fear...
I can't find the grabby grab so I might have to just do...
Wait a second.
Did I see...
Oh no.
This is where we went.
Yeah.
I just fear!
There they are.
They're walking.
They're already heading over.
Uh...
Wait.
Here we go.
Do you think they'll see me from over here?
Do you fear me now?
Never.
But...
I can't tell if they see me or not.
Are they...
Oh.
I just felt my controller rumble which means that a lec...
Whatever thing that happened here just happened.
Okay.
They're gone.
They're not gone.
You think they'll see me?
Look at them!
Wow!
Ooh!
Ring, ring, ring, ring, ring, ring...
Ring, ring, ring, ring, ring...
They see me.
That's me walking.
So they know, they think I'm one of them, right?
They think I'm one of them, probably.
Probably.
Oh boy.
You're kinda short.
Act natural.
I'm acting natural, I'm acting natural, I'm acting natural.
I'm just gonna have to follow him, I think.
As they say, there's no fear, but the fear of tigers.
Has she made any progress?
That's so rude!
I have made progress!
What are you talking about?
I've made progress, right guys?
I think I'm on their pathway.
Uh oh.
Time to go.
Don't fall too close behind.
Okay, here we go, here we go.
I'm one of you guys!
You rude!
I was here for the show!
I just wanted to see you!
Not invited.
Oh my god!
You finally did so good!
Thank you!
Didn't buy a ticket.
Yeah, they're really cute, actually.
I thought, like, I thought something scarier would happen.
They were really confused, though.
They were like, um...
What the hell?
They were really confused, I think.
Can I go back?
You think they'll let me in this time?
Hey, I'm... I'm back, man!
Private party.
Literally, the jazz music stops me.
Think they'll let me in this time, or...
But, like, I don't think there's anything I can really explore in there, because they'll...
They're gonna be walk... They're just gonna get me again.
So I think I have to go past...
And go to the next floor.
I'm just one of you guys.
I don't remember where the entrance was.
Uh-oh.
I'm gonna get got.
Don't get me, please.
I'm one of you guys.
Come into your meeting.
I have your little candle and everything, okay?
They're just jealous I'm alive.
Mm-hmm.
Breathe on their lantern.
That's so messed up.
You are alive?
In the game.
Sorry.
Oh, I forgot.
Alright, to the tower we go.
Oh, jeez.
Okay, to the tower we go, everybody.
Okay.
Let's get around this little tree here.
There is that other tree that has, like...
I haven't seen, like, such a tree here.
Mysterious.
Everything is so mysterious.
Oh, I was trying to avoid this rock, but, you know...
Okay.
Oh!
Unless... wait, it was... hold on.
It was in this tower, wasn't it?
No...
Like, where we saw it was what I mean.
It's this one, right?
Yep.
What was in the tower?
The, um... the mural that we saw.
That may be a misremembering.
You mean the tree?
The tree mural, yeah.
Okay, goodnight.
So now that I know that they're not gonna be so mean to me...
They were so confused.
They were just staring like...
It's kind of funny.
Oh yeah, here we can go.
That's right.
Ignore you.
There was the burnt house down here.
Fear conquered.
I wouldn't quite say that, but, you know, I'm doing my best.
Okay.
Let's try and go to the...
left side this time.
I know from here that I can...
Okay, I think we're good.
Let's try going...
Wait, will it let me go?
I don't think...
I think I can only steer it back and forward this way and this way.
Yeah, so I can't like...
take it to another spot.
Just imagine a random alien showing up in a...
They're all just staring at me.
Okay, so we're back here at the burnt mural.
Anything else here of significance?
We have this thing up here.
The boat is on rails.
Ah, that makes sense.
Like, what is...
This!
Before...
It's like...
It's almost like a...
binocular.
There's nothing else over here, actually.
I'm looking around.
No!
Hmm.
Yeah, binoculars.
I kept wanting to say magnifying glass.
Magnifying glass for far things away.
But I can't use it.
Too short.
Okay.
Whatever.
I think that's the only stuff over around here.
Oh.
Maybe.
Possibly.
Okay.
There is something else.
There is?
Smelloscope.
There's something else here?
You were just by it!
I was?
Who?
Blind Minto.
I keep almost falling into the water.
This thing.
Ah!
I didn't realize it could open!
Oh!
What?
What does this mean?
This tiny flower is producing...
Well, I say tiny.
This flower is producing galaxies.
Okay.
What?
Yeah, see?
There's the eye symbols.
Yeah, they also liked that.
It's really interesting.
That these guys have the same symbol for the eye and then Nonomai also have the same symbol for the eye.
I find that a little fascinating.
Wait.
Yeah.
Don't leave.
Very convenient.
I don't know if convenient is the word.
But, you know.
Yeah.
I can't go any further because of this rock.
So, let's go.
Is this the thing that goes off?
Here we go.
Nice.
Well, then.
Let's explore as much and more that we can before we get kicked out.
There's a hand.
Yeah.
Let's go to the other side.
I can't remember exactly everything that we hit on this area.
But, I do know that there's something here.
I do know how...
I do want...
I do know we need to get down there.
Oh, that's where we can...
Oh.
Maybe that's how we get down there.
Okay.
Loop done.
Let's go meditate.
Okay.
Let's meditate.
You know what?
We'll meditate in the water.
It's always so spooky how the world turns sideways before we know, right?
So funny.
I gotta go to the bathroom and I'm gonna go check on my cat, if that's okay?
With you guys?
He's been eating a little bit more, so...
But I've just been checking on him.
He's been mostly kind of laying under the bed.
So I've just been kind of leaving him alone.
I have a doctor's appointment for him tomorrow.
And I...
How can I give you some music before I go fishing?
I don't wanna waste the time.
You know what?
I'll just waste the time.
You guys can have the music.
And the ASMR.
And then we'll just reset.
When I'm back.
Okay.
I'll be right back.
Okay, I fed him.
And I went to the bathroom.
And I forgot to get more tea.
So I'm gonna go get more tea.
And then I'll be back for realsies.
Then I'll be back for realsies.
Okay.
Give me like two more minutes.
Winky Splanky.
Okay.
Who's gonna win?
What are you talking about?
Okay.
You guys.
What's going on?
I went into...
Into...
What's the word mode?
There we go.
Okay.
Meditate.
Welcome back, boys.
Thank you.
Are you winning, Min?
I think so.
I'm gonna start by picking at a walkthrough.
Okay, I'll be...
I'm gonna have 100% transparency here.
I didn't look at a walkthrough.
But I asked a friend to look at a walkthrough.
I was like, okay, can you look at a walkthrough and just give me a hint?
Don't tell me the answer.
I have to...
I have to look at the...
And they...
They didn't.
If anything, they did.
Really?
They were just like, I don't know where you're at.
I was like, no, just like... I was like, just look for...
I was like, look for something that says the hidden vault seal.
And they were like, I don't know.
I can't find anything.
I was like, don't tell me the answer.
Just give me like a one word hint.
What I should do.
And so... Mint, that's cheating.
I didn't get any help, so...
You know...
Let's go back to the Starlit Cove.
I give up on the show.
For now, at least.
I want to have more time at the Cove.
She tried to cheat.
No, I didn't try to cheat.
I just wanted a little hint because you guys weren't giving me anything.
You guys weren't giving me anything.
I'm so... I'm so lost.
We're going to be here all day.
That's okay.
We're going to be here all day, you guys.
All day.
I have to wake up so early for my cat, but you guys don't care.
You're just like, no help.
You guys are like, doesn't matter.
No help.
To the tower, to the tower.
Ask chat to be...
The hint is explore more.
Well, that's what I'm doing.
We're going to the tower to explore some more.
Since I also don't have the... Well, I maybe... I'm not going to say anything because I will eat my words.
You know what?
Never mind.
I'm just going to shut up.
Just going to shut up.
Oh, the artifact.
I think we can get one over here as well.
Right?
Oh, wait.
No, I don't think we can.
Oh, you guys, I think I just messed up.
Wait, I think I just remembered that there's no artifact.
Yeah, there's no artifact here, is there?
Okay,
we're going to another place.
There's one in the tower hidden room.
Just kidding, we're not going to another place.
Turn around, turn around.
Oh, the water is too strong.
Wait, the water is really strong here.
Oh, here we go, here we go.
I think slowly but surely we can do it.
Come on, come on, come on, team.
Come on, team.
Team, team, team, team.
There we go, there we go.
Power, power, power.
Power, power, power, power, power.
This way, this way.
Slowly but surely we're making it.
Oh, I don't know if we can make it.
Whatever.
Secret room.
Wait, it's not?
Which secret room?
The one down there?
Did I get one guide?
For realsies?
Did you just one guide me?
Why are you spreading lies on the internet?
Why are you spreading lies?
The meditative shame.
Why are you spreading lies on the internet?
How could you do that?
How could you say that and then feel good about yourself?
That's what you get for reading chat?
I don't think it's very...
Okay, come on.
I don't think it's...
Telling me where an artifact is is not the same as telling me how to do a puzzle.
It's completely different.
To the stranger.
Whoa, we're moving sideways.
Ha ha.
Me after spreading misinformation?
I think it means streamer.
I just made it so that the streamer...
had to do something and then go out of there way, and then it didn't matter in the end.
I just disrupted the stream and I made my mark in this stream forever.
I just disrupted the streamer and they're angry about it.
I just made them angry.
Perfect.
I think the streamer is going to have a horrible day after this.
I think the streamer is going to think about this all night.
The streamer is going to be thinking about me and how much I give them the wrong information.
I think I'm going to do it again next week.
You.
Your inconvenience is nourishment.
Get in there.
There we go.
Minecraft rules.
Real laugh.
Oh my goodness.
There we go.
Alright.
Let's get out of here.
Skedaddle-addle.
She's so obsessed with me now.
Give the streamer wrong information once.
I'll be obsessed with you forever.
Wait.
Oh.
This way.
We're going to the tower.
I don't feel like going to the show anymore.
I have to go back to the show though, don't I?
Eventually, I have to go back to the show.
This is a terrible place to leave.
Okay.
Don't stop, please.
Push.
You got it.
No!
This way.
I like when the music starts back up.
Like I know I'm doing something correct.
Okay.
No, no, no.
Ouch.
Okay.
That's fine.
Just get me out of here.
What is wrong with this boat?
It's defective.
And don't say it's the driver.
It's the driver.
I said not to say that.
It's the captain.
Stop.
It's the streamer.
It's the steersman.
There's still this hole.
Wait a second.
I'm picking up something else.
My bad.
Okay.
Good night, everybody.
I feel really like we're all close friends now.
But they're not zombies at all.
They were very much alive guys.
They looked pretty cute.
Just like the pictures.
Also, how do I get down here?
Hmm.
Yeah, I thought they were pretty cute.
You didn't think so?
Okay.
Get up.
Also, when I jumped from here, the alarm went off, so we're gonna have to not get caught again.
We're gonna have to be sneaky about the boat controls.
In IT, we have an acronym for a common bug.
HEC-KAC.
The problem is it exists because it's a chair and keyboard.
Oh, what are you trying to say?
You think he's in here?
So then, what are you trying to say?
There's a thing there.
Okay.
They're probably like, hey man, you can't open up the thing.
I'm like being such a nuisance here.
Oh, I thought it would open the door.
I'm being such a nuisance here, being like, I'm just gonna open your safe that you clearly don't want people using.
They're like, hey, don't do that.
I'm like, too bad.
I'm gonna do what I want.
I'm an alien.
Hold on.
There was another light.
Let me light that one too.
Let's see what happens.
Oh, my controller just rumbled.
So I believe that electricity thing just happened.
Hmm.
She forgor.
What did I forgor?
I don't have like my little guy anymore.
I don't have my little scout anymore to shoot through.
She knows, she just doesn't remember.
I don't remember.
Does anyone want to give me a...
What did I forgor?
I did, actually.
I don't remember at all.
What did I forgor?
No elf, but it's something I knew before.
This is so unfair.
Why are you guys like this?
I already knew.
Are these the flowers?
Oh, yes.
Yes.
Because the light, the door is always open when there's no light.
I remember.
Shut up.
Shut up, shut up, shut up.
Wait a second.
Oh, my god.
Tower stuff.
Oh,
my god.
We're finally here.
Oh, my god.
Is this where...
Oh, this is really, really tall.
There's not going to be anyone here though, right?
I think I have to extinguish these.
Good night, sweet prince.
Oh, oopsie.
Hahaha.
I think I extinguish these and then I go back to the other world.
But also, what's up here?
Oh.
It's just the same.
Yeah.
Look at you guys.
Drawing things with sunlight.
Wait, what did that say?
Oh, drop artifact.
No, we're good.
Okay.
So that's how you get here.
I cheese this part.
What do you mean you cheese this part?
How do you cheese this?
How do you cheese this at all?
But now we have the seals, right?
But hold on.
Before we jump into the water, I have something I want to do.
Tool flip.
Hold on.
Oh, here.
There is something else on this side.
Is it a boat?
Okay.
This.
Does this create a boat?
It does.
Okay, never mind.
I don't need no boat.
Mint changed her name?
I changed my name?
Who am I now?
Wait, no.
I'm Minto.
What do you mean?
I changed my name.
Okay.
I think we have to...
Good morning, gamers.
Alright, see you suckers.
I don't know why I can jump out there, but I can't jump here.
Okay.
Into the secret.
Tunnel?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, we're gonna get the passwords, right?
Maybe?
And then...
What location was it?
To unlock...
Oh, it was inside the thing.
Yeah, inside the bell.
Okay.
Open!
Uh-oh.
Wow!
Thank you.
Open.
Oh, come on!
No, no.
You guys suck!
Oh, we're leaning.
We're leaning, guys.
We're leaning.
Wait, which one was this one for?
Oh, wait.
We've been here.
This one, though.
We know this cave.
It did a shiplog, but I'm screencapping it, too.
I'm screencapping it so that when we go back to the cave, I know what to do.
Okay, take a picture.
Okay.
New info!
Can we even make it there, though?
Oh, you sons of...
This is fine.
This is good.
This is fun.
This is fun, everybody.
This is okay.
I told you.
We're literally just messing up the... They're like, hey, we really... Like, it's bad...
It's bad news bears if anybody messes with, uh...
If anybody messes with this thing, and I'm just like, I don't care!
And I do it anyway.
Oh, wait.
I can see the sun from here still.
Hmm.
Interesting.
I thought we wouldn't be able to see the sun anymore.
Okay.
Um, let's go down, down, down by the river.
It would be...
Here, right?
This is where the cave is at.
I need that.
I need that boat.
Do you think we can make it?
Yeah, we can make it.
I can make it.
Oh, I'm trapped in the boat.
Hold on.
Boat, boat, boat, boat, boat.
Boat, boat.
There we go.
Nice.
Go, go, go!
Cave was at the third area.
This area right here, then.
Instead.
This one.
No.
That's not this one, is it?
Maybe we can check.
We're right here.
Oh, the right side!
Are you sure?
Oh, yes!
Okay, we're going to loop.
We're going to loop around.
Because...
I do want to try and get this if we can.
We have a little extra time.
Push, push, push, push.
Push, push.
Wait, too much push, push!
Push!
Because...
I'd like to...
Try and get it.
We're making progress, guys.
We're making progress.
Push, push.
Yeah, this is the...
This is the one that has the little...
The artifact thing.
You guys pushing me in the right direction.
Eek!
When I...
Wait!
Come back!
Okay.
When I need it.
Okay, okay.
To the right.
That way.
Artifact is right here.
We got him.
Don't worry.
Right here.
Actually, I'm gonna hold on to him just in case we lose our boat.
For some reason.
Okay.
Stop.
You're being too pushy.
That's what you're supposed to...
That's what Oshi means!
Push!
That's exactly what Oshi means!
A push!
Okay.
We got this.
Oh yeah.
Oh...
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Go!
This way.
I don't even know if we can get inside it anymore, because everything's destroyed, but... oh.
The elevator might work.
We might be okay.
The elevator...
The elevator might work.
Still.
I think it works.
Yeah!
We're fine!
Let's see...
Yeah!
I'm gonna Oshi my Oshi off this road.
Getting a little violent here.
It's okay.
You're just excitable.
I get it.
Getting over to the other side...
I think we can make it.
Here we go.
Nice.
Big flip.
Okay, okay, okay.
Now what's so curious about this part is...
I don't remember...
Anything that looked like...
I just never went over to the side.
Wait a second!
This is how you get over here?
This whole time?
We could have done it so easily?
Stop.
It's not done yet, right?
No, no, no.
No, no, I just made it here.
Please.
No, no, no, no.
Please, I just made it.
Please!
No, please!
Hold on, I'm pulling up my picture.
Resume, resume, resume.
Okay.
Use the interface.
This one.
Down!
Saturn!
You!
Down!
Star, star, star, star!
Star!
What's going on?
What's happening?
Oh!
An elevator.
Lift it.
No, no, no, no, no!
I just made it here!
Please!
Go down!
Ship log.
Updated.
Wait, what is this?
What does this mean?
Okay.
I still have a couple of seconds.
Oh, I'm getting hurt?
Wait, what's happening?
Oh, I'm just in the light.
That's what it is.
Huh?
Updating.
What does...
Huh?
In past loops you looked at the ghost matter and instantly assumed you couldn't get past.
Yeah, that sounds about right.
Oh!
There's a thingy in here!
I'll come back.
Next round.
I'll come back, everybody.
Unless...
No, we don't have time.
There it is.
Am I right at the top?
It's kind of fun.
Hmm.
But now we can get there so easily.
I'm wondering...
I used...
I can probably bring the artifact now that I know how to get around the ghost matter.
So...
Nice.
Is he good?
Yeah.
I'll put some of my throat stuff in it.
That's what they mean.
Oh la la la la.
Wow.
Holy moly.
Secret.
A map I found in the abandoned temple reveals a secret location.
Somewhere within the stranger.
Oh!
But you're not gonna show me?
Okay, we're gonna have to go screenshot those points, I think.
Oh wait, here we go.
Thank goodness.
Projection that seems to reveal a secret location within the stranger.
Meet a secret stranger...
Yep.
Too much progress for the voice.
Secret ope- Secret location?
Symbol room, a secret room filled with wooden containers marked with different symbols.
Three of the containers are marked with glowing vault seals, but their contents have been burned away.
I opened the container marked with the symbol of a burning slide reel, Yup, and then we use that.
They all say the same thing, I'm just trying to...
There is?
Oh, that's how we did the...
Okay, yes.
That's how we did the elevator.
Duh.
Entering the correct sequence opens a path to a secret room beneath the temple.
There was some stuff upstairs.
I guess that's what we didn't get.
And then we have all these secret locations to go to.
So that's exciting.
Yippee.
Yippee yippee.
Okay.
I will not make this mistake again.
And the slide reel.
Yes, the slide reel.
Thank you.
Yes, we need that.
That probably is what the... is saying is remaining, right?
So we'll go look at the slide reel.
We'll go...
We'll go there first, for sure.
And I think I'm... since we'll be there, I'm gonna...
You can kind of see them in the...
In the logs, but since we won't have...
I won't memorize them.
And since we won't have the ship...
I'll just... I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna screenshot them.
Hello.
I would like to do a tumble.
Okay.
Awesome.
I know that there's like an easier way to get there, but...
I really didn't want to go through the little hole.
It's kind of obnoxious, so...
And I can't...
Well, actually, I guess we could...
Well, I'd have to open it.
It's fine.
Everything's fine, you guys.
It's all good.
I like the river.
Me too.
I like the river also.
Okay.
I'm gonna grab the artifact just in case I need it.
Because this is probably the easiest one to get, so...
Well, I'm playing along with my own spooky game right now.
And this DLC is spooky.
We really hit a fun point in the game, though.
I believe in us...
Baby's got this.
We got this!
Thanks, Carl!
Carl!
Yeah,
it's good to just grab it, I think.
And have it on hand.
The bow is...
ISO code.
Baby's strong.
This is Baby Nation.
Babies, rise up.
Babies?
If you're a baby, say Goo Goo Gaga.
All my babies in the chat!
Goo Goo Gaga!
Yeah!
Gosh, I really can just get you guys to say anything, can't I?
Oh my god, look at all these eggs!
Baby maxing.
No!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
This way, this way, this way.
This way, this way.
Yes, streamer.
You take me for a fool.
I take you for a baby.
Goo Goo Gaga.
T.L.
God, bitches.
I don't think that's what a baby would say.
Don't be unrealistic.
Only realism in my streams, please.
Thank you.
I don't want to set some weird standards for babies.
Goo Goo Gaga.
I want...
I want milk.
Um, please talk to your mom about that.
Woo.
Whoop, whoop, whoop, whoop.
Goo Goo Gaga.
This is the ghost.
Ghosts are real and I'm proof of it.
Obviously.
Do you sometimes think of your wisps as your babies?
Never, even once.
I've never, ever, once even thought that.
But that's okay.
I've never once thought, aw, my little precious babies.
Only realism.
Ah, a ghost.
Get the exorcist.
No!
I'm a good ghost.
Shits diaper.
This is the projection room, right?
So we'll have to come back here to see that.
Oh, I was like what is down there?
Literally where we just came from.
So they stopped.
They were like, abandoned the eye.
We don't believe in the eye anymore.
We believe in the burned reels.
They were like, the eye sucks.
Screw the eye.
It's burned reels time.
That's where it's all...
I thought I remembered.
Anyway.
We're fine.
Yeah, burned reels is where it's at, everybody.
I like the music here.
It's very cool.
Oh...
Dog...
Oh!
Look at that!
Oh, how handy!
There's a shortcut!
Glad I checked up here.
OK.
Use the interface.
You, Saturn.
You, you...
What's happening again?
Oh, we're gonna need the real...
Oopsie.
It's fine, though.
OK.
Let's pick up the lanterns.
This doesn't really help that much either, though.
Does it?
There was like...
A better one.
A better way to see...
Hold on.
Probably through the...
Through here, we'll see it better, right?
Let's... Hold on.
You want to screenshot these?
Give me one second.
We're gonna have to come back for the...
For the artifact, anyway.
Hmm...
Insert.
And let's go get this guy right here.
Signal scope can zoom.
Oh!
You're so right!
Then we'll do that.
Just give me one second.
Let's see.
Let's look at this first.
Because it might give us a...
Also zoomed in on here.
And so...
If it dies, we can just screenshot it from here.
Oh!
Worship.
Oh.
They sink it.
Then they look at the camera.
Look at that.
One guy is really happy.
Oh!
This is like not your best angle.
But that's OK.
They're like...
Yeah!
Screw the eye!
We're gonna go burn all these!
Erase history!
He's like...
Whoa!
There's gotta be a method to our madness.
This one?
Wait.
What the hell is this?
They're sinking the egg.
It's saved.
Oh!
I think they...
Save the information?
Oh!
They're saving the information, maybe?
Unarchived karaoke deletes browser history.
Real!
Nah!
OK.
Interesting.
So where the hell do we find that thing?
Maybe...
That thingamabob...
Is in...
Well...
OK.
Up here.
I can't quite tell if...
What these locations are about.
Are they of that thingamabob?
Or are they of the places where they burn the...
The reels?
Scant eclipse channel.
OK.
Signal scope, right?
I...
It zooms in way too much.
Because now I'm like...
I don't even know what the heck...
Where the heck that is.
OK.
Hold on.
Is that an egg?
OK, guys.
I think I found the egg for real.
Then back up.
Shut up.
Stop using logic against me.
OK?
Stop being sensible.
I don't like that.
I actually have no idea where this is.
Wait.
Is this like a secret?
Secret!
Oh my gosh!
Print screen.
Hold on.
Paint.
Paste.
OK.
Next.
This one is pretty easy.
I'd say.
I don't even...
This one is right by...
Yeah.
This one is right at the beginning.
So I'm just going to print screen.
F12.
Hi, you guys.
I'm...
I...
I put everything into paint.
I'm...
I'm just going to keep creating.
I know it.
Probably drives people crazy.
But you know what?
At least I'm not Matara.
Who gazo's everything.
This one is...
Zoom in.
RB.
RB?
Wait, why isn't it?
It's equipped?
Why isn't it zooming in?
Equipped?
RB.
It's not zooming in for some reason.
OK.
Why?
Uh, I'm trying to see which this is.
I can't tell.
Print screen, Ctrl-R, MS Paint, Enter, Ctrl-V, Master Race.
Oh no, it's a bug!
Uh-oh.
Okay, hold on.
But this is where we're at, actually.
Now that I think about it, right?
This is where we're at.
So there's a hidden room.
I'm guessing, right?
This is where we're at, I think.
It's a known bug.
You guys know everything!
How do you guys know so much?
How do you guys know everything?
Jeffrey told us.
Oh.
You guys know everything.
Hold on.
Um, wait.
Uh-oh.
I'm really slow and I can't put down the artifact.
Wait, I'm really slow?
And I can't put down the artifact?
No, no!
But I can still rotate this.
I'm just gonna be a little slow, guys.
Press RB.
RB doesn't work!
Uh-oh.
RB's stuck.
RB's stuck!
Oh my god, I'm really...
I'm really slow.
I always press...
I always press like where circle is because I'm so used to playing...
dang metal gear.
Okay, hold on.
Um...
Ah...
RB.
Where are we?
How do I...
Hold on.
I did it again.
What can I set it to?
How can I set it?
Maybe that worked?
We're fixed!
I just reset everything.
Which I didn't change anything before either, so we're good.
Okey-dokey.
Let's get out of here.
Oh, there's one in here!
There's been one in here this whole time.
Okay, so...
If I'm looking at this picture, it's in this tower here.
But...
Right there.
Hmm.
Oh my god!
Why?
Why do you have to frighten me so?
Oh, I thought it would stop halfway through.
I thought it would stop halfway through and so I could...
Nope.
Hmm.
Let's see.
How can we get in here?
I have to go back up.
Oh, gosh.
I don't know if
the building was going to come down or not.
Holy moly.
Okay.
Let's go downstairs.
So, right there.
And down a little bit more.
Ah.
Oh.
Yolo.
I think I went too far down.
Oh, we're exactly where we were before.
And with no elevator.
Oh.
Goodness.
Hmm.
Okay.
Hold on.
Let's...
Oh.
It's going to be such a pain in the butt getting over there again.
Ouch.
We're all good.
Everything's fine.
We're going to figure this out.
We're going to figure this out, guys.
Let's see.
I'm looking at it.
Okay.
You know what?
It's so funny.
I never know...
I'm...
I guess I never noticed that part before.
Hmm.
Could have brought the elevator back down.
No, no.
I could not because it was broken.
No, no, no.
No.
What if I like launch my...
I see.
Oh.
I can't...
I can't equip my launch scouter.
I can't equip my scouter.
My RB is still broken.
I'm going to have to restart the game maybe.
Okay.
Oh, no.
I just wanted to...
I wanted to...
Rebind it.
Equipment.
Retrieve.
Scout.
There's only retrieve.
Okay.
Primary action.
No.
It's not primary interact.
Hmm.
Primary action tool.
Oh?
Use the mouse.
It's such a pain in the butt though.
Huh.
Primary tool interaction.
Wait.
Where do you guys see that?
Oh.
Here.
Thank you.
Okay.
Oh.
How do I rebind that?
If I...
If I press it, it like...
Okay.
Here we go.
There we go.
Okay.
I just really should stop.
Uh -huh.
Aha-ha-ha.
See?
The dang elevator could stop here.
It just chooses not to.
Hmm.
Now if I...
Shoot it...
Like here.
It got the most ideal way to see it.
Wait.
Where is it?
Okay, there's... I don't see any way to go in from the bottom.
I was seeing if I could fly up from the bottom or something.
Do I just have to be good at flying?
Do I just have to be good?
Do I just have to be really smooth with this?
Oh!
Oh, I can't get in there!
Let me see from down... Oh no, I should have at least brought the elevator down.
Okay.
Well, I guess that makes things a bit easier.
Tell the elevators who's boss.
Yeah, see if I want to bring the elevator back down, the thing is broken.
And it always has been, so...
All the way back.
Here we go again.
Peek-a-boo!
It looks like... It looks like...
Oh yeah.
Is that a tree?
Yeah.
It looks like this one is like more broken than this one, but I don't think it is.
I think it's the same... Yeah, it's the same amount.
I don't know if I can fit in there.
Bring... skillshot the scout to the elevator and bring it down?
Holy cow, that would be insane.
Insane, right?
Gotta be clever, Mint?
I'm... I'm clever!
I'm kashikoi.
I'm, you know...
Hold on!
Yeah, we can't fit through there.
What's another way to be clever?
Does it involve the elevator?
Because, I mean, I could... Pew!
I could skillshot it, right?
Like...
No?
Too high, too high.
Dang it.
No.
He... He... Here!
Just kidding.
Oh my gosh.
It's like the most precise thing that I'm ever doing ever.
I'm really thinking.
I'm really processing.
That's why I tried with the elevator before.
Hmm.
But maybe I just didn't do it correctly.
So...
I'm seeing smileys.
Is someone...
spoiling?
No spoiling, you guys.
Oh, no, no.
Get on here.
Oh.
Time's up, everybody.
Time's up.
Well, it's okay because we have the other ones as well.
I only went to this one first because...
we were here.
Hmm.
Think in the box.
Bro didn't even let us listen to the banger?
Why the soundtrack?
Oh, we're on a mission.
Oh, it wasn't spoils but backseats that could feel spoilery.
Oh, that's...
Oh, thanks guys.
I appreciate it.
No backseating until I'm really like...
Help me!
And then only give a little hints.
Little tiny hints.
I don't think it's...
Yeah.
I was gonna say, I don't think we got anything else, truly.
Well, no.
I mean, we saw...
I guess it's this.
These are the...
Oh, this area I wanna go to so...
badly.
This secret area.
I wanna go so badly.
Come here.
New secret.
We gotta be so vague it doesn't even make sense.
Here we go.
Meow.
Okay.
We are inside the stranger.
Which...
Take me out to dinner first.
Oh my goodness.
That's what the stranger is saying right now.
He's like...
Yeah, I barely even know you.
Okay.
Roll.
There we go.
Perfect.
It's a beautiful sunny day.
I'm stuck on...
I'm gonna grab the artifact.
I'm gonna grab the artifact first, though.
Again, just in case.
Just in case.
Where are you going?
To where the tower is?
Stranger.
I already know her!
Oh...
I completely...
Caught me...
Off guard!
Which is why...
I can see that.
There...
Nothing.
This is why it's so funny!
You're laughing too hard at this one.
You're not laughing hard enough.
Oh man!
That was a good one.
I think it's because... oh god.
I think it's because I've only ever heard people do it correctly.
And so when it's like...
You know.
Okay, okay, okay.
Over there, over there, over there.
Is this it?
Wait, yeah.
Is it?
This is it.
Okay.
This way.
You're giving me tears in my eyes.
Hello?
Over here?
This is it, right?
That looks like...
That's the egg!
That's the egg.
Hopefully I didn't...
Need to...
Uh oh.
Wait.
Let's see.
Okay.
Huh?
Nice.
And it's...
Hold on.
I'm checking my screenshot.
It's in the trees.
So it's...
It's basically where I'm at, right?
Here?
In here?
Hello?
Is it in the water?
No.
Do I hop up here?
Hold on, let me...
Oh gosh, you guys!
My RB is broken again!
No way!
I just realized.
My RB is broken again.
Uh oh.
I might actually have to restart my game.
No!
Unplug, replug the controller.
It's a... It's a wireless controller.
Jeff said to toggle active controller on off again.
Okay.
Oh.
I was like, wait a second.
I can't move it!
Okay, there we go!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
I hope you guys don't think that, like, you know...
If I get a...
A bug, I'm like, oh my god!
How dare!
I don't really care.
Like, it doesn't bother me.
No!
I fell!
Is there another way in?
Let's see.
Is my boat still here?
Uh...
Nope.
She's long gone.
Wait.
It's pretty obvious, don't worry.
Oh, so you're saying I'm stupid, huh?
You're saying I'm a dummy, huh?
Is that what you're saying?
You're saying, wow, Minto's so stupid.
No, I'm just... Yeah.
That's what you're saying, right?
That scared me so much!
Oh god, it happened right as I jumped in!
Oh!
I think I found it.
So why are all of these ones destroyed?
The thing...
The thingy...
Oh.
What a lovely portrait.
I had a feeling it would move.
Oh!
Whoa!
It looks like eyes are staring at me.
It's so freaky.
Hello?
Who locked me in?
I'm a
good Minto, I promise!
Oh god!
Wait a second.
What's over here?
Uh...
Anyway...
Rude as hell.
I'm taking this back.
And I'm...
I didn't know that I was going to fall through.
Okay?
Left the real.
I didn't know that I was going to be...
You know...
I guess we don't need the artifact.
For now.
This leads to...
This room.
Okay.
I have...
Something I wish to view.
What if this is how we had to watch anime?
Um...
Now I need to find a place for...
The lantern?
Which is...
Uh...
Oh, the tower.
The tower had a ton of...
A ton of...
Nineteen eight...
Eighteen nineties anime.
Yeah, exactly.
We're old school.
We're retro here.
That's how you have to watch VTubers.
I'm going to have all my...
Streams in stop motion.
From now on.
Let's
go onward.
Where did we come from?
That one right there?
Right?
Yeah.
Claymation.
Every stream...
In five frames per second?
Good luck everybody.
Figuring out what's going on.
Oh...
Okay...
We got a little more...
They're doing something with the seal?
This is...
This is where the eye temple was!
That's the binoculars!
Wait, what the hell are they holding?
Okay...
We've been here.
Oh!
Hello my friend.
Oh.
He gives him the tablet.
Bye!
We go back.
There's a secret!
Crabby crab!
And then he goes down.
Oh my gosh, this is giving us so much information.
Oh my god!
Okay!
Wait a second.
So once he goes down, the lights come back on.
So that's what turns off the lights!
When you think about it, clips are just the Vtuber equivalent of watching an episode of Ranma half...
Ranma half in...
In 10 minutes chunks on YouTube.
I do...
What is he doing here?
He's just chilling.
Okay...
But I still haven't figured out a way down to the hole.
Which is the issue, I think.
Oh no.
I think as soon as I do that, two of the guys are going to start walking around more.
Aren't they?
Oh, right now they're upstairs, but as soon as I do that, they're probably all going to come running.
Okay.
Oh, shucks.
Unless they start descending themselves.
And then I follow them like before.
We do need a cardboard box.
Okay, so that was one.
Or rather...
two.
Part two.
The dam still hasn't broken, but like literally any second now it's probably going to...
Look at that thing.
That thing is about to blow!
Holy hell, we're watching Interstellar.
So the other one was at...
Sorry, I'm checking my map.
So we have the one inside that...
building I'm trying to get to.
Oh, and the one at the very beginning.
Which is like right around...
here.
Which I don't think we're going to make it.
It's going to become flooded.
In like two seconds.
Do you remember why you couldn't go down the hole?
Because I died.
Because I dropped down...
I couldn't find an entrance, rather.
I haven't been able to find an entrance yet.
I dropped down and I broke my legs.
Okay.
I don't think we're going to make it.
But...
I think it's going to become flooded.
We could try.
But what killed you?
Oh, it was the alarm.
I do know that.
Or rather, I don't know if the alarm is what killed me or if I died by my own...
silliness.
You know?
I could not tell you.
I don't have like an artifact or anything.
I have nothing with me.
I've got nothing on my property.
Is stream a little stuttery?
Honestly, for me, streams have been so awful on YouTube.
I like the music here.
This is so relaxing.
Stream looks good today?
Streams are like in general...
Like I'll be watching someone and like...
It's almost impossible to watch them.
But I'm glad that it's okay.
I think it's probably because I'm using Firefox with like an ad blocker.
And they're like, um, can you stop that?
Oh my gosh, I didn't realize it would take me...
Ah!
The house is like right here.
Oh god.
We made it.
Oh, the house was here.
Wait, have I never noticed that?
What is that thing?
Oh I think it's...
Huh.
Is it just a bell?
Is it just like a decoration?
Yeah, maybe it's just a decoration.
Oh, really?
Okay, good to know for the future.
Oh, there it is!
There it is!
The other house we need to get to.
Okay, I think we might...
be able to still do it.
We'll see.
Who knows?
Maybe we had to wait this whole time to do it, to get in there, right?
It is this house, though.
I think.
Right?
Do-do-do-do-do-do.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Do-do-do-do.
Do-do-do-do-do.
Oh!
It's this pla... wait.
Okay, so that first one was like super obvious.
Can I rotate you, please?
Oh, it's stuck.
Never mind.
That's the raft house.
There's our raft!
Oh, dang.
Okay, hold on.
I'm looking at the picture again.
I'm zooming in.
I think we might just have to meditate to get to it.
Or to do it.
What is this?
I think we'll have to meditate.
Let's take it.
Wait, because it's like right...
Hold on.
I'm trying.
Down here.
Or something.
I think?
I'm getting pushed away.
Hmm.
Blah-blah-blah-blah-blah-blah-blah.
Because there's like a bridge that I'm seeing.
Like, you see this place.
This is the place.
Yeah, you see this place.
And then...
You see...
There's a bridge.
Hmm...
Okay, I meditate.
I give up.
I'm not going to fight the current.
Okay.
Blah-blah-blah-blah-blah-blah-blah-blah-blah-blah-blah.
I tried to do this while flooded.
Might be a bit hard.
Okay.
Good to know.
Good to know I probably made the right decision then.
And it's right at the entrance.
We'll be fine.
I love meditating.
And then...
We'll have this one.
And then also...
Did our...
Oh, our ship log did update.
Beep-beep.
Sec...
Oh, secret well.
Yes.
Well, it's...
It's like the...
Not really a secret.
The real I found in the slide burning room shows a container marked with a symbol glowing being handed to a shadowy figure.
The lights are extinguished and the figure carries the container down a dark well.
The room...
A room full of burned slide rails piled next to a strange device.
Am I able to use the device ever?
Or is it just not a thing?
I love meditating in bed with my eyes closed.
I call it sleeping.
Right.
I love sleeping too.
I found a hidden slide reel that shows a container marked with a glowing symbol being handed to a shadowy figure.
The lights are extinguished and the figure carries the container down into a dark well.
Yato Takoyaki.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
I pray to no sleep.
I'm in an open... invisible bed.
Freaky ghost bed.
Virtual!
Thanks for two months.
Gosh, I can't believe it's been over two months since I've been back.
It's kinda crazy.
Soon to be three, right?
Cause...
You know, I guess if you count April 1st...
Take it in!
Perfect.
Perfect landing.
Can't believe it's only been two months.
It's already...
been two months.
I have to use this to call Minto cute before he's gone.
Stop it!
4-4.
4-4 is...
It's funny because, you know, 4-4 is the day I stopped streaming.
Before.
And...
That is the day I returned to streaming, so it's just basically like...
Nothing ever changed, you know?
Nothing ever stopped.
Okay, hold on.
I'm looking at the picture real quick.
Oh, wrong picture.
Oh, here we go.
So there's this...
It's...
Behind all of this.
Oh, I see it!
I see it, I see it!
Okay.
Let's...
Oh...
Uh...
Happy Yuri Day?
No way.
Thank you.
Here we go.
Give me the real.
I turn around.
Don't be a little freak.
You better not be a freak when I turn around.
Ehehe.
Thank you.
Okay, now...
This one...
Oh, okay.
We have to...
I was gonna say...
This one is a little, you know...
A little more difficult, I'd say.
Wait, what did I put down?
I didn't have anything...
Did I?
Oh, the lantern.
Okay, we don't care.
We're good.
Two months?
Here's too many more.
Mint is cute.
Stop!
Oh, the lantern.
I love it!
What's over here?
How mysterious!
This is kind of fun.
Does this also lead to the projection room?
Which, if it does, we'll just go back for that lantern.
Yes.
Yippee!
Everything is like opening and closing.
What an inefficient... You could just go into anybody's house, honestly.
Where was the door?
Oh, here.
Nice!
Alright, let's go get the lantern from in here.
Now my contact is starting to bother me.
I got new contacts for my new prescription.
And they're like better quality, so that they're...
So that they keep my eyes moist.
But...
I have so many contacts of my other prescription, my older prescription, that I'm like, I have to use them, or else they'll go to waste.
But they make my eyes so dry.
I haven't even gotten the other ones, because I was supposed to have them before Japan, but...
They called me while I was in Japan.
Because I hadn't even arrived yet.
And now...
I came back and I had COVID, so I couldn't even go get them.
Okay.
The first...
On the first seal of...
Strangerville...
My true safe said to me...
Your RV isn't working.
No, don't go in reverse!
Don't go in reverse!
Wait, wait, wait.
Hold on.
I have to...
I have to reprogram it.
Why is it happening like this...
This time?
It's so weird.
Here, let me turn the active controller on and off again.
There we go.
Okay.
We got a grabby grab.
I don't...
Recognize this place as much.
There we go.
Pause...
Oh!
This is where they do the concert.
What the...
Bug feet.
No, it's okay.
Also...
It's the alt tab losing app focus thing.
That makes sense.
How am I supposed to do that one?
Okay.
Interesting.
All right.
Let's go figure out the final puzzle of the other thing.
Yeah.
How am I supposed to...
Just walk into the fire?
No, but how am I supposed to sneak past them?
Maybe if I walk into the fire...
Like, I kind of just stood there before.
I kind of just stood there and let them take me.
You know?
Maybe it wasn't my most proudest moment.
But then
I decided I was doing my best.
I think I just need to...
Um...
Come back!
Don't run me over!
Okay, we're good.
Everything's fine, you guys.
Town down.
I felt like that was...
I like, literally felt like a tumbleweed there, you know?
I'm so sad.
Okay.
Way to go!
Here we go.
Come on.
We're all good.
Yeah, just a couple of concussions.
Concussions for science, everybody.
Concussions are fine if you learn after them.
If you learn things because of your concussion.
It's all good.
This dang...
Confound it.
That hole's too small for me.
I'm a thick boy.
Yes, I learned English again.
If there's a hole, there's a way.
Something, something, hole, goal.
I get it.
I think outside
the box.
The only thing I can think of is involving an elevator.
There's not even a door to open.
Wait a second.
Whee!
I'm okay.
I did it.
And I didn't die.
Can you imagine if I had died there?
That would have been pretty embarrassing.
What's up here?
Okay, that's our secret tunnel.
Just minor leg damage.
That's our thing.
Oh, there's even like a...
Is that our way out?
If there's a freak, I'm gonna be...
a little upset.
Okay, so I probably have to...
launch the...
Oh.
I just have to guess.
Nice.
Guys, I'm a bit of a genius.
I'm a bit of a genius.
Gaming skill.
I know.
Genius.
I'm a genius idol.
What did you eat today?
What's your favorite book?
If you're going to play, where are you going?
You haven't eaten anything.
That's a secret.
Can't wait for season two.
I...
Yeah.
I'm...
I haven't read the manga, but I do have someone like...
like a friend that will kind of...
They'll be like, do you want a spoiler?
And I'm like, okay.
Usually...
Usually I would say no, but I wasn't sure if I was going to continue the series.
Actually...
Actually, wait.
Now that I think about it, I don't know at all what the second arc is about.
Is that friend Mata?
Why?
Is Mata always spoiling things to shows?
Okie dokie.
All right.
Where's our...
next...
thing?
The third.
Okay.
Very helpful.
They're just in pure darkness.
This is where they were doing the recital.
And then...
Shut up.
Oof.
He's taking it to the tree.
Never mind.
Yes.
Wow.
Wait.
That was in the tower.
Oh my goodness.
Okay.
That one we can do.
An invisible bridge.
Sleeping in your bed.
Okay.
Wait, though.
Hold on.
I'm thinking.
That's why the boats are so important.
Okay.
Because I was like, how do I get to the tower?
It was in the tower, right?
Oh my gosh.
Whoa.
This is...
Hold on.
This is a lot of...
Okay.
Oh, geez.
I might have to write like this step by step because...
Oh, goodness.
Okay.
Right.
No.
It was the lodge.
It was.
Oh, you're right.
It was the lodge, right?
Because...
We...
Sneaked past the guy and then we saw the mural in the basement.
Yes.
Okay.
Hello?
There it is.
Oh gosh.
That was spooky.
OBS disconnected for a second?
Everything good?
Everything alright?
You guys okay?
OBS.
OBS disconnected for a second.
Very spooky.
I don't remember where this one leads us to.
Small F.
Yes.
It is...
Oh my goodness.
That spooked me.
It's this one, right?
They're yelling?
Or they're dying?
I can't tell actually.
Maybe they're dying.
Maybe there are fires going out.
Wait, that means that they would be...
There wouldn't be any guys walking around then, right?
If there are fires go out...
Did I guess it?
Did I get it correct?
Maybe... genius?
Maybe...
Are you obsessed with me?
Let's see.
Well, this guy is still here.
This guy... What's your dealio?
He's watching the best 5 frames per second livestream of his life.
It's his favorite.
Okay, let's see.
I'm just happy.
Well, I guess we'll figure... We'll find out soon enough.
Right here.
No!
He's still going!
Interesting.
But someone's dying.
Someone is dead.
Oh, I don't know why I'm here just yet.
Because...
Okay, okay.
Hold on.
I don't even remember what the order was.
Can I jump down from here?
I just realized.
Oh, no.
I go into the water.
Raiders!
Thank you!
Thank you for the raid!
Sorry, I didn't see who it was.
But thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Go to the recital.
That's right.
But that wasn't like a completely...
Do I have enough time?
I wonder.
I guess we'll see.
To the recital.
We have to go take a boat.
Which...
Where is a boat around here?
Anyway...
Oh, wait.
It was upstairs, wasn't it?
My bad.
No!
Thanks for the five gifted!
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't know who raided me.
But thank you so much.
We're playing a kind of spooky game.
So...
If that's not your style...
Then...
See you later.
Wait!
I remember!
There was a boat over here.
That's right.
There was a boat down here.
I remember.
Nexy!
Thanks for the five gifted!
My brain has been expanding.
Wait, it was over here, wasn't it?
Maybe I...
Wrong.
Maybe.
The boat was the other way.
I thought there was one...
Oh, here, here, here.
Here, here, here, here, here.
Okay.
We got this.
We have to go...
Down, down, down by the river.
Here.
Okay.
Right?
Yes!
Oh, will we have time?
If I'm speedy...
Maybe.
It's got to be speed.
Okay.
Unless it's here...
Wait, where are you heading to?
It's...
The music said...
It was this bar?
It was?
Wait.
I thought the...
I thought it was...
Minto lost.
No help.
No!
This is find help.
Wait.
I thought it was...
Um...
I wasn't think...
I thought it was in the same area as the first...
As the big recital.
As like a little tiny place to the left.
Okay.
I understand the error of my ways.
Wait, so it's...
Around this way?
No.
Uh...
I forgot how to get there.
Wait a minute.
I wish I could open this.
Well, maybe I don't wish I could open...
I don't know.
I don't want to wish anything in this area.
It's too spooky.
Wait.
Was it through here?
Trying to figure out how to...
No?
Hold on.
Let me go back to the very beginning.
I don't die here though.
I think.
Oh, shoot.
I have to go...
Oh, my God.
I'm...
I keep...
Sorry, guys.
My brain.
I'm so sorry.
I'm like, yeah.
I have to go all the way up so that I can...
Go to the hand.
Oh...
Tensai deactivated.
There we go.
So around here...
Uh...
Wasn't it...
Maybe it is on the side.
Oh...
Or wait.
Yeah, because that...
Oh...
That blue...
That turned on the bridge.
Are you...
Eh?
Oh!
Do I need to go that way?
There.
Up there.
I know it's over here.
Right?
Like, it's over there...
Somewhere.
It's over there.
I think the bridge just fell.
I think I was too slow.
Here we go.
Okay.
It was here?
Where was...
What was the spot, though?
Oh, I don't remember.
Here?
They did something?
Well, I found it.
But...
Okay.
I'm not sure what to do here.
Near the edge.
That's right!
We walk to the other side.
We...
We'll come back.
That's right.
We walk to the other side.
And then we blow this out.
I don't think they like that very much.
Whoa!
Wow!
Neat!
Are they going to be walking around?
I don't know.
Are they going to be walking around in here now?
It's okay.
Just run.
Where did the bridge go?
Oh God.
That's so rude.
It blows out all the candles in the house.
So it blows out the bridge.
So I have to go do it again anyway.
Do you think love can bloom even in the outer wilds?
It's a great question.
I'm just going to wait to die.
Oh man.
And I also have to go to the bathroom.
So I will do that too.
You have to do it while they're looking for you.
I know.
They're going to be walking around.
There's going to be time.
There's two of them.
Oh no.
At least I know the layout pretty well at this point, but...
He's going to be mad because he turned off his show.
No.
Stop the stream.
Here's where the real stealth happens.
I can see a lot of progress is going to be made in this run.
Well, I'm hoping to beat it.
That's why I'm like, even if I play for 12 hours, I'm hoping to beat it.
But I do have to go to the bathroom.
So I'm going to go do that.
I'm going to go potty real quick.
I'm going to go to the little ghosty's room.
Oh gosh.
That means all three of them are going to be stealthy.
All three of them are going to be...
And they're spooky stealthy.
It's like the worst kind of stealthy.
It's my least favorite kind of stealthy.
It's like spooky stealthy.
It's not as bad as it seems now.
Okay.
I'll trust you.
I'll be right back.
You guys can...
roast your marshmallows and have a...
Have a delightful time.
I guess we'll go back to that one first because...
I...
know what to do...
immediately with that one.
We'll do that one.
Maybe then we'll do the giant...
The opera house.
And then maybe we'll do the third one.
Because I still don't know what to do with that.
Like how to get down to the hole.
There's a way to bypass every spooky section of the game with puzzle solving.
What?
Oh, are you saying like I sequence break and I figure out how to do everything without being told what to do?
That is not true.
Oh, just kidding.
Hey, stop one-guying me.
Everybody...
Wait, who said that?
Who said that?
More...
people?
More people!
Why would you...
Why?
Why you?
Why would you?
Protect that wisp.
No!
No future knowledge or sequence breaking needed.
What the...
Don't lie to me.
Okay, I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
Sorry, I have to pee a lot today.
Gonna get more tea though.
Yippee!
Guys, I'm doing a blue archive break.
A BA break.
Is she alive?
No!
No, I'm not alive.
I'm dead.
I'm a ghost.
A BA break.
I haven't...
I have...
I'm install...
I'm like downloading the new update right now.
Because I forgot to last night.
Time for camping hidey.
Exactly!
Let's pull for her right now.
Wait...
Wait, did the banner start already?
Actually.
BA fun.
Thank you!
Sensei got a sensei.
You know one of my favorite things to do?
Actually, one of the meetings last night that I had...
One of the people was a sensei.
And I was...
Because they had like a profile picture.
I was like, are you a sensei?
They were like, yeah!
And I was like, who's here?
This is one of my favorite things to do to senseis.
I'll be like, who's your favorite?
Who's your favorite character?
And they'll be like, oh, I really like so and so.
And I'll be like, wrong.
If you were a good sensei, all the girls would be your favorite.
You would treat them all equally.
And then they're like...
The other person...
The other person in the meeting was like, she told you.
True.
They were like, oh, damn!
Yeah.
If you were a good sensei...
Oh wait, the banner's not up yet.
Is it tomorrow?
Oh wait, yes it is.
Camping Haru!
I remember seeing the ads for this in Japan.
Like the ads for her.
I didn't realize she was a...
Oh, I thought she was a unique.
Oh, nice.
Maybe I should wait then.
I thought she was a unique.
Maybe I should just wait then.
Both permanent.
Maybe I'll just do like one.
Maybe I'll do one.
Good rolls be with you, Mito.
I'm waiting too.
But isn't she like really good?
So it's like good to get her now.
Just one temple.
One becomes two.
Two becomes four.
No, no, no.
Actually, yeah, that happened to me last...
Oh.
See, this is peak gacha polling music, right?
Hold on.
Blue archive break.
Everybody do your dailies.
If you play...
If you play any gacha games or whatever, do your dailies with me.
Let's do dailies together.
You know?
I forgot to do them earlier.
Well, I guess I was streaming.
I streamed right when it updated, so...
Or when the date changed.
But you know.
I don't wanna do dailies.
Do her dailies.
The girls are gonna be so sad.
I love this song so much.
I did Nikae dailies already?
Well, then...
Do something else.
But that is for now.
This is why I can only play, like, one gacha game at a time, because, you know, I invest so much into the one, that it's like, doing dailies for more than one gacha game seems tiring to me.
Very valid.
At least with Blue Archives, it takes, like, five minutes.
It's not even so much to do dailies.
I'm playing three and it's a lot.
You're crazy.
You're crazy!
Hmm... I'm doing my lessons.
Such a good sensei.
I'm teaching my girls good things.
I'm teaching them...
What do you think they learn?
What is sensei teaching them anyway?
Maybe don't answer that.
Do you assign homework, Mint?
It's optional.
It's optional homework.
I'm the cool teacher.
I'm THE cool teacher to them.
Can I get extra credit?
What a question.
I didn't think about it.
Stop!
That's enough.
Get your mind out of the gutter!
I find... I almost have my Hot Springs Chetty Node 2 Level 20 relationship.
Not relationship... What's the word?
Oh, it is relationship.
Relationship.
Relationship doesn't have to mean romantic, though.
We're just... I'm her comrade.
I'm her comrade, you guys.
Don't be so weird about it.
Sure.
She's at 18.
Almost got her.
I like the hot springs one so much, though.
It's so cute.
With her little milk mustache.
She's so cute.
Chetty knows a cute brat?
Yeah.
She's...
She's definitely a brat.
I think that makes me love her more.
She's so dumb.
She's like, when's my nap time?
How dare you make me oversleep?
I love that about her.
Comrade is the new roommate.
What do you mean by that?
Oh my god, we're living together?
Ooh la la.
Blue archive in the streets.
Comrade in the sheets.
No!
My love for Chetty and I was so pure.
Can't say that about others.
I guess I can.
I'm a good sensei.
I'm a pure sensei, you guys.
Oh my god, they were roommates.
Get your minds out of the gutter.
Nice thumbnail.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I lost the tactical challenge, as always.
What else do I need to do?
I can save probably some of it.
Okay, I'm gonna do some polls, though.
Oh, they gave a lot of... a lot of...
Gemi's.
Nice.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna do one poll... one ten poll for Hare.
Poll confirmed.
It's blue.
But maybe...
Maybe it'll change.
I'll draw a wisp on that.
Wait!
It changed!
Let's see.
Blue.
I got blue.
I got Judy.
And...
No way!
Oh shit!
I pulled Hare!
First try!
Wow!
Oh my god, streamer luck!
Streamer luck!
Yippee!
Yippee yippee!
I threw out a boyboy.
Cute.
Thank you.
Really cute.
Yeah.
Yippee!
Very nice.
Her thing is so cute she's eating the Yakiimo.
It's my favorite.
Mmm.
That was meant for me.
I'll take it back?
No take backsies.
You would give...
You would give me a gift and then ask for it back?
Have some shame.
Never got into Gachas because I refuse to get a new phone.
Oh, you know what?
You're saving a lot of money.
The Kotama...
Like... she looks so cute.
Everyone's so... I want everybody because they're all so Yuru Camp.
They're all so Yuru Camp.
So cute.
Okay.
I'll do the rest of everything later.
Oh, I am starting to get hungry.
I should probably think of what I'm gonna have for dinner.
Okay, let's meditate.
Beer is actually pretty good for a gacha when it comes to currency.
Sometimes.
Now it's time to try gacha luck on...
Wuwa.
What is Wuwa?
Oh no.
What is... If it's Yuhyun, then don't trust it.
What do you mean by that?
Look, it's like... It's just the campfire the whole time.
Weathering waves.
Oh, it's Genshin 2?
I've never heard of it before actually.
What?
I've never even heard of it.
Hot new gacha game I won't play.
Oh, never... Oh, it's new.
Genshin but harder.
Oh, interesting.
Beep.
Okay.
Let's see.
Guys, I'm not looking forward to this at all.
I'm not looking forward to this at all.
A room full of burned slide rails piled up on a hidden slide rail that shows a container marked with a glowing symbol being handed to a shadowy figure.
The figure follows a procession of green lights through a forest to a candlelit building where they carry the container into a passage behind a roaring fireplace.
Oh, okay, that's that one.
Just kidding.
I was like, wait a second.
This isn't the one.
Made by the same company from Punishing Green Raven.
Oh, okay.
Oh, oh, oh, there we go.
No, no, no.
Um...
This is...
the one we're doing.
Right?
Oh!
No, this is the one we just did.
What the heck?
Wait, I can put mark locations on these too?
Okay...
I'm just getting rid of these real quick.
Wait a second though, aren't...
Oh!
They're the same because they're connected.
I'm so...
I get it.
Secret well.
We're doing this one.
The secret mural.
I don't want to do...
I'm scared, you guys!
Can I turn on the baby mode now?
Can I turn on baby mode now, please?
No.
I can't do this alone...
You'll be fine.
Is that why it was a spoiler?
Whoa, whoa.
Coming in hot.
Coming in hot!
Is that why it was a spoiler... because...
Yep.
Do it in one run.
Okay.
I'll try at least one run.
Probably should have gone the other... Well, I'm going to grab the...
The artifact here.
I like getting it here.
It's really easy.
I'll fail in one run.
Guys, I'm not good at stealth.
I'm scared.
I'm scaredy baby.
I'm so scaredy baby.
Take it down.
Going around town.
Careful not to imply what she's about to experience.
Okay.
I'm not going to look at chat too much.
I'm sorry.
I'm just being a little baby.
Okay.
Here we go.
We're going.
We're going to go in like two seconds.
Here we go.
We're going.
I keep forgetting this is not a VOD.
Thanks for joining.
It's not a VOD, not yet.
I could stop the stream if you want.
I'll play it off that.
I'll play it off the stream.
I'll finish it.
Wow, thank you.
I'll finish it off the stream so that then it will feel like a VOD.
It is this one, right?
Yeah, it is this one.
She actually hates us.
Stop being so dramatic.
This has all been pre-recorded.
Pre-recorded the whole time.
Pretty much.
Let's go.
I'm going over there.
I'm going there.
I'll see you later tonight.
Is it too bright?
Nope.
Okay, hold on.
Okay, order of operations.
Okay.
Order of operations.
We go there, go to the show.
Go to the...
Go to the where the little recital is, or the stage.
We walk across the river.
Blow out the lights.
Go back inside.
Turn on the lights for the bridge.
Walk across the bridge.
Go to the basement.
Okay.
I'm scared.
I don't want to do this.
I'm so scared.
The shortcut I found.
What shortcut?
I found a shortcut?
Wait!
Wait, if I go across the river... wait a second.
If I go... yeah, wait.
If I go across the river...
And I... where is that part... where is that spot though?
Yeah, where we pop out.
I wonder if that will work then.
Right.
Over here.
Right?
And then we just come back and...
Wait.
No.
No, that doesn't work.
Wait.
You can see it from the bridge.
That... but...
No, that's just what we have to...
I'm confused.
What's the ghost cooking?
Nothing.
My brain is fried.
I'm too scared.
I'm too nervous.
The power just went out?
Power just went out.
No time for music!
Oh god.
Oh golly.
My... my shoes!
Will he be...
Will he have a light?
This room...
Oh my god.
It's just a place to hide.
I hate this!
It's just a place to hide!
No wonder I didn't want this...
He's not gonna have... He's gonna have a light though, right?
He's gonna have a light though, right?
Oh god.
Is he gonna have a light?
They all have the same artifact.
Yeah, right?
Thank you!
I'm lost.
Oh my
god.
They don't have a light.
Why can't I just jump down there?
Actually...
No.
Wait.
If I were to leave...
Technically speaking, if I were to leave...
And take the boat...
And come back here...
And...
Um...
How that...
Oh wait.
No.
I would need the ladder.
Or I would need the elevator.
Dang it.
Nevermind.
I would need the elevator.
I was gonna say, what if I just left...
And then...
Came back...
And then took the boat...
And then avoided everybody inside.
But...
Cause then I would use the little...
Boat area and go through the back way.
But...
You can lower it first.
But I have to...
You have to...
Get on that side to lower it.
That was some good cooking.
Thanks.
I mean...
Unless...
Hold on.
What if I...
Lower it before I...
Before I blow out the lights.
Hold on.
Cause then I could...
Then I could avoid everything.
I'm just stalling.
No.
I'm actually cooking.
I think.
Should I try it?
But I would have to...
Hold on.
If I go back inside...
I'm scared.
I don't wanna get caught again.
Worth a shot?
Okay.
I'm really scared.
So I think I'm gonna...
Think I'm gonna try it.
Wait.
What if I just...
Who knows?
Maybe I won't break my legs.
I'm just an alien boy.
Or actually I don't know what my gender is.
I'm just an alien!
Okay.
I think I would have to meditate though, right?
I think I'd have to meditate.
I wonder if there's a way to do it the other ones too then.
Hold on.
What were they?
I'm just a little guy!
Yeah, I'm just a little guy.
Then...
Hold on.
So that was that one.
There's the one...
We still don't know how to get down.
Sorry.
I know it was probably a waste of time.
But I just came up with this idea.
Heartians are genderless.
Okay.
I'm just a little...
creature.
I'm just a creature.
Okay.
That was a bit of a waste of a loop.
But...
Okay.
If we...
I'm trying to remember.
I think it's the...
I think it's the first area...
I gave her a super chat by the way.
Hold on.
I think it's the first area that has...
Not the hidden gorge.
I think it's he...
Here.
That you can access the boat.
I think it's here that you access the boat.
Okay.
All right.
We're going to speed, speed, speed.
If I can find the seat.
Okay.
We can find the seat.
Here we go.
Okay.
My mind is...
All right.
That was so close.
My mind is clear.
Not really.
Gender scaredy cat.
Stop.
For the other two though, I'm still not sure.
I'm going to have to even look up what to do again for them because I don't quite remember.
Okay.
All right.
Inside.
Oh.
Oh, good.
Can I exit?
Then we're fine.
Okay.
Here we go.
Now...
No.
I'm just going to go the normal way.
Just going the way that I've been going.
Okay.
It's okay because first we're going to grab artifact.
Then we go in, we lower, we go in, we lower.
The...
Why do I want to say umbrella?
Elevator?
Hello.
Hey.
Under my umbrella.
Then we leave, come back here, go back in with the artifact, you, and then we ride to that area, use the elevator, go up, avoid all spookies.
Right?
The umbrella-vator.
Elevator, vator, vator, ay, ay, ay.
Oh, yeah.
Is this a tutorial?
I sure wish.
Oh, oh, no, no, no, we need you.
Alright, let's go.
It might be a really tight timing, but...
By golly, by George, I hope we can do it.
And then we'll figure out another way to avoid...
the rest.
Full speed ahead!
She's had brain cells spooked into her.
As long as the dam doesn't break, broken, yeah, exactly.
Come on, come on!
We need to go faster!
Faster!
Full speed!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
This way, this way, this way.
This way.
Okay.
And the reason I also wanted to take the boat is because...
now we have an easy access boat for when we...
come back...
that we can just drop down...
and continue...
onwards.
Run, run, run.
Come on, come on!
Come down, come down!
Go up, go up!
At this part of the DLC where time really starts to matter.
Yeah, right!
Which one is it?
It's...
you!
I knew that.
Okay.
Go, go, go!
Go, avoid the spooky!
Sleep!
Wake up!
No time for sleep!
What's wrong with you?
Wake up, wake up, wake up!
Run, run, run!
No time to be scared!
Only scared if we don't make it!
Only be scared if this fails us!
Okay.
No time to be scared right now!
No time for caution!
His shoes!
There wasn't there another room?
In the...
Actually, with the tree...
There was another room in there that...
That...
We...
You couldn't go in just yet.
Okay.
Your shoes!
Just keep watching them!
Don't worry about me!
Okay.
Go up.
It is really rude though that it does extinguish the fire... or the... yeah, the bridge over here.
I'll be honest.
It's pretty rude.
Look at all these hiding spots!
This guy is gonna be crying.
Crawling around here, it'd be so scary.
It'd be so terrifying.
Now we go back.
Time to lower.
And then we're just gonna jump into the water.
Is there something here?
Oh no.
Don't jump into the water yet.
No time to slow down.
Only speed, only speed here.
Okay.
Oh, hello.
Alright!
Okay!
We got...
We've got the elevator down.
Go, go, go!
Alright.
Good morning everybody!
See ya!
See ya later.
Bye bye.
Bye bye, bye bye, bye bye, bye bye.
Okay.
Now...
We...
Go back.
Wait.
Oh, I forgot!
I forgot to shut off the light.
You're right.
Why did I...
I made a grave mistake.
Wait.
Okay.
Then we go back.
We turn off the light.
And then we leave again.
Wait a second.
Can I leave?
The lights are on.
Sorry.
This is why I was...
This is why I was like, I should write this down.
Because the order of operations is gonna be all over in my brain.
Okay.
Then we go over here.
There's so much to keep track of.
There really is.
Okay.
Upwards.
Why aren't you using the shortcut?
I don't remember the shortcut!
I don't remember where Wubba is!
I don't remember!
Thank you so much for the 20 gifted!
Thank you.
Okay.
Now... Okay.
Now I wake up though, right?
Because then I...
Hold on.
Okay.
There's no way to drop...
I have to...
Yes.
Now I wake up.
And then I go back to the...
Okay.
Into the water.
Whoa!
Okay.
See ya!
You just walked through the shortcut.
Oh!
That...
Okay.
You know what?
I'll be honest.
I don't even notice which...
Which picture frame it was.
So...
I'll be honest.
Okay.
Then we have our boat right there.
All ready to use.
Ready to...
Cruise!
Gustavo!
Welcome to my cruise ship!
Thank you!
Wee!
Okay.
Did you guys see my short?
My...
My snake eater short?
I was so nervous about it.
I'm still so nervous.
I still don't think I sound very good.
But...
The comments seem positive enough.
So...
Thanks guys.
If you listen to it...
It's a song I really don't think...
I can sing very well.
But...
I don't know.
If you guys say so...
I'll trust you.
Maybe.
I think it's because I wish my voice was a little bit more...
Soulful, I guess?
Like a little more...
You know?
Something.
I feel like something's missing.
Not more idolized.
Leaving Scout on the Dam makes a good clock.
Oh!
Like that!
That's so...
It already went down.
Oh my God!
Wait!
It's going down really, really fast!
Um...
I don't think we're gonna make it.
Yo!
This is so messed up.
Go to the tower?
Instead?
Oh, I guess we could go to the tower instead.
Okay.
We'll go to the tower.
You guys are right.
Yeah, the tower lasts longer.
You're right.
And there is...
We can't get the bolt there.
Wait.
How do I...
Um...
How did I...
Set that up before?
I'm trying to think.
Whoever...
Suggested that...
Thank you so much.
That was such a smart idea.
Um...
Zero!
Wait!
Will we make it here too?
Um...
Let me just get to the tower first, please.
Before you come crashing through here.
Okay.
Okay!
Wake up!
Now, guys, here's the issue.
I don't quite remember...
I don't quite remember how we got the boat to reappear... here.
I don't quite remember how we got this part.
Gotta loop around.
Hold on.
Gosh, there's so much...
Activate your memory neurons.
I'm trying!
Yes, you guys are right.
The door to the left.
Thank you.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Because I was like, we've done it before, so...
We've done it before, so it's fine.
If you guys give me a little reminder.
Yeah, remember how you forgore.
You're right!
I forgore how to go places... or how to go through doors when they are...
not open.
Okay.
Now we travel.
Run!
I wish I could run faster!
Okay.
Come on!
Please, come here.
Come here!
There we go.
Is this the one?
I think so!
Here we are!
Full speed ahead!
Okay, maybe not so fast.
Let me be able to get off the boat, please.
Okay.
Go!
Oh my God!
This might work!
Please!
I'm going the right way, right?
I see like a...
I see like a flashing there.
Do you guys see that?
Oh.
I'm... I'm... I'm in a wall.
Uh, I can't see anything.
Time is precious, I know, but I can't see anything, you guys.
What is this?
Wait, what's going on?
Upstairs?
Where am I?
I can't see anything again.
Eh?
I've never seen anyone do the puzzle this way.
Thank you!
Oh, here?
Oh!
Goodness gracious.
Okay.
Oh gosh, it's really dark though, so I can't see anything.
I can get my artifact back.
Okay.
Now it opens the doors.
It's so over.
Stop!
I'm grabbing them!
Not yet!
It's not over yet!
I've got to put them in.
There we go.
Okay.
Okay,
there we go.
I think we've seen this one.
And they cry.
They're so sad.
Yeah, I remember this.
Oh!
This is the part that was blacked out.
What is that thing?
It looks like a Digimon.
Like, you know?
Okay, they're like...
Let's go home!
In our dream world!
They fall asleep.
And they're like happy, happy boys.
Yeah, the DigiBites.
Yeah.
Okay.
So that's what happened there.
And there was another one.
Got it?
Just had to use my leggies.
Okay.
Alrighty.
Oh!
Digital Saturn.
He's walking...
And...
In his...
What the hell?
It says stuff.
What?
So if I leave my...
If I drop my artifact and go too far away from it, I become a Polygon.
I literally become Polygon from Metal Gear.
Cool.
Very cool.
Yeah.
PS1 asset.
Can I go through here?
No.
Is that everything in this area?
What if I...
How...
Oh, clearly not.
Oh!
Whoa!
What's happening?
Oh!
I think my game just crashed?
Wait!
No!
Um...
No, I didn't get any of the information!
Do I have to exit my game?
Oh...
You got all the info from that place?
But it's not gonna update.
Is that okay if it doesn't update in the...
If it doesn't update in...
Just kidding.
Actually now that I know it's all a simulation...
Wait!
Oh wait!
Maybe it did update!
Forbidden archive!
Wait!
There's more to explore here.
Okay, we gotta go back, you guys!
Who knew that this was literally VR missions?
Library full of intact slide rails hidden deep underground.
I found a slide rail that shows that...
Wait, so they're all just, like, in this simulation, and that's... they're all, like, they... they, like, sword art-onlined it.
And, like, never wanted to wake up because they all were just so much happier being at home.
Oh my god.
So they're all so much dead.
It's just their, like, consciousness.
Well, if they actually wake up, they die.
Yeah, yeah.
I found a slide.
Oh, some sort of error report.
It shows one of the strangers as an inhabitant dropping their artifact on the ground and walking beyond its projection radius.
You name it!
Thanks for the five gifted!
There's more to explore here.
So...
If I go back...
I've reached the tower's upper floors by protecting a power... wait.
Oh, that's just the more to explore.
If I...
You don't have to do everything all over again, trust?
There's a code in there.
Yeah, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna try the new thing that we just learned.
That was probably the best... one to start with, maybe.
I feel like...
Oh, uh-oh.
I do not know where the planet is.
One moment.
Don't crash.
Actually, buckle up, everybody.
I don't know where the stranger is.
It's some...
Um...
It's...
I know.
Hold on.
I know where it is.
It's up there, obviously.
Gosh, you guys.
It's right there.
Duh.
We're gonna try our new trick.
Our ghost trick.
The recordings are the game plan.
I'm just worried that...
Oh my god.
We're fine.
Anyway, um...
Do a flip.
Perfect.
Okay.
Right by the entrance.
That's where we need to go.
Wait, what was the super chat?
They did the thing where you fly to a foreign country.
Oh.
Stay in the hotel room and play games on your laptop the whole time.
It's true.
Well, that was me.
But, um...
Involuntarily.
Okay.
I'm kind of...
Confused how...
I'm supposed to do this.
Now...
Um...
I don't know.
So, I'm guessing it's easier to avoid them...
If I can see where they are because of this new trick, right?
I'm guessing that's...
The deal, yo.
Oh my goodness.
Or maybe they won't even see me.
Who knows?
Maybe I will be able to...
Like...
When I...
Oh my god.
Oh, that was close.
When I did it in there...
I...
I was able to like walk through the walls and stuff.
So...
I'm literally hacking their game.
I'm gonna hack the game so that...
Instead of little alien people, they're all...
Big, booby anime girls.
Jeffrey, I'm hacking your game.
In a good way.
Hacked wild.
Dot hack wild.
Oh my gosh.
I only...
I actually only read dot hack.
Um...
Uh...
I watched a little bit.
I didn't finish dot hack sign.
Oh, what was the...
There was like...
One where they were cuter.
Oh...
Um...
The Legend of the Twilight Bracelet, I think it was...
Legend of the...
Something bra...
No, not G.U.
She's figuring out how to actually press the button.
She's been thinking about that since the stream.
We're fine.
No, not G.U.
Yeah, Legend of the Twilight.
I was like, Twilight Bracelet.
There's something with a bracelet in it.
That's why.
Oh...
Okay.
Oh, it is Twilight Bracelet.
Legends of the twilight.
Oh.
Well, actually...
It's called Legends of the Twilight.
Um, actually.
I listen to the sign OST like weekly.
Yeah, because it's like Kajiura Yuuki.
Yes.
God composer.
Tobias!
Thanks for the tank gift and thank you!
I'm surprised we haven't seen more... the attacks.
I don't know.
It just feels like...
It's not another... like a franchise that they would continue.
Unless I... Unless there has been and I just don't know.
SAO killed it?
No!
I don't think so.
I know people would compare it but...
I think they're different enough.
So if I just leave this here... See ya!
An attempt to leave.
I'm walking up the stairs.
Maybe I should have left... Okay, hold on.
Maybe this was a bad idea.
You guys...
I'm good?
When does it activate?
I'm stuck in a corner.
Okay, that...
I saw light for a second.
I'm looking around.
I'm turning my head.
We had jump.
I'm stuck!
What do you think that is?
Wait, what do you think that is?
Tower staircase.
Wait, so where am I?
Lost.
Light from the fire.
Um...
Anyway, okay, let's continue.
Okay, I'm gonna leave it right...
Right here.
There's even a...
Do you think I can fall onto that?
I think I can fall onto that?
Anyway.
Total flip!
Okay.
Second goal.
Well, we tried.
There was an attempt.
Sha!
Wow!
This is so much fun.
Oh, beautiful!
Oh my god!
This is so pretty!
Game changer.
For real though!
Oh my god.
Wow!
Still, this doesn't work though.
The game is borked.
Wait, can I...
Oh, but it's still... the lights still need to be off.
And I can't go through here either.
Okay.
We still need to turn the lights off though.
But let's explore a little bit, I think.
But also...
Also, how will I work the grabby grabs?
Yeah, see, I can't even get over.
Yeah, okay.
But now if I turn it off, it's so easy to get over there.
I'll have to forfeit my artifact though.
I love VRChat!
Wait!
Yeah, wait, can I take that hidden path with my artifact?
Oh!
I like the music even with it.
Hold on.
Okay, wait.
What's this?
Is it this one?
No.
This one.
Yes.
Push!
My shoes!
Weeeeee!
Now, I don't... I'm not quite sure if the path works.
I guess it would because there was that hidden path, right?
Is it here?
Oh god, wait.
It's here, right?
I'm scared.
Wait.
I don't want to fall into the abyss.
Let's just check.
We can set it down and we can check.
Drop.
Whoa!
Okay, okay, okay.
Way more to the right.
Wow!
I guess I just...
You just never think to drop your thing, right?
Like...
You just never think to get rid of your artifact, so...
Oh.
Crazy.
Mind the gap.
I wonder now though...
Wait, which one is it?
This goes outside.
So it's this one.
I'm curious if I just go without...
Oh my goodness.
Uh oh.
Oh, it's already off.
Okay, never mind.
My bad.
I wonder if I go...
Without even holding this thing.
I'm kind of curious what will happen.
I'm just gonna drop it.
Okay.
Just curious.
Huh.
What's up down there?
What's going on down there?
How are you going to use the elevator?
Oh.
Good question.
But let me see...
I want to see if there's a guy down here too, okay?
Oh, okay.
Have your spine adjusted by a pursuer?
Oh, and I came... Okay, I still have it though.
Wow.
Okay, so that guy is not so nice.
That guy is a little mean.
Hmm.
Okay, cool.
Well, there is a guy down there.
Good to know.
Still think they're friendly?
You guys...
But I was just like, I don't think they're friendly.
It was you guys that were just like...
No, they're friendly.
He's mad because I clearly turned off his TV shows.
I don't know if I have enough time, but we can try.
I really don't think so.
I don't think I have a lot of time left.
This makes me just want to play everything...
Without...
Okay.
The artifact.
Ah!
Huh?
Did it get shorter?
Oh, I walked off the...
Oh.
You have to point at the elevator.
One more time!
Shortest nap in existence.
I nap for one second.
Can you...
Gosh.
I would love to be able to just close my eyes and fall asleep.
I have a lot of trouble falling asleep.
You know.
I'm like always...
I'll be...
I'll be rolling around for like...
Okay.
So the elevator.
Is that the elevator?
Keep the little tree on each side of your...
I can't with this.
We're gonna...
The...
The tower is gonna fall at this rate.
It's all my fault though.
Hold on, I'm gonna put this here.
And we're just...
I'm just gonna go check, okay?
Okay.
What is my landmark?
Tree?
In between the trees?
Doink.
Here
we go.
I hope I don't get caught by the guy.
I'm going to get scared.
Okay.
Like that?
Wait.
Over a little bit more maybe.
It's so hard to see that one.
Yippee!
We made it!
We made it just in time!
No, I don't want to go back down there.
I'll be honest.
I'm too scared to go back down there.
I'll sprint past one guy.
Okay.
We're back here.
I love the music in this part.
It's so epic.
I don't think we have a lot of time.
So, time is not of the essence.
We got to figure out what we're doing.
Which means I'm putting this sucker down like right here.
And I'm walking away.
And I'm going to go to this thing.
Over here.
Okay.
Open.
Oh.
It's corrupted.
But maybe it won't be corrupted in the real world.
JK, get owned.
Hold on.
Maybe it's normal.
Here.
Oh.
It's not.
Okay.
What else can...
What else is weird in this world?
Just...
Oh, there's a code.
Yeah.
Oh.
It's because the lights.
Wait.
I have to put them in...
Into here, right?
Um...
Hmm.
Oh, that was it?
That's it for this place?
No way.
It was for a nonsense, useless code that didn't even exist?
What if I had discovered that on accident?
What if I had put the thing in and then...
Wow!
Whoa, it's that light over there.
Where are we?
Where are we in this video game world?
Ohio.
Very funny.
Now you know the shortcut better.
Yeah!
I mean, do I have to come back here?
Maybe eventually to figure out how to fix this, right?
It's all corrupted.
Okay.
I was just gonna wait for the...
There's also a screen over there.
So those are the other ones that we have to get, I'm assuming.
This is the...
This is...
The screen.
I think there's nothing else, right?
I think that's it.
Yeah.
I think we can wake up and...
Or I think we can just meditate until the next level.
Good.
Very good, everybody.
Good job.
Why can't you see the scrolls or the slides in here, though?
How peculiar.
Huh?
Oh!
I like...
I like died-died.
I don't know how to swim.
That's interesting.
Two more locations to solve.
Yup.
One of them I'm really not looking forward to!
One of them I'm really...
Wait.
Huh?
Didn't I just meditate until the next one?
Yeah, I wasn't holding the fire, so I actually drowned, drowned.
Oh!
I...
That's right.
Alright, I meditated... close to the fire.
I remember, I remember, I remember.
Okay.
Good loop, everybody.
I remember!
I remember.
You got world-breaking knowledge now.
I know, you're right.
Okay, let's see.
If I go in here...
Not even the system knows what to tell...
It's like...
I don't even know what to tell you, man.
Oh, here.
There's a container marked with one of the Vault Seals, but its contents have been destroyed.
Yay!
We got it!
Okay.
Shrouded Woodlands is...
Uh...
The one with the boat.
Right?
How will people please fix...
The first one.
Okay.
Um...
And then this is the tower.
We still have the sealed vaults...
But...
We know so much more now...
Than before.
You have new knowledge.
Yeah, we have new knowledge.
In fact...
I'm thinking...
Well, I should probably go to these two first before I go...
I was gonna go to...
This submerged structure and sleep there and see what happens in the...
At the lake.
But I will...
Refrain...
Maybe for now?
Until we do these two other ones?
Or I could do that as a break?
Try it?
I was gonna say...
Maybe do it as a break...
From...
From these?
So that I'm...
Since I'm...
Since I'm scared...
Scaredy baby?
Look at this.
All started with a radio tower.
All right.
So let's go to the submerged structure.
I'm coming.
Okay.
Cool.
Is there any part of the game which doesn't scare you?
What are you talking about?
What?
I'm scaredy baby.
Please.
Understand.
Coming in hot.
Do a flip.
Okay.
Sorry.
Here.
I'm suckling.
Actually, I am kind of hungry.
Okay.
All right, everybody.
Teeth out.
I'm hungry.
Wait.
You know that person earlier that was just like, have you ever thought of Chad as your baby?
Oh, wait.
Let's get this.
Sorry.
I know I always get this one.
I just think it's really easy.
It's like so fast and easy to get to it.
Well, it would be if I didn't get the post.
This side.
You know how they were just like...
Do you think of Chad as your baby?
And I was like, no.
What if you thought me as your baby?
Would you treat me better if you were like, I gave birth to this ghost for death?
Kind of complicated, isn't it?
Are we allowed to?
I don't know.
Your name is the bravery duck.
Are you brave enough?
Why did you have to go and die so soon?
I'm not into baby play.
That's fine.
We'll go to Nile Perch and we'll all get new outfits together.
And if you don't know what Nile Perch is, just look it up and tell me.
It's like...
It's like the cutest brand ever, but I can never wear a single thing.
Actually, that's a lie.
I bought a beret from them once.
But everything else, I'm like, I can't.
I can't buy.
I just...
I just can't buy from this brand.
Because I would never be able to wear it at home ever.
You were doing a baby RP and I took a nap and I woke up and you were still doing a baby...
Why did you sleep during my stream?
You're not feeding the alligator.
Oh, wait.
We don't have to go to the right.
I just remembered.
Just remembered.
But you can go straight.
Don't...
Is this a clipper sleeping on the job?
Don't sleep during my stream.
Fine, I'll do ASMR or something.
God, is that what you want?
God, stop pulling my...
Gosh, you're really yanking my arm here with this...
Just like nonstop.
Do ASMR, Minto.
Actually, I think my ASMR...
I have an ASMR mic, but I think it needs to...
I think it needs new batteries.
I think I forgot to turn it off.
Niall, perch is apparently also just a straight up fish.
It is!
I had no idea.
Okay, to the submerged...
place.
We're gonna keep our boat here.
Please, please, please.
Da-da-da-da.
You guys know that Sabrina Carpenter song?
I've kind of been listening to it a lot.
Heartbreak is one thing.
My ego's another.
Don't ever something embarrass me.
She goes so low.
Motherfucker.
She goes so low there.
I was singing it earlier.
While I was getting ready for stream.
While I was thinking, how late should I be today?
I was singing it.
Pulling your locomotive limb.
What does that mean?
I've only heard her name like yesterday.
She's like the hot...
hotness right now, you know?
She's kind of the hotness.
I like her music.
I think it's cute.
Okay.
Let's leave our little buddy here.
Right here.
Towards the exit.
Thank you.
It's probably fine.
Oh, there we go.
Oh my god.
Oh, there they are!
And then there's a beam of light that comes down that makes us visible.
And there's also parkour!
Oh, the power thing just went out?
There's also a boat that goes directly here.
Oh my god, he's like half...
Can I see inside?
Yes, we've seen this already!
I'm bored!
Stop!
I've seen this already!
You can see the platforms, yeah.
Vision jump scare.
Walk out of it?
Oh, okay, thank you.
I still am not quite sure.
Unless I have a box, I don't really...
I'm not really quite sure what to do here.
I was hoping that maybe if I...
Wait, I see what I can do.
If I go along the railing...
Hold on.
Let's go get our thing.
I don't think I said that last stream too.
I was like, what if... Oh my god, leave me alone!
I don't care about your vision!
He's like, wait, wait, wait.
He's like a tech bro.
I was wondering.
I was like, I wonder if I...
Go along the railing, if that will work.
I'm crawling.
Oh.
No worries?
No worries!
That means no worries for the rest of your day.
Oh.
It's a problem.
What if I drop?
That was a far drop.
You can't solve it yet.
Yeah, I don't think so.
What's wrong with me?
Okay.
We're gonna get out of here.
We have other places to be.
I think the dam is about to explode.
I think we should...
Go over here.
Towards.
Yes.
Right there.
Okay.
And...
Nice.
Okay.
I feel kind of bad for them.
They were just so like, yeah, we hate it here.
We're just...
Like...
We're just gonna go to virtual world and...
Become VTubers.
For real.
I ask myself that question every day.
About yourself?
Or about me?
Oh.
Uh...
Guys?
I don't think we have much time.
Both.
Sadly about you.
What are you doing?
What are you...
What do you mean by this?
Why?
Why me?
Twenty-two.
Twenty-one.
Twenty.
We'll go to the tower.
Nineteen.
Eighteen.
Seventeen.
Sixteen.
Fifteen.
Fourteen.
Thirteen.
Twelve.
I don't think we're gonna make it though to...
The tower.
We'll see.
Ten.
Nine.
Oh, maybe we will.
Thirty seconds left?
Oh, we might make it then.
Maybe.
Well, no.
Not thirty.
Maybe?
Actually, I can't tell.
Oh, we'll make it.
We'll definitely make it.
Five hours ago.
Wow.
It's already been five hours of streaming?
Holy cow.
Even I'm shocked by that.
No way.
What time is it?
Oh my gosh.
It's 8 p.m.
What?
Wowee.
Okay.
I don't care.
I sleep.
What was that?
What are you getting all upset for?
Unless he died.
That was pretty freaky.
Okay.
So...
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Wait.
I just wanted to see what this looked like because I knew that we weren't going to have a lot of time.
But I did want to see what this looked like.
Um...
Why are we still walking around?
I...
Okay.
What was it?
We go down here.
Then we go halfway.
Then we blow it out.
But I'm trying to see if there's any, um...
Any shortcuts we can do.
Once...
Because they're going to be...
You guys are going to be walking around once we...
Oh, I thought that was him.
I was like, he's a spider.
Oh, there he is.
Oh my gosh.
It's kind of crazy.
Um...
They're going to be walking around and I don't quite see how we get down here.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Hold on.
I see.
So now we're figuring this out.
Because we go this way.
We go...
Down.
And then around.
And then...
Through.
Okay.
There's the other guy.
You can see him up there.
Okay.
See?
This was helpful.
Did you ever check the other door on the left?
Okay.
I wonder...
Actually, is it a shortcut?
Let's see.
I don't know where these guys are going to be wandering around.
It's an issue for me.
This door over here.
I can't remember if I did or not.
Maybe that's easier.
Hold on.
We can go check right now.
Void.
But if we're coming from the boat, it's hard to say which one will be easier.
You know?
Yeah.
So there's the elevator.
So we'll be coming from that end over there.
Yeah.
We'll be coming from over here.
Over there.
So...
Hmm.
Okay.
So I'm just going to make this blocky and then I'm just going to go downstairs and see what happens.
This is just getting us...
Oh,
I thought it was the music of...
Music of...
You're done.
I'm just getting a feel of the area.
Okay.
So down here.
I can go through here?
Is anyone around here?
I'm scared.
Oh no!
There's a loop down here, which means somebody was gonna be down here!
There's a loop!
God...
Okay.
Well now we know.
What is their vision like though?
You know?
Okay.
Alright, so we take the boat.
We blow it out.
Now that I know how this works...
What is a way that I can avoid...
avoid having to do this...
in the manner that must be done?
You know what I mean?
How can I... How can I big brain this?
Just like the other one.
You turn off the game.
The DLC got redesigned to make it easier to bypass the aliens.
Oh really?
You won't cheese this one?
Alrighty.
Well we know what we must do.
We go to the other side.
We uh...
We blow out the...
We blow out these lights.
We come back.
And attempt...
to go around.
I'm just gonna...
Trust your instincts as a soldier.
As a gamer!
I played the old design of the DLC.
It was hell.
Really?
So, actually I'm curious.
Now that we know...
Now that I know...
About what's going on...
If I turn on baby mode...
What does it change?
The enemies move slower...
when chasing you.
They chase you slower.
Dumber AI.
Still just as spoopy.
See?
That's not that bad.
I figured they'd be chasing after me.
So I feel like that wasn't even really a spoiler.
Did I get anything new?
Oh!
The wall at the bottom of the village is guarded by a statue that activates an alarm bell when it sees me.
Astute observation.
Thank you.
As long as I'm faster than them, all I have to do is run, right?
As long as I'm faster than them, I just...
I just book it, right?
Okay.
Here we go!
To the tower!
Hello!
Coming in hot!
Do a flip!
And we're good!
It's just a glass.
We're never coming back here ever again anyway.
Goodbye ship!
Goodbye!
Goodbye world!
Everybody say goodbye to the ship.
Say goodbye ship!
I hardly knew ye!
Okay...
Oh.
And let's get our artifact!
I never liked that ship anyway.
What?
What did this ship do to you?
So after I do...
I mean, this seems like pretty...
Pretty big puzzles.
After these...
I'm guessing I have to figure out a way to...
Unscramble...
The code.
So then we can unlock it.
Every time I'm just like, I don't know what else...
I have to do in this game.
It always surprises me.
Ship during base game.
Oh my precious baby!
Ship during DLC.
Smell you later stinky!
That's because I needed my precious baby before.
Now...
He just gets me to this place.
And now it's all about boats.
It's all about boat baby!
Ain't that part of the fun.
So true.
Alrighty.
Okay.
I'll be honest though.
Do you guys think I'm gonna finish today?
Another...
How long has it been?
One second.
Oh I can exit out of all these paint.
Windows now?
Mmm...
Get rid of you.
Oh sorry.
It keeps like auto...
Auto returning to the game.
Oh I just...
Oh shoot I just exited out of one of the codes.
But it should be okay.
Okay.
That works.
You are in the latter half.
Awesome!
But it depends... possible but it depends.
Alright.
Guys we're just gonna big brain everything.
Okay?
We're gonna big brain everything.
You can finish in one hour?
Brain think good?
No way.
Brain...
Um...
Might need a break.
Food.
Actually okay.
Is there... now that I think about it.
Is there anything I need to do here?
Hold on.
I'm thinking.
Is there anything I need to do here?
Um...
To make things easier for me.
No the...
Elevator was up.
Mmm...
I think
we're...
I think it's not like before.
I don't think it's like before.
I think we can just go...
If not then...
I guess uh...
FML...
Um...
Well really F-M-A-L.
And then...
Um...
I'm really scared of...
I'm really scared because before I was like I can just chase her.
It's great!
Now I know I cannot.
But...
Conceal.
And walk.
And that's the thing that sees me.
So now I'm good.
And here we go.
About half way through.
Where are you?
There it is.
Elevator.
Downwards?
Upwards?
Upwards.
Oh nice.
Nice.
Wait what's over here?
Hold on a second.
They didn't show me this in the visions.
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait.
Where does it take me?
Oh!
Look at them!
I took a nap and woke up.
Why are you all taking naps?
Um...
What was I gonna say?
Yeah, it said endurance in the title so...
I really am planning...
I'm really wanting to finish the game today.
Okay.
We just lost the electricity.
Also I noticed that sometimes my controller rumbles and sometimes it doesn't so...
In some places we're closer.
Oh!
Nope, never mind.
There's the rumble.
Let's see.
What?
I wonder...
If I can like jump from here.
And then...
Run over to the elevator.
I think that will be our best bet.
I think.
We'll just need to cook.
Okay.
Well you know what?
We have so many kitchen...
So many cooks in the kitchen, right?
We have so many cooks in the kitchen, I think we'll be good!
You weren't even watching TV.
Why do you care?
Oh.
There you go.
Wait.
What the?
Oh they're coming down.
Fento.
Thanks for the gift.
Wait, are they just taking the...
Elevator up and down and up and down?
Oh no.
I think they went down.
Oh?
Wow.
Very cool.
Oh!
Oh no!
Actually...
I wonder if this works even better.
Because...
We can take that shortcut on the left, right?
Why is he able to turn his light on?
Why can't he have his light on all the time?
I also can't hear them walking.
Before they were like so thumpy.
But now it's actually very...
Hard.
To hear them walking around.
Do you think he's in here?
I think he's in here.
I'm so...
I don't know.
I don't want to fall in the water.
Okay.
This way.
It's so dark.
I think I hear footsteps.
I'm scared to turn off my light.
I'm actually so scared to turn off my light, you guys.
Do you think it's okay?
I can hear...
I didn't see nothing.
Is that better for you?
Okay.
I'm gonna turn off the light.
Oh.
What's happening?
What's this music?
What is this?
What is this sound?
What is that noise?
He was right in front of me.
No!
You!
Why don't you want me here?
So that's what that music was.
Yeah, clearly.
That's the dam breaking.
I think the guy...
is downstairs.
Legit jump scare.
I know, right?
Okay.
Alright.
Let's do this again.
Hmm.
Will they see if I focus light?
Has she found out what that noise is?
I have not.
What?
Wait, did I...
Did I go in the water or did I get caught?
I guess I got... I guess I went in the water.
Oh my god.
Gosh.
Luckily it's easy enough to get over there.
You guys say I need to use my brain.
Well, it's really just...
I need to...
I need to get this to work.
I need to get over there.
I'm just gonna walk.
If I get caught...
Have they seen me?
We only have...
We're living on borrowed time.
I think he's all the way on the other side.
Set down the lantern.
Trying not to fall in the water.
I think I'm in front of a rock.
Don't fall.
Um...
Oh my god.
Ouch!
Guys.
Okay.
I know what I'm gonna...
Before I set it down, I'm gonna see what the water situation is.
And then...
Then I'll walk away.
And then I'll...
And then I'll go.
I think.
The mint who sold the outer world.
Okay.
We understand how it works now.
We go off and then we go...
We pivot straight to the right.
Gotta put it right here.
We'll come back for you.
Alright.
I see that.
When?
When does it happen?
When does?
It sounds cute.
Oh my god.
Fine.
Did you see something?
I saw him staring directly at me again.
That's what I saw.
Why can't he...
At least he have a light, you know?
I think that's the most frustrating part.
Because I really can't hear him at all.
I can't hear his footsteps.
He will turn around once he starts looking.
I...
Oh...
I know.
You guys are gonna hate me.
You know what?
Never mind.
I give up.
He's there?
Yeah.
Thanks a whole lot.
Idiot.
You're also dead.
Oh...
Black screen makes me sleepy.
I took too long.
Yeah.
No shit.
I know.
But it's...
Look at all my footage.
It's just black screen.
It's...
Oh wait!
Are the... Are some of them...
Wait.
Some of the things when it shows out of the game?
It doesn't show that.
Interesting.
This area was the spookiest.
Really?
Not the one with the house?
Or like the concert hall one?
That one seems the scariest for me.
This is... This is tricky though.
It's because I can't see them.
That area was the hardest for me.
It's... Yeah.
You can't see them.
You can't... You can barely hear them.
It's... It's tricky.
It's tricky.
This area is really...
It's only difficult before you pass it through at the first...
At the first time.
Okay.
So maybe if I like...
Like if I can't outrun him...
But I have to have my light off anyway for when I...
Go to the...
Woooo...
When I go to the...
Do a flip?
The hole anyway.
So maybe I should just have it on.
Run to where I need to be.
And then...
Turn it off when I get there.
Maybe.
Focus the light on them.
I could do that too.
Yeah.
The focusing the light...
Scares me the most because it's like...
Having to switch between it and...
Covering the light.
I'll have to practice a little bit though.
Oops.
I forgot to push my wrap.
Come on.
Frozen!
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you!
I'm struggling a little guys.
I'm struggling.
Blip.
There we go.
Okay.
I feel like this is stealth but it also doesn't count so much.
Because I have to...
Seems like I have to get caught.
Justin!
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Good night, mint and...
Good night!
Oh yeah, I haven't eaten...
I didn't realize how late it was.
Now I'm realizing I haven't had dinner yet.
I will have to...
Do that at some point.
Have to take another break.
Short break though.
Just to eat.
But it's only been 6 hours.
So...
This one?
Oh, I forgot to wake up.
There we go.
Okay.
Okay,
so I can focus...
So I can focus and then close.
And then open and close.
Okay, okay.
Good to know.
Now we go this way.
I wonder...
Okay.
Hold on real quick.
I'm putting my thing down.
And I'm gonna go in a straight line.
I just wanna see.
I think the elevator is the only way down, right?
I can't...
But it seems...
What do ghosts eat?
I just possess somebody that...
Could be you.
What are you having for dinner tonight?
Possess somebody and then I...
You know...
Just have what they're having.
Pretty much...
Oh wait.
There's an elevator here?
But these all...
I wouldn't be able to make it.
Right?
I...
Show me where all the elevators are.
Wait.
Okay.
Hold on.
If I have to wake back up, I wake back up.
That wasn't supposed to happen.
That...
I didn't mean to happen.
Sorry.
Okay.
The real enemy is the gravity.
Truly.
A terror.
Door?
Door.
Oh, sorry.
Okay.
Let's see.
I'm checking again.
Where this leads to?
If it's the only way I can go.
Over there.
I think it's the quote on quote easiest though.
I think it was...
I think it's the quote on quote easiest way.
Cause I...
Unless it's like in a cave in here.
But then there's also a guy stalking the knight.
So...
It's not so good.
Wait.
Okay.
Mint is too spicy of a flavor?
Even I can have mint.
And I can have anything spicy.
Are you sure?
Mint too spicy.
Okay.
We're going up.
Light it up.
Oh...
I hear like him walking around here too.
So I'm kind of curious.
Who comes this way?
And up like this elevator.
Is there a guy over there?
I just don't notice him.
Is there a guy in there?
Are there three guys?
How many guys are there?
I don't know.
So I think...
Just finish the DLC on my end.
What?
Absolutely 10 out of 10 experience.
Kyle, how did you get past this bar?
Kyle, help.
Kyle, let's get there.
Kyle?
Five guys?
I love five guys.
Yummy.
No help.
I hate you all.
You know what?
What are you saying?
She hates us.
It's real.
It's true.
It's the truth.
I think he sees me, you guys.
I lived?
Oh, he's coming.
Hey, how did you get here?
Hey.
Hey, leave me alone.
I think he gave up.
Let's go back.
I think he got me.
Oh, bing-bong.
You're setting off your own alarm.
Can-can, everybody.
Wake up.
What if I just blew out all of their flames?
Wouldn't that be kind of diabolical?
That would save me so much time.
Why can't I blow out their flames, huh?
They're too dead asleep.
Oh, gosh.
Now we're back to where we started.
There's an extinguish on everything.
You just go up and you...
You extinguish it.
They should be able to extinguish their own fires.
Yeah, take that.
You don't want me hanging around here?
I don't want you hanging around here either.
Oh, there it goes.
I'm running out of time.
I'm stalling too much.
Oh, this way.
Here
it comes.
I think I hear him to my right.
So I'm just gonna go straight.
Oh, shit.
Run!
It sounded like he was on my right.
Guess not.
Perthian lungs are too small to blow out their flames.
Okay, then.
And I'm gonna get a bucket of water.
I'm gonna cup the water in my hands.
And I'm just gonna douse him.
This guy is such a freak.
Yeah, carry a squirt gun.
I think I'm already screwed.
Is he coming this way, you think?
Or did he give up?
I wonder if there's a way I can sneak past him there.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Oh.
Maybe I do need the baby mode on.
Just so I can progress.
Maybe I need baby mode on so I can progress through the game.
Oh.
I'm hungry.
Just give him the runaround.
Oh, I'm trying.
I'm trying.
I just gotta...
He's faster than me though.
He's pretty fast.
It is a skill issue.
100%, yeah.
Yeah, you can say it.
Skill issue.
Yeah, whatever.
It's a skill issue.
Pretty much.
What am I looking at?
I think I'm looking in the wrong direction.
Okay, hold on.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, I turned around.
I'm trying to troll him a little bit.
What are my lights coming from over there?
You don't know.
How do I get to the other...
Don't turn around, mister.
Where's the exit?
Oh, I found it.
He's not coming still.
Now I need to know how to not fall into the water here.
Oh, you guys.
I probably should just meditate and redo this.
I don't think I'm gonna have enough time.
Okay.
So close.
I think it's just the one guy.
I sure hope so.
Please be honest, guys.
There's no one else.
By the...
I will cry.
If there's someone else by the actual thing.
Okay.
Don't just put smileys!
You guys know I'm struggling and you hate me so much!
You just hate me!
I'm having so much fun in my death loop.
Please stop noticing me!
Please!
Why does elevator have to go back up?
Stop noticing me, please!
Run past him.
He's definitely gonna grab me.
There's not land there.
I thought that was my own vision.
Going nutty.
All I am is frustrated.
So used to going to the plate.
Okay.
Let's go all the way back.
Coming in hot.
You know what?
Let's come in hot.
Good enough.
Okay.
Let's see.
Let's get our artifact.
How far can this...
There we go.
Now we'll always know.
Okay.
Wait.
But I have to put this...
I have to put it away though, don't I?
To get the thing.
Actually maybe...
Maybe I can't do that.
Because we have to grab the...
We have to grab the artifact.
Oh, it still works.
Nice.
Okay.
Is my endurance okay?
I'm just... I'm just frustrated.
It's all...
I think because I'm getting hangry.
But I'm like...
Wanting to do this before I eat.
And I want to take a break.
Because I just want to get through it.
Because we've made no progress in probably like a fucking hour.
And that annoys me.
But right now...
I'm not...
I'm less than okay.
But I'm okay.
Oh.
Viewers are encouraging a streamer called Minto who is overcoming...
Okie dokie.
Alright.
Let's go back to the boat.
And blow out the candles.
And then...
I wonder though.
Hold on.
Before we do so.
Let's get a...
Let's get a little more acclimated.
With our...
With our terrain.
We go down here.
There's no one here, right?
No one here.
So if I just go...
Where's the...
Ok.
I see.
So here.
We can go here.
Ok.
This is...
This is what I was trying to find.
I thought it was another bridge.
I knew there was another bridge.
But I thought it was like... immediate.
So if he starts seeing me here...
Then I can just run here.
Ok.
See that's what was tripping me up a lot.
And then here...
It's just straight.
From...
In here.
Just straight.
It's gonna see me in the light though.
I didn't know there were candles there.
Um...
Straight until you hit the candles.
And then to the left.
And then...
We go down the stairs.
Ok.
Alright.
That should help a little bit.
I thought I knew what I was doing before.
But I did not.
I just don't know when he'll give up.
But...
The music freaked me out for a second.
Ok.
Will he?
Well, maybe not.
But if he doesn't...
Whatever I guess.
If he does, that's pretty cool.
If he doesn't...
Well...
We'll just keep on going.
Ok.
I just felt the...
The power thing go out.
Oop.
Wrong thing.
There we go.
Oh.
I heard the bells for like two seconds.
That's so funny.
Can't catch me today, sucker!
And hand.
Ok.
Oop.
Use your light a bit to avoid drowning.
Yeah.
I think...
I will have it up.
I think it's fine to have it up.
If um...
If I'm like...
Running away from him.
Oh wait.
No.
I can't have the light because I'll get spotted and the bells will go off.
Well, I'll have to like...
Quickly conceal it, you know.
Let's not waste anymore time.
I'm just gonna...
Drown.
Or die or something.
I'm just gonna...
So we can...
Quickly get back to the beginning.
Ok.
Please.
Hopefully...
I can game.
Please let me game.
Please.
I think I just heard the...
Things still going down.
The elevators.
Please let me game.
Ok.
So it was...
It was...
Distract him.
Have him come forward.
Go to the right.
Don't die in the water.
Right?
I think.
Cross the bridge.
Yeah, but I won't even be able to see the bridge, right?
He's gonna be coming after me.
Right?
So...
Um...
Straight but hug...
Straight but hug the right wall.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can flicker your life to see it.
Ok.
Here it is.
So it's here.
Hey.
Hey dummy.
Yeah, come here.
He just showed me the exit.
Don't look this way.
Oh shit.
Yeah?
What are you seeing?
What are you seeing, huh?
Oh gosh.
Straight?
I think I still hear him coming.
Where am I?
Where's...
Is there an elevator?
Coming in here?
I'm scared.
Is there...
Is there an elevator?
Shoot.
Nooooooo!
Awww.
You made it to phase two!
You might wanna put the light down to get a better look.
I don't even know where I can put it down.
Put the light down upstairs.
If I can... I can't even see anything!
Oh.
Shit.
I'm stuck.
Trapped somewhere.
I'm going downstairs.
Screw it.
I'm lost in the sauce.
I'm lost.
In the sauce.
Put it down now?
Ok.
Uh.
You won't see me though, right?
Ok.
So...
We go upstairs...
Oh there's two of them!
No way.
There's two of them.
Ok.
How did I avoid both of them?
It's kind of impressive, right?
Impressive in its own right?
Maybe?
Ok.
Over here?
Here?
Oh wow.
This is really obnoxious.
Who designed this?
Who designed this level?
Is that it, right?
Oh here, here, here.
And there's a light thing.
Oh my god!
What?
Jeffrey!
So I'm kind of in like the worst position in here.
I'm kind of in a really bad spot right now at the moment, actually.
I wish that was you.
I wish that was you right now.
I wish that was one of you guys.
I don't even... There's a room over here?
Where does this lead to?
An elevator?
Ok.
Um...
This used to be harder, by the way.
That's insane.
Ok.
Oh my god!
He's all the way over there!
By the room where we need to be at!
Go!
Ok, hold on.
I can't even figure out how to get around.
It's up here?
Wish you had a soliton radar.
I know.
Ok.
What?
Can I at least see where...
No, no!
Go away!
Oh my god!
I think this is where he's usually roaming.
And I tricked him earlier.
Maybe?
I can't tell.
He's circling.
I don't know where the other guy is.
Hold on.
Let me see where he's at before we continue.
Sheesh.
Where is he?
This is so messed up.
He's camping!
I'm gonna have to get through all of this?
Oh my god.
There's no way, you guys.
There's no...
There's no way.
There's no way I can do this.
I don't even know where the other guy is.
Wait, there's a... what?
There's a spoiler mode.
What does that mean?
What do you mean?
Is there a bridge over here?
Oh, in the darkness.
Oh, so they're both on the bridge, maybe?
You think?
No, I don't think so.
Oh, he went down here, I think.
I think maybe he's...
I see someone over there.
I don't know what he's doing.
Oh, gosh.
I don't see him there now.
This is...
Already?
Where at?
I'm just gonna go...
Until I can hear no more.
Okay.
What
the hell?
Why am I stuck on the stairs?
What am I stuck on?
Actually...
I'm stuck!
You can't get me!
Can I outrun them?
Oh, shit!
Wait.
Oh, wait.
No, I'm going the right way.
How did...
How did I manage to get so lucky?
Wait,
but...
Do I have enough time to explore this area?
Is the bigger question.
Okay, there's a lot here.
Let's keep... Let's get this ball rolling.
Wait, I can't see.
Actually, wait.
Drop, slide...
No, no, no.
Here we go.
There we go!
Here we go!
Insert!
Yes!
XE, thanks for the tech gifted!
Okay.
The eye!
They're like, yes!
We love the eye!
Eye is my favorite thing.
Just kidding.
Eye will destroy the universe.
Crush...
They will destroy all our planets.
It will even destroy me.
I will just become bone.
A new life will happen.
Oh my god!
No!
The eye sucks!
We hate the eye.
Eye sucks.
Burn the eye!
Eye is the worst thing ever.
Oh, build?
A thing to trap the eye.
Okay.
Huh?
Put the used ones here.
Okay.
Eye is cancelled.
So, yeah.
They blocked the signal of the eye.
It was like doing its thing.
And then they were like, no, no, no, no.
We don't care about you anymore.
Oh, bing-bong, bing-bong.
Oh, brain says, time to awaken.
Oh my god.
He's dead!
Bing-bong, bing-bong.
Everybody wake up.
No signal then.
They stay.
That's why they're not waking up.
Okay.
That makes sense.
That's why they're not waking up.
There's no...
No activity up there.
He's just like, me for real, for real.
There's not a single thought of...
Brain.
Too much brain rot?
Oh, this is literally me.
Okay, brain.
The brain.
You go in here.
And it monitors your brain.
Brain good.
Brain not so good.
Oh, you're asleep.
You're in the game.
You're playing Sword Art Online?
Oh, yes, grandpa.
Oh, they're like...
Oh my god, grandpa!
No, no, no, no.
Grandpa, grandpa, grandpa.
No brain activity.
Literally me.
Oh, but he made it.
Because he...
Fell asleep.
No sleep.
He's like...
I like the music here.
I'm grandpa!
Grandpa lived!
He's in the game.
What else is...
Oh, here.
Oh, come on.
You...
You!
Gonna drop the artifact here.
Gonna walk away.
Gonna go into the game world now.
Now.
What else can we see in here?
Well...
Not much.
Hold on.
Oh, I need that.
I need to actually...
Let's see.
Okay.
We need to open that up.
There's more... here.
I can't extinguish these.
Because I'm...
I'm a stupid alien.
Hmm...
So that's it?
That was it?
We got everything here?
I think?
Got what you needed?
Okay, cool.
Oh, we did it, you guys!
We did it!
I'm so relieved.
Oh, man.
I'm so relieved right now.
Holy moly.
Okay, that means just one more.
And then we figure out what the heck is going on with these.
Holy cow.
Um...
I guess I'll die?
Okay.
Oh...
You guys have no brain.
Ah, brainless, stupid.
No activity.
Nothing going on up there.
You wish you could have a single thought.
But you can't.
You have no thoughts, no thoughts, no thoughts.
This one's for me.
I wanna have no thoughts too.
Alright.
Um...
I'm gonna go make food.
And, um...
I'm going to...
Then we'll do the last one, which was the house...
there?
I'm nervous though that...
Um...
Good night, Minto.
Thanks for streaming.
Good night!
I'm still streaming.
Don't worry if you guys...
I'm still gonna be here.
I'm still standing.
I'm nervous about the next one though.
Because it seems more difficult.
But maybe it's not...
Maybe it's okay.
I don't know.
We'll see.
Back from food.
What did I miss?
Jeffrey, I finally did it.
I finally... Jeffrey!
You put me through hell, man.
I think this one is the most difficult.
Wait, the one we just did?
Or the one that we're about to do?
Because I sure hope it's the one we just did.
Oh yeah, I was pretty mad at you, Jeffrey.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh, the next one is the easiest one.
Oh, okay.
Good.
I'm glad to get the harder ones out of the way then.
Because...
Forbidden Archive.
Wow!
A library full of intact slide reels hidden deep underground.
There's a container marked with one of the vault seals.
Blah, blah, blah.
It's been destroyed.
I found a slide reel that shows the stranger's inhabitants analyzing the eye of the universe.
Intact slides reveal the construction and launch of a spacecraft designed to block the eye's signal.
Reveal the construction and launch of a spacecraft designed to block the eye's signal.
Yeah.
What do I do?
What?
Hmm.
I found a slide reel that shows two artifacts being lit near a green fire...
Wait.
Are we gonna have to do something like...
...Destroy the craft that's blocking the eye's signal?
I wonder.
I found a slide reel that shows two artifacts being lit near a green fire.
The first artifact lights after it's bearer falls asleep.
and the second artifact lights after the bearer dies.
I found a slide reel that appears to be some sort of error report.
It shows an alarm bell failing to wake up the stranger's inhabitants.
Okay.
I'm gonna let you guys listen to the music while I go get some...
We're going back to the... I think this is the first time I've ever taken the lift down.
Now that I think about it.
I'm gonna give you some of this ASMR.
I'm gonna get food real quick.
Real, real quick.
And I'll be back.
Once I... Once I have some food.
Okay.
Barely.
I'm back with food!
Yippee!
Yippee, yippee!
Okay.
Food break, everybody.
Food break.
Dinner break.
Scatter.
No!
Don't leave!
I'm checking my notifications.
If I'm ever midstream and you guys see that the Delta Collector's Edition goes on sale somewhere...
Will you guys let me know?
Tempted to grab some mallows.
I know, right?
I bought a, like...
A portable...
Marshmallow.
It's really like a portable fire.
But it's intended uses for marshmallows.
And you get some stuff.
Like some starter.
And you pour it in the center.
And then... Cause I always...
I had like a...
My favorite thing about marshmallows is how...
When they get toasty.
So...
Like they have to be set on fire.
You know what I mean?
And...
And so...
I got that.
And um...
Cause I originally bought... I really like... I don't know.
Maybe I just really like toasted marshmallows.
Because I had bought one before.
But it only like heated it up, you know?
So it still made it gooey.
But I like the crunchy.
It only made it kinda gooey.
But I love burnt marshmallow.
So...
Crunchy.
Yeah!
When they have the crunch on the outside.
And then you can peel off the skin.
And then you can eat the burnt skin.
So good.
Crunchier-blush... yeah!
I'm jealous.
I want S'mores.
I don't have them right now.
Two words.
Toaster oven.
Yeah but... Then I want to put this on the stick, myself.
Like I want to be able to roast it myself.
It brings out my child.
It makes me go, here look!
Come here, child!
Come on out!
I miss making s'mores with my friends.
If you miss it, then you should do it!
Say, hey guys, today we're making s'mores.
You get marshmallows in the shape of squares.
No, I normally just get the normal marshmallow.
Have a child!
Let me on the raft!
Never had s'mores?
I'll be honest, I like just the burnt marshmallow more than the s'more.
Usually, if I have an option for s'mores...
Because with like the graham cracker and stuff, you're gonna get full more.
So...
So I just eat the marshmallow.
I seem like the type what?
What does that mean?
Just a s'more, then.
Just the mo.
The marshmallow.
The mo.
Please stop eating burnt marshmallows.
I'm not it!
What do you mean?
You can't stop me!
This is such an awesome view.
That's not the sun at all.
That's um...
That's Brittle Hollow.
That's not the sun.
Look at all those stars in the distance.
Bursting though.
Hmm...
But yeah.
How are you guys?
What day is it?
Tuesday?
Do you have any fun plans this weekend?
Who's going?
Is anybody going to Anime Expo?
I have a concert.
It's not at Anime Expo.
But it's during Anime Expo.
Oh, that's Giant's Deep.
Just kidding.
Hold on one second.
There we go.
Too far away?
That's okay.
AX is overrated.
Nah, it's uh...
Like, even for me, I'm just like...
I don't know how people...
do stuff.
I feel like everything needs to be ticketed.
And like, I would feel less pressure if everything was, one, ticketed, and two, the tickets were given out before the convention.
You know what I mean?
Because it's just so busy.
And there's so much that's not ticketed.
And what I mean is like, the events and stuff.
Like, autographs.
Like, if you applied online and got everything.
There's... the lines are insane.
There's... there's... it's like almost impossible.
You have to pick, like, one thing that you really want to do, and that's basically your weekend.
Misty's talks.
Thanks, Minty.
But like, the amount of guests that are gonna be there this year that I...
that I have an interest in, I'm like...
I wish...
I...
Like, I'm gonna be there.
Because I'm gonna be there for the concert.
But... it's...
And then the lines on the summer heat...
Yeah!
It's awful!
What I mostly plan on going to do...
is like...
is like marketing...
myself.
I wanna go to companies.
Like...
The Blue Archive booth and be like, Hi.
Um, have you heard of Mint Phantom?
So I'm gonna basically only be there to be hustling.
Mm-hmm.
We're all networking.
I think there's like an industry...
There's... these conventions usually...
I mean, most conventions...
Um, have an industry party.
But I think the concert is...
I don't know.
I don't wanna do like anything before the concert.
Because I don't wanna...
risk it, you know?
Mm-hmm.
She's on the grind set.
I have to be!
It's just me, myself, and I!
If I'm...
If I'm not gonna do it, nobody's gonna do it.
Oh, uh-oh.
That was my controller.
We're all good.
Yay!
We get a song!
Window 10 user?
Wait.
Is there a different sound for Windows 11?
I've never heard it.
You should never hear it.
I have Windows 11 for my laptop.
Not by choice, obviously.
I don't like it.
I don't like it at all.
But...
I still use Windows 7.
Windows 7 was the GOAT.
I got...
It did the whole thing where it was like...
Um...
It keeps being like...
Oh, by the way!
Microsoft AI!
I'm like, please stop!
Please, Yamato!
The sun!
Praise the sun!
Don't look into the sun, you guys.
Don't look into the sun.
I can look into the sun.
I have ghost eyes.
Don't look into the sun.
Keeps looking.
What did you say?
I can't see!
Oh no!
We lost one!
Woah...
It looks like a giant...
Like cell.
Like it could split into two in any second.
You know?
That's what it looks like.
Oh, there's giant state.
Wait.
No, this is giant state.
That's giant state.
I was right about Brittle Hollow, was I not?
Or did I not?
Wait.
I can't remember anything anymore.
I'm almost done with my food, by the way, guys.
Don't worry.
I'm almost done.
I'm eating fast.
That was right.
That's the stranger.
Down by the river, stuck in my head all day.
I feel like...
Oh my gosh.
If they ever release...
A...
Like a super...
Okay, Jeffrey.
I'm pitching this to you.
If you're still here.
A VR version of this game.
And it doesn't have to be...
But it doesn't have to be like the full game.
Just like...
Just like very minimal.
I actually looked it up.
Like in...
What's it called?
In VR chat.
If there were any Outer Wilds worlds.
And there are actually.
There's a mod?
There's a VR mod.
I would become one of those people.
There's a Yudacamp game.
In VR.
If you guys didn't know.
And like all you do is just sit there.
And do nothing.
And that's what I would do.
I would exist in their headset.
I would just sit in here.
And I would listen to the music.
And the crackling.
I would just stare up at the sky.
I would be like...
I'm going to become one with my chair.
I'm never moving from this location.
I want to do some more VR.
Or maybe not VR.
Some like...
I want to do the...
The new WarioWare game.
Once I have like...
I don't know if you guys have seen it.
But the artist has been posting it on Twitter.
There's like a chibi mint 3D model.
That's getting made.
I want to try it with that.
Oh no.
That's the noise that Matara makes.
Are you going to watch the anime where the wife dies but reincarnates?
Oh the...
My wife is a...
Reincarnated as an elementary school student.
Or whatever.
No I...
I remember seeing all the people being mad about it.
But I heard the story was actually really good.
Don't judge a book by it's cover everybody.
Or...
A light novel by it's title.
My light novel titles are so long.
They're supposed to...
Because...
They just...
From what I remember...
And someone can correct me if I was wrong.
But the site that they were hosted on...
Didn't allow descriptions.
And so they had to put the description of the...
Of the...
Of the work into the title.
They had to work it in.
Yeah and so that's why...
You have all these titles that are like...
Ridiculously long and silly.
I've heard that explanation too.
Yeah yeah.
Unfortunate name.
Heartwarming story.
I mean I guess it got people's eyes on it.
And once it comes out...
I mean but the manga...
There was also like a live action I think.
The manga's been out.
I mean there...
You'll have people that will watch because of like...
You know the morbid curiosity type.
And then they'll see...
That it's not as bad as they...
.
And it's so crazy to see how dark it gets.
Oh my controller's going crazy.
For someone who's read it it's genuinely like...
Reincarnation sucks.
Learn to adapt laws.
Yeah reincarnation does suck.
Being a ghost is the best.
.
Don't reincarnate just become a ghost.
Okay, let me put my plate... I just finished too, so let me put my plate down.
Okay, awesome.
Yippee!
Alrighty!
We have our next thing that we gotta do.
I don't remember what we gotta do.
22 minute break over.
Alright, so...
For this one...
Uh...
This one.
Okay.
They go to the bridge.
I don't remember where this is at all.
They hand over the goods.
The codes.
They walk away into the woods.
Then they go through the fire, right?
Ah!
The fishing!
Sorry.
I always forget about it.
Okay.
Oh wait.
One second again.
My bad.
There we go.
Okay.
Okay!
And then they go through the fire.
So some people said this is the easiest one.
I sure hope you guys aren't pulling my leg.
Or my ghost tail.
Hope you guys aren't pulling my ghost tail.
I hate when you guys do the smileys.
I'm retracting that rule.
It feels like you're mocking me at this point.
It feels like you're mocking me.
I don't like it anymore.
Okay.
At least with this...
Coming in easy.
Oh!
Just kidding.
If I'm so fast and I leave the hatch before my helmet has finished putting on its head...
Do I die?
You know how like the helmet will like go over your head while you're...
When you get back up from the...
From the...
The seat?
Can we have a no-elp emote?
No!
You guys don't deserve a no-elp.
I don't even know...
I don't even know why you say it like that.
Someone said it's from Twitch?
You think we're on Twitch here?
Give me a break.
This is no Twitch stream.
Alright.
We don't have as much time here.
Because we basically have until the dam breaks.
Um...
This way.
So we're gonna have to...
Scadaddle.
I think maybe that's why I did the other one before.
I was just like, oh I have more time because...
Even when the dam breaks I can keep going.
But not here.
First what we're gonna do...
You made it to the party once before.
What's the plan this time?
Um...
We're gonna...
We're gonna look at the area...
In data mode.
We're gonna look at the area in data mode.
I don't quite remember where the bridge is.
Oh not this one.
There we go.
This way.
Oh maybe this is the bridge.
I think this is it actually.
But we have to...
Yeah.
I think so.
But we have to bring it into existence.
It was like around here?
Nope.
Just kidding.
Uh...
I'm lost.
Here?
Over here?
Yeah.
Right here.
Perfect.
And there we go.
Okay.
I'm trying to decide where I want to leave.
You know what?
I'm gonna leave it here.
Because we can see all through here.
Wow.
Wowee.
Oh wait.
I think there's the hand.
Wait.
No I don't.
No.
There's no...
Not...
Not yet.
Oh you can see him.
Well...
They can't see me in this mode.
So what if I just go in there?
Right?
The elevator.
Yeah.
That's true.
I can't remember where the entrance...
Oh.
Okay.
It's down over here.
Hello.
Sorry.
Continue.
Keep going.
I'm trying to see like how every...
Often...
I don't know.
A guy shows up.
Oh there's...
Okay.
I was gonna say there's something here.
It's just...
They can't even program...
Comfier chairs.
What is in this house anyway?
This is where they're all coming from.
What's over here anyway?
Look how close these two are together.
That's not fair.
Oh.
I was gonna say.
Back up buddy.
Back up.
Oh.
You can't go inside.
Ouch.
Okay.
Nevermind.
No worries.
Oh.
If I have to redo the loop this time it's okay.
Outer Wilds VR Mission.
That's literally...
Yeah.
There's no way you can't follow me.
So the...
At some point there will be two guys that are really close to each other.
But when it's those two guys, I can go.
I believe.
They look so similar to me.
Okay.
Can I just walk?
Do I have to go through the whole basement thing?
Can I just walk over there?
Let's see.
What is this?
This way.
Oh no, it goes underwater.
Good to know.
And then you come out on the other side.
Oh, then there's another guy.
Okay.
Hold on, my turn first.
My turn first.
I'm going.
Wow, it's so pretty in here!
This guy's slow as molasses.
You're going ghost?
I mean, this is just Minto World, is it not?
This is Minto Vision.
Essentially.
I can hear them.
They're little...
Okay, I wanted to... Oh, okay, there's nothing over here.
Well, good thing I didn't...
Oh!
Oh, they still see me.
Oh my god.
Yeah!
Oh, that's right.
They can still see me.
I just have to... yeah.
I just... I can hide better is what the... yeah.
Okay.
I don't know what to do.
Okay, well clearly...
Okay, first thing we gotta do is we gotta blow out...
the light, which was...
um...
which was...
uh...
somewhere.
Over here, maybe?
I think you may have actually figured out this puzzle previously.
Um...
Well, I did know how to get past them.
So I did... yes, figure that out.
Oh, no, this is to open that up.
Um...
How do I turn off the light?
Hold on.
I don't remember.
Oh, shoot.
What?
What's your goal now?
To sneak in!
I think.
Act natural.
Oh, shoot.
We're gonna follow...
Nothing?
I don't see anyone.
Where'd he go?
Ah!
Where'd you come from?
You jerk.
Okay.
What was it that I did?
I wish I could go back to the ship...
and watch the thing again.
No, they...
Oh, that was close.
What was it that they did?
They went...
Okay, hold on.
I'm trying to remember.
They like...
Went from the bridge, but it looked like some back way.
Or was it from the bridge?
I don't even know.
Maybe they did...
Eh?
I think it was from...
Maybe the bridge over there.
I see them walking.
Oh...
Oh my god.
Oh wait.
Grabby grab.
Grabby grab did something.
What did it do before?
What the?
Oh, shoot.
No!
Oh, I forgot.
Okay, we'll just meditate.
Shoot.
Oh...
Oh, god...
Uh
-oh.
What happened to the water?
Yeah, we can watch the log now.
We can watch the log.
We have all the tools you need.
Yeah, I know.
I'm just...
They walk...
I can't remember.
They walk somewhere.
Okay, hold on.
Okay, so yeah.
Wait, that is the bridge, right?
Is it?
They walk somewhere.
That has to be.
They walk through there.
To there.
Yeah, that has to be.
And then...
They walk through.
So does...
The light never have to go off at all?
The funny thing is she came to the conclusion and thought it out loud and she forgore.
It's so funny.
Why?
No way!
Am I that dumb?
Don't tell me.
Don't say yes.
What?
Wait, then if I already came up with the...
With the conclusion, you guys can tell me.
If I already came up with the solution myself, then you guys can let me know.
If I already came up with it...
Right?
You have to put two and three together yourself.
Oh, so it wasn't like... Okay, now that... Okay, that actually helps me more than you guys realize though.
Because if I had been like, wait, the solution... If I said the solution earlier...
While I was...
While I was doing the thing, then I would have... Like this whole part, then I would have been like, oh, okay.
What did I forget?
If I figure out the solution somewhere...
I'm so...
I'm so confused.
Mintomatics.
Thanks.
Thanks a whole lot.
Minto brain small.
What did I figure out?
Well, I... You know what, guys?
That doesn't actually help me at all.
Because I figured out so much today.
I've figured out a ton.
And...
So, it could be literally anything.
I'm...
I'm banning no ELP from my chat.
I hate it.
I actually hate it now.
Now, it actually pisses me off.
I'm banning it from my chat.
Wait, what?
What was that?
Up there.
Wait, can I get a hint where I figured it out?
When I figured it out?
What context I figured it out?
Two to three hours ago?
Oh, I always forget to wake back up.
If you didn't figure it out, it was unrelated.
I was just desperate to spoil the solution.
Well, now I feel even dumber.
Thanks.
So, I didn't even figure it out.
You guys are just...
Okey-dokey.
I did, just not that it was a solution to a puzzle.
Ah, I see, I see.
You're so tense that you didn't realize you figured it out.
There's our guy.
Is it one or two?
Huh...
It's two?
It's two of them.
So clearly, the solution is to blow their things out.
Ok.
So, we'll wait for these two.
Um, when the second guy goes...
Um...
That's when we can go.
I
don't remember where the entrance is, which is why I'm trying to get closer.
No one else has come yet.
Don't fall in the water.
Wait, where'd it go?
Oh there.
Right?
Here?
Yeah.
In fact, I'll just conceal just in case.
That thing just vibrated.
They can't see me.
Um, act natural everybody.
Act natural.
Okay.
Act natural everybody.
Oh my god, it's so loud.
Wait, I can't see.
Okay, we're fine.
Everything's good.
You jerk!
Close one.
Got a good look at him though.
He looked really cool like in the...
In the shadow, you know?
I don't think he's going to move.
I have a feeling he's not going to move.
Especially because when I came before, another guy was the one who came out and grabbed me.
A little shortcut with the grabby grabs.
I always forget.
I actually don't know... I don't remember where this one leads.
I don't remember.
Oh, I saw one I think.
Just going to go forward.
Oh shoot.
Why don't they stop coming?
How many of them are you?
This can be the easiest or the hardest depending on your big brain.
Oh gosh.
Guys...
Why is the game so dark?
Because it's dark!
I don't know where his path is.
Oh my gosh, wait, no... is that a... no.
I don't think that's another one.
I'm just gonna get up behind him.
Okay, easy mode.
Here we go.
We're following.
This one was the hardest for me?
Oh gosh.
No, why can't you guys give me a hint?
I've gone through so much, you guys.
Please.
Any help spoils the solution.
I'm trying not to get too close to this guy, but I don't know if there's someone...
I don't think there's anyone following him.
I think we're good, but...
Just to be... just in case, you know?
Look at him with his goat-like limbs and...
You?
I'm just following to the party.
Don't mind me.
Leave me alone!
But I came in with that guy.
He invited me.
He literally just led me there the entire way.
He led me there.
I was totally invited.
Okay, hold on.
I'm thinking...
Mm...
What is the thing that I can do here?
Hmm...
There's some elk... Minto is cute.
There's no help at all!
I think I had to look up a guide for this one- felt dumb afterward.
Oh yeah, we need a second Hirtian.
Why don't they like me?
What... shouldn't they be like, oh my god, what?
What are you?
You're so cool!
You're so cute!
And I'll be like, I'm so tiny.
I'm just a small alien compared to you guys.
At least bring a nice bottle of wine.
Is there a way to give a hint that won't spoil it?
Like a one word hint.
Is what I'm wondering.
No.
You can't get a bucket of water.
I know.
Outside the box.
A fire extinguisher on the ship.
I know, right?
I'm thinking.
Just pretend you're the delivery guy.
I know!
It's a me!
I delivered the pizza!
The pizza!
You did ironically solve this earlier.
I'm so... what?
I can't... It's been seven hours, please.
How am I supposed to remember everything that I've done and haven't done?
How am I supposed to remember everything that I've done?
Your brain has been working less ever since you're not as scared.
Oh my god!
Don't be so mean!
What are you talking about?
Oh my god!
So mean!
Wow!
Don't be rude.
Thanks for the gift, dude.
I'm thinking.
I'm thinking, girl.
First puzzle of the day.
Because I was thinking, I was like, does the...
I can't... Oh, wait.
Oops.
I forgot to do this back off.
I can't wait until the water because...
Because...
Unless I can.
I'm in a different building.
And that building over there, I think, doesn't get affected.
Oh, wrong way.
So maybe I can wait until the thing is destroyed.
Because I was thinking, oh, I can't wait for the water because it'll flood me.
But that's in that room.
This is the building across the way.
It should work.
I think.
Conceal.
Don't feel.
Don't let.
Well, I guess we're about to find out, baby!
Oh, shoot.
Wait, no, but the fire is still going to go out.
Ah,
see.
But...
Wait a second.
Do I...
Oh, wait.
Maybe I take a boat here or something.
Okay, hold on.
Maybe I take a boat.
From the tower.
Why am I going out the longest way?
Oh, come back!
Come back!
You're going too fast.
Okay, let's try it.
No, not the rock!
Dwayne.
Wait, is it Dwayne or the rock or Johnson?
Okay.
And...
Put you down.
Take you.
Pick up.
So maybe if I don't have enough time here, maybe I should start from here.
And then...
Go through the boat.
And like kind of wait it out until I watch them all burst into flames and disappear.
Well, I guess they wouldn't burst into flames.
But you know what I mean.
Okay.
Dwayne the rock.
Dwayne.
Dwayne or the rock.
Dwayne or the rock or Johnson.
They're brothers.
So that's all the hullabaloo...
Oh, silly.
All the hullabaloo we've been hearing screaming.
It's those guys dying.
Probably.
I hope.
Most likely.
Rock the rock Ron...
Rockston.
Dwayne or the rock or Johnson.
Oh my god.
Hold on.
Dwayne.
Rockston.
Knock on wood.
Dwayne.
Rockston.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Unfortunately, the camera is getting all the way to the boat.
Pass here.
Oh, I like the singing, though.
Who was singing, I wonder?
Maybe the guy... the one blocking the...
Okay, not here.
Oh boy.
Are we gonna make it?
I don't know.
It's not here.
Continue onwards!
Forward... whoa!
Forward march!
Trying to spread Ls just to take them.
It's this one, right?
I can't tell.
Yes, because these are their houses, right?
I think?
Wait a second.
Uh-oh.
I just realized something.
Well, I can...
Um... Isn't there a door here?
Oh...
Wait, I can probably open it from the other side.
Is there a Krabby Krab anywhere?
Or...
Um...
No way...
How did we...
How did we fumble so hard, everybody?
Gotta restart!
How did we fumble so hard?
Can I jump?
Onto?
Yes, we!
This is a collective effort!
We, we!
Yes, we, we!
You're going so far away from the shore, Little Boat!
Okay.
I think at this rate I should just meditate.
Because I can do the other.
Because, uh...
Because I can not go any further.
I was going to say, I'll just go back and do it, but I cannot.
Okay.
We got this, though.
We got this.
We know, hopefully, maybe the solution.
I think.
I think I have a pretty good idea of the solution.
I think so.
Do you trust?
Do you trust Minto?
I trust you with my afterlife.
Oh, my.
What?
Last, don't know what I meant.
You immediately thought outside of the box that one.
It was a no spoiler hit.
Sorry.
It's okay.
I accept your apology.
And I'm sorry if I'm a little sensitive.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, too.
Aww.
Hahaha.
We're... we're getting through this together, okay?
We're going to get through this together.
Oh, my gosh, you guys.
I have something to admit to.
I have a confession to make.
So, Metal Gear on Saturday.
I stopped at...
At Psycho Mantis.
Not because I didn't think I could beat him in time for Doki's outfit.
But also because I was afraid to ask how to change the controller.
Since I didn't know how to do it.
Oh, we're fine.
All we need to do is leave.
Oh, I forgot my suit.
Oh, no.
I put on my suit.
Can I open the hatch?
Oh, yeah.
We're fine.
Okay.
Anyway.
I thought I was about to die.
This is the top three worst landing.
What are you talking about?
But, yeah.
I was afraid.
I was like...
I don't know how to change the controller.
The controller port, too.
I should figure that out next... by next stream.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Push, push, push.
Wait.
Is that Super Chat a spoiler?
I only saw part of it.
Oh, no.
Can I read it?
I don't know.
I can't tell if I can read it or not.
Swap your keyboard to a different port?
I'm... I'm not using keyboard?
Oh, is there something I already solved?
Oh, okay.
I'll read it in a second.
Or I can read it once it pops up.
Wait.
Grab.
So... yeah.
That's why I was just like, you know what?
I'm gonna...
I was embarrassed to ask for help.
Oh, it's spoilers?
I can't tell.
Some people are saying it is and some people are saying it's not.
Well, anyway, thanks for the Super Chat.
Okay.
Fifty-fifty.
Bing!
One second nap.
I hope you're rested.
I hope you're well...
Feeling well and refreshed.
I was wondering if...
Okay, I'll be honest.
I was wondering about the door because I know how to do the door.
Obviously, because it's right here.
But I was wondering...
If I would have to use it.
Because I knew that I needed...
Oh, whoops.
I knew that I needed it for the boat.
But I didn't...
I guess I just didn't realize.
Okay, from here...
Now, we can take a boat.
And we can go wait in the other...
Oh, wait.
I should wake up.
Because I'm going to have to leave.
I'm going to have to leave.
Oh, wait.
Let's get the...
Let's do the...
I'm getting ahead of myself.
Because I got to do the bridge too.
Well, maybe.
Do I need it?
I'm better to have it than not.
Let's just do everything that we can do.
Do everything that we can do before we skedaddle.
Is it this way?
I can't quite remember.
Wait.
Where is it?
Did I not go far enough?
Further down, maybe?
Okay.
I'm getting all sorts of jumbled, everybody.
Oh, I didn't even cross the bridge.
I'm getting all sorts of jumbled.
Holy moly.
Okay.
We're good.
I think I understand what people are saying is a spoiler.
I have not played this game.
It's not so hard because people's definition of a spoiler will be different, right?
Like, you could think something's a spoiler and I'm like, hmm.
That's just...
That's whatever.
But also, I do appreciate...
Because if someone...
You know, unless I'm...
Unless I'm asking.
If someone's like, oh, have you thought about this?
But it's like not an answer, the actual answer.
And then I'm like, hey, I was able to figure out the answer because of your little hint.
So, but some people consider that a spoiler, you know?
Hmm.
Uh-oh.
Okie dokie.
So, I'm going to go to the tower now.
If I dip my toes in, does it...
I don't even need to dip my toes in.
All right.
Let's keep going.
Okay.
Wait.
Like a little bit.
Just a little.
So that I can get my scout.
Okay, I'll try from here.
Nice!
75%.
Okay, we got plenty of time.
We got plenty of time.
Okay.
Now we continue onward.
Grab my stuff.
Oh, oh, oh, whoopsie.
I don't know if this is a spoil, but in this game, there's a time loop or something.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
We haven't even reached, we haven't even gotten there yet.
Please.
It's kind of unnerving watching it count down.
It's just something ominous.
There's always something ominous about a countdown.
I don't know.
Always something like...
Something crazy is gonna happen.
I don't know.
Something ominous.
Damn, my bad.
You should... Yeah, there's finality, maybe.
Wow, that was smooth.
That was some smooth sailing.
It's starting to look a little...
A little questionable, you know?
49.
Hello, everybody.
I love... I love a group of free thinkers.
Or no thinkers.
I love no thinking.
Yes, I would like to also join the no thinking cult, please.
Yes, I don't want to think of her again.
Yes, take me with...
Take me with you.
I offer myself.
I'm gonna be like that guy.
No thought.
There is one place open and I've very much been wondering.
I thought it was...
Maybe a guy in here.
But now we know why they are all in here.
So now I'm thinking...
It's the guy with the cracked antler.
Because they scratched out his face on the wall.
They... They... That guy... That guy is...
That guy thinks too much.
I think.
Oh no.
I'm gonna get kicked out.
I just thought.
Uh oh.
I'm gonna get kicked out of the club.
That guy was just like...
Look, we can't live in Sword Art Online.
We have to... You know, our planet is gone.
We have to experience...
Other stuff.
And they were like...
No, we love our planet.
Reject new, embrace old.
Alright.
It sucks that we can't see the...
Um... Integrity of the...
Okay.
We're just gonna take it easy for now.
Until...
What about the boat candles?
Wait, you can do that?
You actually can.
Ooh.
But then... I think that's what's lighting this partially, right?
I don't think it'll move at all if we...
Blow them out.
We're just cruising.
Oh yeah, we'll know when it comes.
Those guys are gonna be screaming, hollering, hoopla.
So much happening.
Why does it feel shorter?
Hmm.
I'm getting... I'm getting restless.
I guess we can...
Maybe still go over there.
Hmm.
I think the first time I heard that...
Some scream...
From the...
Or from the dam...
Exploding...
Was when I was on the boat, actually.
And I was like, why'd they scream?
Meow.
Pretty sure BGA Final Fantasy Tactics...
There it is.
Did it with the main cast getting sucked inside a book in the MC Adventure to free everyone.
Alright, we're zooming!
We're zooming!
Oh!
There they are!
There they go!
Did you see that?
I just saw them dissolve.
I just saw them...
Yeah!
We just saw them burst into flame!
Oh, we're slanted a little bit.
Oh, oh, oh.
Yeah!
They're dead!
Wait.
Oh, here we go.
Haha.
They're all dead!
Wait.
Are they all dead?
I guess...
We'll still be careful.
Just in case.
Dead.
Oh!
That's my boat.
I was like, oh my god!
They're not all dead!
Because there could have been someone visiting from the tower, you know?
I think the tower is the only one that's...
Good.
Oh.
Wait.
No.
That's the night sky.
I believe.
Yeah.
The night sky?
Okay.
Good thing...
Good thing I set up the bridge.
Now I don't quite remember how to get in there.
Uh...
I wish I...
Um...
I wish there was a...
Wait.
There is a path.
There is a...
Right?
That I'll eventually run into.
Right there.
There we go.
That I'll eventually run into.
Uh...
Huh?
Wait.
What is this?
Where is...
Oh!
No!
This is not where I wanted to go!
I'm all backwards.
Oh!
I didn't use the glitch.
Oh yeah.
I'll try that.
Oh!
It's really scary going into pitch.
Wah!
Oh.
Okay.
Where is it?
Actually, I'm gonna go see if there's anybody left too.
I'm gonna go check.
Where the heck is this hole?
It's a hole in the ground.
It should be...
So...
Oh!
There it is.
I'm stuck pulling a double at work.
It's awesome having your stream to keep me company.
Oh!
Peg!
I'm stuck pulling a double at work!
You seem to be suffering more than me at this point.
Hey.
I'm all right.
We're okay.
I think we just solved a puzzle.
I'm gonna go make sure that there's nobody in here.
That's it?
Nice.
Okay.
All right.
Cool.
We're all good.
I think.
I hope.
Oh.
Whoops.
Definitely dead.
Donezo.
They're all gone!
You need the lantern.
I know.
That's...
I'm gonna go get...
I was...
I...
I literally said I'm going to go check to see if everybody's dead first.
That's all.
That's all I wanted to do.
Here we go.
Pick up.
Okay.
Don't worry guys.
I know.
Is it here?
Is it this one?
Is it this here?
No.
Oh my god.
I can't...
Wait.
Here?
Here.
Yaso!
Awesome.
That's why the guys didn't die in the other one too.
Makes sense.
Because they were in that high up building.
Right.
Okay.
Thanks for the preach!
I just walk on in?
Cool.
Here we go!
Wow!
Are those eyes or...
Those are lanterns.
Oh, okay.
Those are the... Okay, okay, okay.
Artifact does not fit!
Okay.
This one's a bit more peculiar, eh?
Oh, now we're going to be all mysterious and interesting?
Oh, awesome.
Let's see what we can do here.
Well...
Well, the artifact goes in here, right?
And then...
How do we get these, though?
Is my question.
Let's see.
Mint, what are you talking about?
We can't even get to them!
Minto, please!
I forgot it opened the door.
I don't remember now.
Thanks for the raid!
Slippy!
Thank you!
Okay, here we go.
Ooh!
The eye sucks!
The eye's going to destroy everything.
He sees everything from the eye.
Oh, my God.
Whoa!
The eye's awesome!
Wow!
Everybody, come look at the eye!
Where are we?
Thanks for the gifted!
Oh, oh, oh!
Eye, eye, eye, eye!
Eye!
That's everybody reaching up for Minto!
Spank!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
We...
We love the eye!
Oh!
They destroyed their own planet!
They destroyed their own home to build this thing to go search for the eye!
So they don't even have a place to go back!
Oh, you idiots!
You didn't even...
Oh, my God!
That's so sad!
Oopsie-daisy!
Whoopsie-poopsie is right!
Digital...
Digital world!
Digimon!
The strangers!
Stranger aliens!
Digital stranger aliens!
He's going along the little...
Down, down, down by the...
River...
Oh, yeah!
Okay!
Oh, my gosh!
To me, I was just like, oh, it's cool that they go through the caves to, like...
You know, but it's in pitch black, so it, like, helps load the next area.
But that's literally...
That's literally their game as well.
It's just a loading...
It's just a...
Oh, boy!
Oh, my gosh!
I can't wait to try this!
We're gonna go in the boat and then...
Okay, that's kind of fun.
Let's go try that.
If you die in the game...
Nah!
Oh, man!
We're no-clipping!
Oh, my gosh!
This is so exciting!
Uh, oh.
Okay.
Now, we...
Go all the way to the ship.
Actually...
How do we get to the ship?
Uh...
No, I know.
I know.
Don't worry, I know.
Okay.
This one's really cool.
Oh, my gosh!
I'm so excited.
Wait, so, will each loading area also have...
A...
Um...
Different...
Thing going on?
I'm so curious!
I'm so excited to try this out.
I hope we have time.
If we don't have time...
The next loop, obviously.
Hehehe.
Uh, where's the bridge?
Over this way?
I was wondering.
Like, in the... in the, um, little...
In their little...
What was that?
Did I say it over here?
In their...
In the slideshow, it showed that they had, like, fish and stuff in their...
In their rivers.
And I was wondering...
Before we knew that this was a simulation, I was like, I wonder...
Where are their...
Uh, like, the...
Some of the sounds we're hearing are other animals or something.
Gosh, it's really hard to navigate through here.
How the hell do I get home?
I...
I can't find the bridge!
The girl is so...
I'm very... I'm really lost, yeah.
I'm pretty lost.
I'm pretty lost, yeah!
I don't know where to go!
I'm... I'm trapped!
Oh!
Oh, thank goodness.
Okay.
We found it.
We found...
Wait, so, then probably...
I'm silly.
Probably...
I have to...
Um...
Blow out the candles then, right?
Actually?
There's a hand here.
But why can't I...
Was there another hand?
I just missed it.
Hm?
Just a silly.
One-way shortcut.
Oh, wait.
What?
That sucks.
Oh, I see it now though!
Oh, I see it, I see it.
Oh.
Okay.
Well...
Do a flip!
No, I can...
Wait, I think that's the music.
I think...
Maybe that was it?
No?
I thought I heard the...
But not yet.
Not yet.
Not yet, Snake.
No,
it's just ambience.
It's just ambience.
To the hole.
With the boats.
I see!
Oh, oh.
Oh.
Not to the hole with the boats.
Anyway.
Let's meditate.
I don't know if you can actually...
Is it...
I don't know if meditating under the water is like...
Is possible.
Okay.
Um...
Thinking if I should get some more water.
I think that's just called drowning.
I think so too!
Everything is so green.
Good morning world!
Oh, to be a Hearthian.
My mind is so expanded.
Not a single Hearthian here can understand what I'm going through.
Nobody here gets me anymore.
I don't even feel...
I don't feel...
I don't feel hurt.
I don't...
You guys, I'm beyond saving.
They're just like...
I don't...
They're like, gosh, what's wrong with them?
They just...
They wake up and they just take off.
They don't even say hello, goodbye, anything.
They just...
They literally just run to their ship and just take off into space.
Like they're a...
A natural.
Like they've been doing this since they were in the womb.
What am I?
Who am I?
Brain maxing.
I gotta get back.
I know, I'm just like...
I gotta go into the void.
I gotta go into the void of the...
I'm so excited to see what's in here.
Oh my gosh, you guys don't even know how excited I am to see what's in the void.
So much so that I did a perfect landing.
Let's go.
Yoink.
I'm also just very excited to be past those parts.
If there's more stealth, I'm sure that's fine.
But I'm very excited to be past those parts.
It has reinvigorated me.
We'll just go to the first one we can.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Whee.
Bunga.
Hehehe.
AI says we are concerned.
What are you concerned about, huh?
Tell me your problems.
I can help you.
What are your problems?
You're indeed done with stealth?
Oh my gosh.
It feels so good.
Yes!
Yabba dabba doo.
I can see why he says yabba dabba doo now.
There's just some moments when you want to say it.
You know what I mean?
She doesn't know.
Stop.
Now it's stealth chapter two.
Oh.
I can't tell.
Some of you guys...
I can't tell if some of you guys are trolling or...
I'm just gonna always assume that you guys are trolling.
Okay.
This one we can get...
We can get through to the bolts pretty easily so...
Good assumption.
Troll?
Awesome!
You're right.
You guys would never do that.
I trust you guys...
I think I trust you guys way too much actually.
And I never learned my lesson.
I trust you guys and I never learned my lesson not to.
So...
I just want to believe that you guys have the best interest.
We do but it's funny.
You're so...
You guys are so evil.
This thing is so much like the little pod or the little thingy in Death Stranding.
Boat time.
Ball time.
Oh!
Okay here we go.
Here
we go.
Ooh they're back!
Oh my gosh, for some reason...
Yes, they would be back.
It's a loop.
But my brain is just like...
Oh my god they're back.
Mia!
Scary!
No, no, nice ball.
Okay so I have to put this down right?
And in the dark...
Scary.
Goodness.
We vanish.
Time to break the game, exactly.
Wait, do I need to extinguish these or...
No, I'm just gonna leave.
Bye!
We're just a figment of your imagination.
Wait, I have to have the lamp?
I'll be honest, I thought in the thing it showed him putting it down.
I'll take the lamp.
Take the lamp.
That was cool though.
Wait,
so it's not supposed to look like that.
Now I'm scared even more.
Wait, so I'm gonna actually extinguish these.
Oh!
Now I know.
Okay.
Third time's the charm, everybody.
Third time's the charm.
Knowledge gained.
Now we know what happens.
Curiosity will get the best of us no longer.
The boats are afraid of the dark, okay?
Please understand.
Oh, I think we just lost that power.
Which...
Will that have any...
Or, not lost the power, but like...
Will that have anything to do with...
Hmm, I don't know.
I don't know.
We'll see.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
Oh!
I'm just gonna go here first.
We can actually walk around in the water!
Oh!
Wait, can I walk in that too?
I extinguished those candles for the first time in one of the caves and legit thought the game bugged.
Haha!
I guess I was sort of right.
Yeah, right!
Uh...
Can I...
Jump in here?
I guess I'll try.
Okay.
Now I know.
God damn it.
No!
Hahaha...
Now I know!
Fourth time's the charm!
I like going from this area though.
Well, actually, it's gonna be a little inconvenient once the...
Once the dam breaks.
Now we're gonna have to...
Now that I think about it.
Maybe we should start doing this from the tower.
But this one is just so easy to get to, you know?
I guess the tower one's pretty easy too.
Hmm.
We'll just keep going until we have to go to the tower.
Definitely we learned a lot today.
Oh yes.
And we will continue learning.
Until it is done.
All right, keep going.
Go!
Oh, the gorge is the fastest.
Oh yeah, we can go there too, right?
Weeeew.
Oh, I was gonna say it's different.
No, it's not.
It's the same.
Let's see.
What's this direction?
Ooooh!
Oooh!
We can actually get here!
Wait!
Am I on the other side?
Wait.
We've been here before!
This is that place?
Okay, what place have we not been to before, then?
Let's see.
Now I know how to get past.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh, this is the end.
Oh!
Nice!
Wait.
Wait, what is this actually?
Huh?
What is that?
Never mind.
I thought it was something else.
Oh!
These are extinguishing the...
The locks!
Ahhh!
Okay.
So we got that one.
Wait, can I just walk on this or no?
I can't tell what's real water and what's not anymore.
Hashtag free Mutara.
Yeah, the combinations are gone, but we can still...
Okay, I'm just gonna try walking on it.
This is real water.
Okay, okay, okay.
How can you tell what's real and what's fake?
Yeah!
Uh-oh, I think I'm stuck here.
So we do... oh wait, no, wait.
So we do...
Skill issue?
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
I can't get over to that one...
quite yet.
Hmm, okay.
So now it's a matter of figuring out how to blow them out.
Let's try over here.
What's going on?
There's even smoke here.
This place looks like it's on fire fire.
You have everything now.
Wait, actually?
Oh man.
Wait, there's a rock up there?
No way.
We're about to get a rude awakening.
Probably have an hour or two left.
Okay, perfect!
Awesome.
There we go.
This way.
Up's a daisy.
Okay.
The puzzle pieces.
We have every puzzle piece!
Now we just have to be big brained.
Hmm.
No.
But also...
I still don't know what that thing is.
The thing that's been...
That's been going...
I don't feel like I'm very close at all.
Unless...
Is it a thing that, like, activates...
Like, the movement?
Because I'm still convinced that we're moving.
Like, away from the sun.
Is it a thing that activates and starts moving us away?
I wonder?
Or...
Something like that?
Look at the map.
Wait, how do I look at the map?
Yeah, I can't.
I have no map.
Where do you enter the stranger?
Why don't you die to Supernova?
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Since we're far, far away.
So I am kind of right.
But it's us getting the heck out of here.
I like going through this one because...
Rather than...
Like, I like doing here because...
The tower, we know how much...
Like, once the tower tips, we know how much time we have left.
You know what I mean?
So it's...
I think it's a better gauge.
It's a better gauge of...
Uh...
Time for me.
Flavor plus assistance with the timing.
Plus you found the log that literally said Stranger Tic-Tac's Supernova and balls out.
Yeah, okay.
So I am...
I am on, like...
In the right mindset of that then.
Okay, that makes sense.
I was wondering if it was like something powering on or powering off.
Powering on...
Does make sense.
Okie dokie.
I don't think that's a spoiler.
I don't think so.
There's a diagram in the damn room that you found that shows it moving away.
Yep, yep, yep.
I did... I did see that.
But unless you like spend six minutes there, you don't see it update.
Oh, okay, okay.
Alright, here we go.
Whee!
So cool.
Okay.
It didn't light back up, did it?
The lock, I mean.
Oh no, I think it's...
I think it's...
This one.
This one that should be here, right?
Yeah.
That went out.
Maybe we don't even need to come here.
Maybe.
Actually, since I sent the boat...
Maybe I didn't need to go to the glitch zone.
Hold on.
I'm still looking around.
Boat is still on land side?
On my side?
Or over there?
Oh no, there's the boat.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, right.
Once I send the boat...
What?
It will just take me back and forth still, right?
So...
Hmm...
I never figured out a thing for this.
Did I?
I don't think...
No, I don't think I ever...
There never was.
Because we never were able to figure them out.
So...
What if I brute forced it?
What if I...
Oh.
Ha ha ha.
Started going on and off again.
Weren't there platforms here?
Or am I crazy?
I want to see the glitch world.
Yeah, that's what I'm...
Literally, that's exactly what I was just saying.
Let's see.
Put it down.
Go down here.
Oh.
Glitch world.
Can I just...
And there are platforms here.
Wait.
Wait a second.
What the heck?
I'm a secret genius.
Oh my god.
That's so funny.
It's
impeccable.
A genius taken before her time.
But now we know we can just go to the bell.
We don't have to go to the glitch world.
At least I don't think so.
You know what?
I'm gonna go to the back rooms.
Actually, I will go to the back rooms just in case we need that boat back.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
We're gonna have to unlock it again.
That's so true.
Never mind.
Yeah.
We're gonna have to unlock it.
Let's see what the ship logs say now.
Hey log...
Nothing.
Oh wait.
This one updated.
There's a container marked with the vault seal but its contents have been destroyed.
Intact slide reveals the sacrifice that was made to build the stranger.
I found a slide rail that appears to be some sort of error report.
It shows one of the stranger's inhabitants jumping off a raft during a transition between areas and falling below the world.
Very cool.
Okay.
Not the back rooms.
Yes, that is the back rooms.
That's the... that's literally the back rooms.
That's the... everybody raise your hand if you think that's the back rooms.
I'm in.
Hacker voice.
Guys, did I cook or did I...
Did I cook with that... that... that answer?
Did I cook or did I cook?
Great landing as always.
Thank you.
Keep cooking.
It's not over yet?
Okay.
So I must still continue to cook?
Wait.
I'm trying to decide.
Oh, well...
I'm just going to grab the artifact here and then we'll go back to the tower.
Nice.
The final cook down.
It's the final cook down.
It isn't raw.
But it's not well done.
It's a perfect cook.
Needs more egg.
Honestly, that's me with like everything.
Egg sometimes...
Wow.
Egg sometimes gives me like a migraine but I love egg.
I love it.
I love egg.
I feel like everything could use up.
Egg is just perfect for everything.
Egg soup.
Egg and ramen.
Egg sando.
Omelette.
I mean, I have to love an omelette.
I'm a maid.
That's why, you know, when Matara makes fun of me for liking tamago sushi...
It's just, you know, it's because I just like egg.
And then they sweeten the egg a little bit and it's so yummy.
Oh, I wish I could get some sushi.
Can't make an omelette without breaking a few eggs.
Thank you, Senator.
Wait, does he say it or does the other guy?
I can't remember.
Oh gosh, I gotta replay.
You know what's so exciting?
Whenever I play Metal Gear Rising again, it'll be my first time replaying it after having...
Like, played through the game.
So things are going to... I'm gonna get so much more of the references and stuff.
So excited.
Yeah, I'll get all the references.
We're making a mother of all omelettes here, Jack.
Into the void.
Into the unknown.
Well, I don't know.
I have no idea what I'm going to be singing at all tomorrow, you guys.
I might just like...
I was going to be like, I'm singing whatever I want because singing, you know...
You know, I'm not sorry.
Sorry, I'm not the best singer.
But singing makes me feel good.
And it's been a rough week for me.
Even though it's only Tuesday.
So I just was like, you know what?
I'm just going to do a karaoke.
To let it all out.
Yeah, Bucket.
We ball.
Exactly.
I... I'm not one to like...
You know, when I hear really amazing singers, you know, I mean...
Like I'm...
Please stop pat patting.
What are my absolute favorite people to watch?
Stop!
It's like, you know, I'm...
There's like...
Like, you know...
There's always going to be someone better than you, you know?
Or like...
Based on people's opinions or whatever.
Oh, hold on.
There we go.
I'm not one to be like...
How do I say?
Like...
Like when I hear such amazing...
Vtuber singers.
Like Elizabeth.
Like, I'm not like...
Oh, man.
I feel so...
Like it doesn't...
It's not...
It's not something that like makes me want to put myself down or anything.
Like I...
Think people having so much talent is like so amazing.
I bring her up because I've been watching her karaoke stream so much.
And I know other people are too.
Oh, wait.
We got to go to the other side.
But, you know...
I do think like...
It makes me want to improve if I can.
In that way.
I think it's...
I think it's really fun when...
Oh, wait.
Let's go put our little guy away.
I think it's fun, you know...
When people have, you know, different...
What's the word?
When like...
Oh, my gosh.
I can't see anything.
How do I say it?
If everybody had the same talent...
It would be so boring.
Is what I'm trying to say.
You know?
If everybody had the same talent...
It would be like...
Oh, everybody can sing.
There we go.
Oh, there we go.
So...
You know...
Even if I'm not the best singer...
I maybe still have other stuff.
So, it's okay.
Wait, can I do it from here?
Or do I have to...
Oh, I can.
Nice.
Easy peasy.
Yeah.
You need your artifact?
No, I don't.
What about the last one?
No, this one?
Let's see what things do.
Hmm.
No way.
You thought you'll use one secret to solve two puzzles.
Shut up.
Please don't sell yourself short.
You know.
But, okay.
I have a question.
Is everything that I...
Like...
That I need to solve this in this vicinity.
I guess.
Because I think...
I think I saw some...
Oh my goodness.
How am I supposed to go back upstairs?
I saw some people say like...
Maybe check the logs again.
But...
I haven't looked at the logs.
So...
Will I be able to solve it if I haven't looked at the logs?
Hmm.
I have all the information to solve it.
It's technically...
No.
Wait.
What do you mean?
It's in the ship logs.
Hmm.
Can I go back upstairs?
Oh...
So.
That's the end.
Thanks a lot for letting me tell you.
That's okay.
You don't have to bring it.
Thank you.
It's...
Another...another thing.
Okay, hold on.
I'm thinking.
Oh, that's so funny.
I forgot that this one was broken.
Where are you going?
Why?
Why did you leave me?
Okay.
Just remember what you learned from each stealth section.
A whole lot of nothing.
Unless this is a similar thing where I have to...
Wait.
So I've noticed...
I'm noticing this.
This is like the big key here.
The...
The light that is shining from the ceiling.
So it must be that I have to wait for something.
Right?
To cover that hole.
Because otherwise...
Otherwise there's no way I'll be able to get through.
Is it?
Oh, am I wrong?
Hmm...
I can't go back...
Oh man.
If I have to go back all the way to the ship logs, I might as well just meditate here.
Okay.
I'll go.
Go back to the ship logs.
I might be able to get back to the ship from here.
Maybe.
Is it coming?
Wait.
Oh, there it is.
Just takes a second.
Oh my god!
I almost got squashed!
Almost got squashed!
You just made me realize what that heavenly light is actually referencing slash communicating.
Oh.
I'm glad that I helped you with that.
Where are we?
Oh.
We're inside the bell.
That's right.
Oh.
Okay, guys.
I think it's just time to meditate.
At least it's easy to solve the first two.
You can like make, you know, you can pick fun at me, but like calling me dense I think is kind of mean after I've been streaming for eight and a half hours and, you know, I think it's a little rude to say something like that.
So maybe...
I wasn't even looking at chat.
I don't even know what you guys are saying.
So maybe...
I just looked over and that's the first thing I see.
So maybe don't be so mean.
You know?
I'm not gonna remember everything in the world.
So, you know.
There was somebody that said it.
It makes me, you know, I enjoy playing games like this, but like sometimes...
And I know that I'm like, oh please help me!
but it's very...
This is... It does make me never not want to play games like this.
When people immediately insult me.
if I don't get the...
If I don't get the...
the answer right away, so you know.
So I want to Okay, what am I looking through?
The archi- was it the archives?
Error report.
Shows an alarm bell failing to wake up strangers in habitants.
So I need to be dumb to not wake up the bell.
Alarm rea- or slide reel that appears to be some sort of error report.
Shows an alarm bell failing to wake up the stranger's inhabitants.
This one was... I know someone said about the error report, so let's see.
Shows one of the strangers having to be jumping off a raft during- Okay, that's the one we did.
Uh, wait.
Um, this one?
Shows one of the strangers having to be dropping their artifact on the ground.
Okay.
So it's this one.
You can scroll to see the slide reel.
Wait, what do you mean?
Oh, thank you!
Oh, it's only three.
Wait.
I don't think I can.
Why is it- why does it only show three things?
Or- oh wait, okay.
Maybe it's, uh...
This one?
Yes.
Okay.
Mm-mm-mm.
Oh yeah, there were three reels in the place.
Thank you guys, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Non-working button prompt- What are you talking about?
It worked!
If no brain activity...
Then, no disconnect.
If no brain activity, then no disconnect!
So...
I already knew that information.
But it's still...
No brain, no problem...
Do I have to die?
Why?
You're already deaf.
It's a good thing I'm not.
Never would hear all the good voice acting in games.
Okay, because we can't... if we're asleep then we obviously wake up, but it has to be that we have to be dead.
How do we die?
You are already dead.
Hold on, I gotta go get some...
My throat is really hurting real quick.
So give me, sorry, give me like two seconds to go grab some hot water.
Sorry, it like... it was hurting earlier, but I was like...
Since I'm just chilling here, I'm gonna go grab it real quick.
Real quick!
I'll be right back.
Okay.
She's in the VR world.
No.
I'm back.
No, that's what I'm supposed to be saying.
I'm supposed to be saying okaeri to you.
Oh my goodness.
I feel like I might overthink this one.
A little bit.
How do we die?
But also...
Die in the game.
People overthink Outer Wilds all the time.
There's more slide reels?
But...
This one shows the brain activity.
And you go in.
And it's like, yeah, I'm sleeping.
I'm taking a little nap.
And then it goes inside the fire and the old man dies.
Wait, do I have to die by the fire?
Wait, do I have to die...
Wait.
Oop.
My bad.
As long as I'm within the range of the fire.
Maybe I could die... death by fire.
If I die by the fire...
If I die by the hands of the fire...
I am dying within the range of the fire.
I think.
Yeah, we're...
Oh my gosh.
You all told me to cook.
It was a hint after all.
That was the hint that we needed.
Just cook.
Oh my god.
You guys do love me.
You helped me after all.
Oh my god.
Good landing.
Perfect landing.
This is the ending.
So we're going to...
go to...
Okay, so first we're going to go to the places that we've been going to.
Like I'm going to go to the tower first.
Wait, do we need to?
I guess... Yeah, I'm going to go to the tower first.
Because...
Um...
I want to get to the boat.
Yeah.
And then do all the boaty things.
And then once we're done with the boaty things, we...
can...
wake up.
And then die.
Yeah, we need at least one loading zone.
Exactly.
So, we'll do that.
Interesting that like...
we have... like the fire...
seems to be...
related to the ghost matter.
But when we're by the fire, we don't get a ghost matter...
like...
notification.
Guess I'll die.
So real.
But...
Death by fire.
Into the video game.
And then once we...
Wait, but won't we be dead?
You know what?
Let's not think too hard about it.
You know?
Whoa.
Wow.
I mean, if you die in the game, you die in real life.
That literally doesn't apply to me.
So...
What am I gonna do?
Die again?
Yeah, we've already died so many times.
Let's one more.
Exactly.
I always love you...
but I've never...
played, so no help.
It's okay.
I'm glad that you're watching...
regardless.
Because I know a lot of people...
don't wanna watch...
Outer Wilds streams...
because they wanna experience it for themselves.
And I totally understand that.
And we're on part three of...
of a...
eight hour...
nine hour long stream now, almost.
So...
I get it.
Okay.
I appreciate you guys watching.
And anyway...
and you know...
There...
There's always like a...
you know...
being a content creator, right?
You have to think of like...
what's the popular thing...
versus...
what's the thing you want to do.
And truly like...
these kinds of games...
are like...
Sorry, my fan was making my like...
dress blow...
kind of weird.
And it was making me like...
feel like someone was touching my arm.
So it's kind of like...
you know...
when you play...
longer games...
it's...
it's much more...
feels like a...
a passion...
something that you would want to do.
You know what I mean?
That's why, I know.
Toonic Next?
Oh Toonic, um...
Kiara really liked that one.
Didn't she?
She like...
wanted that to be...
Game of the Year or something, right?
That's how...
that door opens?
Oh!
I'll always watch...
BitPlay anything.
I appreciate it.
You know.
Yeah...
Cause it's always just like...
What's the popular thing?
Saying what's gonna give me the views and then obviously what's the thing that I want to play and want to experience.
And this was one of them.
This is something I really really wanted to play.
Just streamer things.
I missed out.
8 hours was working.
Here we go.
We're in like endgame now, right?
So...
Tunic is great.
Is FNAF a popular streamer?
Streamer?
Oh my gosh, Freddy Fazbear, my Oshii streamer.
I don't know.
I can't... sometimes I can't really tell what's popular and what's not.
Even though it's my job.
She's gonna meet Matara.
Oh my god.
Is this... is this...
Is it Matara time?
Soon.
Matara time soon.
Wait.
Drop artifact.
There we go.
This should be far enough.
Yeah.
Perfect.
Okay.
We should play Suica game.
You know what?
I've never ever played Suica game before.
Even when it was so popular everybody was doing it, I had never played it.
When you're done with the DLC, I really recommend watching an Outer Wilds 100% speedrun.
They do some wild things, especially in the DLC.
Oh yeah, that sounds awesome.
Speedruns are so interesting.
It's kinda awful, but fun.
Yeah, that's the general consensus, right?
That's the general consensus, I'd say.
Uh...
Let's light some more pathways.
And such.
So I'm not completely blind going up here.
Pull the lever, Kronk.
What's your plan?
I think I'm gonna death by fire, I think.
Wah, Joy!
Thank you for the 50 gifts and thank you so much!
Mmm.
There's like a multiplayer now though for Suica game, so I think a lot of people have been playing it more.
Not a lot, I say that.
I usually forget solutions, so I'll be fine if I decide to play.
I think this is the only thing I know to do.
If I die, I die.
But...
I think I must die within the vicinity of here.
I don't know if the...
I don't think the elevator counts.
Is this what you would do to wake Amatara for the pause?
Wow, my controller is shaking so...
much.
Wait!
Wait.
Oh, oh, oh.
Right, right, right, right, right, right.
Okay, now we go to the...
I was like, wait a second.
Huh?
Yeah, I died in the game.
I was confused for a moment.
I was like, wait, how do I have all my stuff?
Okay, now we go to the bell.
I believe.
Echo bell.
And then...
Hopefully this works.
I hope this works.
I just got fired!
Oh, Saio!
I'm so sorry!
I'm so sorry.
90 degree over here.
Everybody be careful not to get...
Now that it's actually summer.
Careful not to get heat stroke or anything like that.
It'll be spicy outside.
Yeah.
Okay.
Over here to the bell.
The structure.
Okay.
Now we die here, everybody.
It's been an honor.
Everybody...
Play...
What's that song they play in the Titanic?
Wee!
I hope this works.
There's even one left!
Oh my gosh.
I hope this works!
It worked!
I cooked.
I cooked!
I cooked myself.
I cooked the meal.
So now it shouldn't go off at all, right?
I guess we'll test it.
We'll test it.
Well, I guess also...
They still go off.
I just hear nothing.
Wow.
This is kind of dark, right?
It's kind of sad.
It's kind of dark.
Oh.
Here we go.
No turning back.
Okay.
I'm scared.
What?
Thank you for the...
Well, it's worth watching you solve this game in some really creative ways.
It was a blast.
So hopefully food, bad eggs have a sour to your enjoyment.
Thank you, Jay.
I really appreciate it.
No, no.
Thank you.
It's really dark.
I can't see a single thing.
Just a little bit of the walls.
It's so dark.
Oh, there's a light.
There's a staircase.
There's some creepy sounds.
So, I'm going to go to the other side.
There's some spooky sounds.
What's in here?
Oh.
Wow.
Okay.
Oh, it's a...
It's a room?
Oh.
Wait.
I haven't looked through here yet.
I can look through.
One, two...
Oh, they're looking at the planet.
Their home planet.
Oh.
Insert the card.
Oh, what's going on?
Okay.
Here?
Nothing in here?
Anyone around?
What is this?
What is that?
There are instruments.
Okay.
Boat.
Their game, it's like a, it's like showing their, what's it called?
Hi!
Wait, it's him!
It's the guy with his... with the, with the, with the, with the... trailer.
Oh my god.
Hi.
Talk to the Prisoner.
So he has been in here.
Who are you?
I thought I would...
Oh, sorry.
I'm in your way.
He's trying to walk.
I'm just standing here.
Thank you.
Okay.
He woke up before them.
What the?
Why?
Why did you do that?
He was just like, Yawn, I'm gonna casually unleash craziness upon the universe.
And they sealed him away.
Yo, that's so dark.
And they were like, no, no, no more eye anymore.
We hate the eye.
Isn't it the same as...
Oh gosh, that one...
That one...
No-Mayan who was just like...
I thought the eye was evil, but it's not.
So they saw the vision...
Already holding artifact.
Oh, thank you.
Maybe...
Maybe they saw...
Maybe the vision they saw was if the...
Was if there's no...
Oh, we're showing him our memories now?
Hello?
I don't know what's going on.
Oh!
You good?
Oh, there you go.
Oh, sorry.
I have to hold it.
Oh!
It's me!
The signal...
What?
Oh, this is the first...
Okay, yeah.
This is the first time because then they launch to the...
The thingy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then...
And then they all die because of the...
Internal burn.
Then that's me!
Well, that might not be me.
It might be someone else, but you know.
There's someone!
It was just like...
Whoa!
That's crazy speak.
That's me!
Feldspar, yeah.
Whoa!
Aww!
Can I ask him...
He had another question though.
Where are we going?
Artifact does not fit.
There you go.
Vision torch.
That was so good.
Made me kind of teary.
Wait!
Oh, wait!
Did I get duped?
Oh, no!
Oh!
Maybe it's not so bad.
It's nice and quiet in here, you know?
Wait, I hear something.
It's through your efforts to release the echoes of the eye that the new mind reached our solar system and gave me.
Oh, I don't think I was supposed to read that.
Well, I can go up to Logan.
Bye!
So pretty.
Where are you, friend?
I released you.
Please don't jump scare me.
I will scream.
Oh, it's not a spoiler?
Okay.
No, stop!
We're gonna go travel together!
Where is he though?
Footprints.
Oh, thank you.
I can barely see them.
Oh!
So he's like, wake up.
Wake up, man.
Wake up.
Okay, here I go.
I'm gonna wake up!
We freed him though.
Now we can't wake up.
But we can.
But we can't.
But we freed him.
Now beat the game for a new ending.
Oh, okay, okay.
Um...
Does that mean I have to go back into what's it called?
Wait.
I'm trying to remember how to beat the game.
Do I just go to the moon?
Wait, how do I beat the game again?
No, I have to go to the Bramble?
No way.
Oh no, I have to go to the Bramble!
You'll like the new ending, I hope.
That's a big ask, for real.
Just going, casually going to the Bramble.
Okay.
Oh well, luckily...
I will need your guys' assistance here though, if that's okay.
It's because...
First of all, let me go find it.
Because...
I don't quite remember...
everything about how to...
navigate the Bramble, so...
Thank you for the...
Thank you for the Akasuba!
Thank you!
Wait, I can't...
Oh, it won't let me lock on it.
Oh no.
Ash Twin for the Warp Core.
Oh gosh, you guys are...
Oh my god.
Wait, this is...
Oh my gosh, I don't remember how to do any of this!
Oh god.
Okay.
Guys...
I'm gonna do my best.
I hope I can do it in this...
Oh my god, I don't remember how to do any of this.
This is pretty bad.
I didn't realize I was gonna have to do the game all over again.
But I go on Ash Twin and I wait for the sun?
Oh my god.
Oh gosh, this is so bad.
Thank you, Asu!
And I just kind of like orbit around here until it dissolves enough, right?
I think I remember...
It's like using the landing mode.
What the hell?
There we go.
To find it, maybe?
Okay.
Which tower is it?
I don't remember!
Oh my gosh, you guys.
This is really bad because I don't...
I'm not gonna remember anything.
Oh.
You need the escape pod rai...
Wait, there's so much stuff that I need first?
This is so bad because I should have...
If I had known all of this, I would have done it on my...
I would have done it on my old account.
Oh no.
What?
This is...
Oh no!
Because I'm gonna need you guys to like handhold me through everything.
Because I don't know what I need to do.
And that's gonna be really frustrating.
Oh my god.
You can look up the codes.
But don't I still need the Ash Twin thing?
I need the...
I need to turn the thing off.
I need to turn off the project.
It's the Ash Twin Towers here.
Okay.
And then when I go to the fish, someone said find Feldspar.
How do...
I don't...
Do I locate him with the...
Oh no!
Oh my gosh.
Swipe the core from the ATP, fly to the vessel, through Bramble, input LXN into coordinates.
Okay, which...
We can get the...
We can get the coordinates.
Let's watch a speedrun right now and do what they do easy.
Oh my god.
This is so...
I just watched a video because I couldn't be bothered.
That's...
You know, that's so fair.
That...
You're so valid for that.
Google the ending.
Give me the controller.
I'll do it.
Yeah, I already have Solanum.
I already got them.
Let me just try once, I suppose.
I don't think it'll all come back to me in this...
In a glorious moment, I'll be honest.
I don't think it'll come back to me at all.
But...
No, no, no, no, no.
Get me out of there.
But...
Okay, there's the sun.
We need this one, right?
Because we're...
Wait, hold on.
No, it's that...
It's the twin tower, right?
Wait.
The sun is to go to the sun station.
We need the twins.
Stranger, I'm gonna get you out of here.
I don't wanna...
You know...
I'm gonna just unclick you for now.
Oh.
I'm just gonna un...
There we go.
Okay.
But the broken roof.
Yes.
It's like...
I remember the timing is quite tight.
Because there's like Bramble in there and stuff that I have to get through.
Very quickly.
Was it that?
That was it?
Right there?
Wait.
Oh.
I lost it.
There?
Is that it?
Don't remember which one it is though.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I think if I land like here, I'm safe.
Probably.
We need to...
Go to the vessel once first.
You can reach it again with the marker like you used for the stranger.
The vessel?
Why do I need to go there?
Hello, interloper.
It's all your fault.
Okay.
But people said that I can just get the eye cords from...
Wait.
Is this the one that's broken or that one?
Not that one.
Maybe this one.
Wait.
People said I can just look up the coordinates.
So I think I'm just gonna do that.
Not gonna lie.
I think I'm just gonna look them up.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
So even if I don't have it, I'll just look it up.
It's no biggie.
Am I still on the equator?
I don't even know where the vessel is.
Why did I do it on this save?
I thought it would be safe.
Oh man.
I'm so...
I don't even remember how to do this part either.
Oh gosh.
I think I would just prefer to watch the ending.
If that's okay with you guys.
You know, I've already done all of this before.
Oh my god.
And if you really want to see me do it again, I'm sure there are ways.
You know, it might just be projected into your brain.
I can do it with my ghostly powers, you know?
So... I think... I think because there's like multiple things about this where I...
You know...
Okay, so what is this one?
I... If I had... What's the word?
If I had...
If I had done this on the save that wasn't completely wiped, I'd be more down for doing it.
But...
Right now, it's just not feeling...
so great.
Am I... I don't even know if I'm in the right one.
I don't think I'm in the right one.
Congrats on getting through the DLC, but I had a great time watching you cook figuratively and literally.
Thank you.
Maybe I was in the right one.
Wait.
This goes up.
Maybe I was in the right one.
Wait.
I don't think I'm in the right building.
This is not the right... This is not the correct building.
Wait.
Then do I...
Oh.
I was supposed to walk in the purple.
Okay.
Hold on.
We'll wait.
Just to watch a video.
This could take some time.
I completely... You guys, please understand.
It's been so long and also...
So much has happened since I last played.
I think...
You know... It doesn't...
feel so great.
Just because...
Because it's just of watching a video.
It's just...
For the sake of my mental health.
What do I...
Oh.
Outer Wilds ending...
Okay.
It's 20 minutes long!
This person's video is 20 minutes long!
No way!
Holy cow.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm gonna check it real quick.
I'm gonna turn off the audio so you can hear it.
Okay, just pretend it's me!
Okay?
We'll just...
We'll just all pretend it's me, right?
Yeah.
I won't... I'm not even gonna... Hold on, I'm gonna make sure there's no...
Okay, I'm gonna pretend there's no voiceover or anything.
Okay.
It's... Alright.
Spend the next 20 minutes with me, everybody!
Give me a second, I'm gonna put it up on the screen.
I'm gonna full screen it.
There we go, 1080p.
Okay, just pretend it's me.
Just pretend it's me.
Okay.
I gotta resize it.
Give me a second.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh, hold on.
Let me get you guys in as well.
Everybody in?
Come on in!
Oh.
Hold on.
Everybody in!
Come on in!
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
You guys are in.
Okay!
This is me putting in the coordinates!
Oh, audio, don't go.
Sorry.
This is me putting in the coordinates!
Yes!
Oh.
You almost... I almost have... Hold on, I'm a little clumsy.
Yes!
Oh.
Boom!
You messed it up.
No, I didn't!
Oh my God, we're at the eye.
There it is, the eye!
The eye of the universe.
We're seeing it.
Together.
Oh, get there faster!?
No, we're savoring this moment!
We're on the I...
It's heavy, I can't do it.
I can't fly.
It's too heavy.
Just a lot of breathing.
Minx, you're so good.
Thank you!
Are you just missing kind of bad here?
Yeah, this is Minto Gaming.
Quantum fluctuations everywhere.
I'm just making sure.
Look up?
Oh, sorry.
I can't do that right now.
I'm Minto Gaming.
It's too dark.
Quantum!
Everything is quantum right now.
This part was so freaky.
Gamers don't look up.
Exactly!
I didn't even flinch.
I'm so brave.
I'm so brave!
No hesitation.
I'm in the cheese!
Maybe I wasn't supposed to go in here.
Hold on.
I'm leaving.
No, I was.
I'm supposed to go up into the space.
I'm supposed to go up?
Yeah, I'm supposed to jump into that.
Into the eye, baby!
I'm tempted to watch the game and beat it faster.
Shut the hell up.
Music is so dramatic.
Oh, all of them.
Horn... Hornfels?
Feldspar?
Everybody's gone.
Everything's gone.
All of our friends.
Yeah.
The evolutionist.
The evolution of Ghost Rider.
A ghost gamer.
No, I will credit this person in the description.
Don't worry.
I'll credit them.
Text missed.
There it goes.
There goes the universe.
I can hear crickets.
I don't remember this happening in Interstellar.
There was a spooky part in this.
I remember.
Sorry for the quality.
The bitrate.
I remember I got jump scared by a fish here.
Wow, it's so beautiful.
Sorry for the bitrate.
You know.
Wow.
Oh, it's dead.
Wow, another universe.
Oh.
Oh, I just destroyed it.
Oh, my God.
I'm...
I am out of control.
There are people living there.
No!
Oh, my God.
I just can't help but destroy everything.
I'm a monster.
What's wrong with me?
Why am I like this?
It's because I didn't get enough love.
And no Elp.
If I have no Elp, no one can.
Oh.
Oh, God.
I'm not gonna get jump scared.
I'm scared.
Wait.
The bitrate is so bad.
Quantum rock.
It's gone.
There was a rock here.
It's gone now.
I was a certified elper, but never a spoiler.
Incoming mouth breather.
It's me!
It's you, it's you, it's always you.
Everything I knew.
It's me.
Shoot your scout at him.
I did that!
I shot my scout!
And he turned into a tree.
And then... it all comes back to marshmallows, huh?
Wait, is there a fish?
Please.
No fish, no fish, no fish, no fish, no fish.
Ghost.
Ghost, ghost, ghost.
I mean, technically, yeah.
Esker, do you hear music?
I do really love this ending.
If it wasn't such a pain in the neck to have gotten to it in this playthrough, I would have done it.
For sure.
Stop flashing the... gosh.
Oh, you have to do that.
Evangel.
It's one of the most fulfilling moments.
It is, it's so good.
Such a good ending.
It's not quite time yet.
Pretty sure you'll need the others for the next part.
No rush, take your time.
The quiet shade.
Oh gosh, is there a fish?
It's always dark.
Whoa.
There he is.
Does this ending have the prisoner?
It does, yeah.
I made sure.
That bush looks like Shrek.
This ending is crazy.
What are you talking about?
What am I wrong?
Oh, because... no, I just didn't want him to flash it so vigorously is all.
I love this part.
Whee!
Whoa.
Beam.
Wow!
Whee!
We're traveling!
Oh, this is a video.
Shh.
No, it's not.
It's Minto Gaming.
Solanum.
Come here, you.
My friend.
I wonder... I'm curious how we get the prisoner.
I hate that part.
Very brave.
What is this?
Is this him?
How did this become iron lung?
Is this the stranger?
Yeah, it's the tree.
Wow.
Oh!
Right here, right here.
Oh, here we go.
Oh!
The ground is opening up.
So cool!
Oh!
It's literally like their coffin.
Wait, look at the pictures.
Oh!
That's me!
Oh my god!
Wait!
That's not me.
Oh!
I don't know why.
There's other candles.
Oh, they're gone in the pictures.
Oh, they're gone.
That's me.
Extinguishing each species.
Oh god, don't turn around!
It's literally a tombstone.
Connection with Scout is lost.
There he is!
Oh!
You're allowed!
Come join the party!
When my kind found the eye and realized what it was capable of, they were terrified.
It was too difficult a truth.
Like a light too bright to look upon directly.
It burned them.
What they could not unlearn was hidden away in darkness.
Obfuscated, then lost.
Oh.
My kind weren't always like this.
They weren't always so afraid.
I did what I could to set things right.
Yeah, I am still of my kind.
And you know now what they did.
I cannot promise our fear won't stay in your mind.
And so a choice.
Are you certain you want to remember me?
Wah!
Join us!
I don't want to repeat my kind's mistakes.
But if you're willing to take the risk, then so be it.
What if I told him that his journey ended here?
It would be so sad though to not have him around.
Everybody's here!
We've come this far.
Might as well join.
Right!
His song sounds so sad even.
Church particularly stumps people that never use the signal scope.
Yeah, I could get that.
I think it even stumped me for a minute.
What do you say?
Harmonica!
I hadn't dared to hope that anyone would hear the signal for how briefly I set it free.
Yet here we are.
Are you ready for the final step?
Then it's time.
Time to send our spark out into the darkness.
Oh, it's so sad!
It sounds like the thing you use with your hands.
This song is new to me, but I'm honored to be part of it.
Theremin!
Yes, thank you.
You still have two more people!
Come on!
Thanks for the endurance stream.
This is the best I've been able to understand and follow along with the story because of it being in one stream.
I wasn't smart enough to beat the base game.
Oh, thank you!
Yeah, of course!
You're creating the new universe!
What a coward throwing away the marshmallow.
How dare you!
I forgot this wasn't you.
Shh.
It's okay.
The immersion, you know?
I believe we've reached the end of our journey.
All that remains is to colla- oh.
Are you ready to learn what comes next?
I admire your curiosity, my friend.
How beautiful.
It's different than I envisioned.
Whatever happens next, I do not think is to be feared.
Bran, thank you for the 50 gifted.
Thank you!
Oh!
Yippee!
Not my eyes!
We were stuck in darkness for so long, you guys!
Get used to it!
There's still so much time.
I wonder if it's just the credits.
Outer Wilds...
Yay!
Is the thing after the credits also new?
Such a beautiful game.
Thoughts on the DLC?
Oh my god, I loved it.
Loved it so much.
Geoffrey!
Yeah!
Loved it so much!
If you stand around the mothership, you can observe the Elks.
Cloaking device.
Oh, cool!
Maybe the ending would be...
from the DLC.
I didn't realize it would be...
I mean, I guess it makes sense, right?
Because...
the ending of the game is just the destruction of the universe?
And the creation of a new one!
So...
So cool.
So awesome.
I think the DLC...
added,
like, such a good...
like, additional story to the overall plot.
And I like the way that they told the story differently...
before, you know, it was all, like, through text.
And then this time, you have the...
you had the...
visual.
Which, I'm a visual person, so it was much easier for me to...
understand.
Yeah, the imagery.
So good.
Really adds a whole new story.
It meshes perfectly with the existing one.
I know!
Oh, K'kwa!
K'kwa!
Providing another perspective on how people react to their own mortality as well.
It's connecting the thoughts of how the Nomai found the signal...
and why it disappeared.
Yeah, right!
It was a very, very good...
very neat tie together.
Tie it, you know?
It
was, uh...
really awesome.
I like the contrast between the Nomai and the Stranger's inhabitants.
The Stranger's were so scary!
The Nomai were like, We're so chill!
Oh my gosh!
Nexi!
Thank you for the hug!
It's my favorite game and you did great.
I was surprised several times by how quickly you solved certain puzzles.
I agree, the DLC really adds something new.
Congratulations on finishing it!
Thank you!
I think the coolest part is like...
you know...
the whole time in the...
one of my favorite things was the whole time in the...
original game...
You had the ability to doze by the fire and then that becomes a key mechanic in the DLC.
It's just so cool.
It's just so, so cool.
All knowledge should be preserved for the future.
And the Elks were not that.
The Elks...
You know...
Yeah, the Elks saw their demise and were just like, Now we're packing it up.
Get out of here.
No.
We're not doing this.
No, no, no!
So...
The area that teaches you how to doze by the fire is right next to the radio building where you start the DLC.
That's so crazy!
The...
The Elk were so...
I feel like they were very...
realistically written.
I feel like, you know...
If a species were to see that...
And also to leave their home planet and everything...
I feel like it would...
You know...
It feels very...
Realistic.
And their...
Their responses were...
You know...
What I would expect.
Congrats on finishing another amazing journey, man!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
They embodied fear, yet they were the most afraid.
Thank you for playing Outer Wilds!
Outer Wilds!
Owks.
Super sympathetic.
Yeah!
Yeah.
14.3 billion years later!
S1-7, thank you for the 10 gifted.
After Doom 64, will we play Doom 3?
Probably eventually.
The creation of a new planet.
A new creature.
Yeah!
Yeah, campfire!
Campfire?
Ohhohhohhmmmm So cool!
I did meet again somehow...
Okay, ignore that.
Thank you to...
Humphutterus.
For your...
For your full play-through of the ending.
I appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Soma by Malaaved.
Let's have them survive!
Let's go!
Yeah!
Why are they so scary?
Don't judge a book by its cover!
Okay, I'm just gonna quit to the main menu then.
Oh, my controller disconnected.
Yippee and congrats on finishing the journey, Minto!
Thank you!
What's the video?
Just the ending.
I would have imagined the whole thing was a video.
Imagine if I just was like...
By the way, guys, get got.
Oh, I'm fine.
But I really would have done the ending if it...
wouldn't take like another...
I don't know...
crazy amount of time for me.
Because I would have to go to so many places and get so much more stuff.
I wish I...
I wish I had played...
I wish I had played on my original game.
I wish I had played my original game.
But...
That's okay.
I still wouldn't have remembered how to get there or do anything.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
That's my mistake.
I thought I could just...
You know, I thought with what I got before...
And...
You know, I thought it would have been...
I thought it would have been different.
Hard to know.
Yeah, pretty much, so...
Look up the new Giants deep easter egg for giggles.
Someone said that there was a Steins Gate easter egg, is that true?
Is that true?
Thank you guys for joining me for this... I didn't expect it to be so spooky!
I may have added one.
Where is it?
Giant's Deep?
Easter egg.
I can now go to the Outer Wilds Wiki and look without any fear.
I can now look with no fear.
I'm seeing... I don't see it under the Easter eggs.
Uh oh, someone's slacking.
Wasn't that added?
It's a new one.
Time to join the Outer Wilds.
I'm sick.
I was just going...
It's really new.
Wait, how new are we talking?
Hold on, let me go to the... I'm going to the...
store page.
Sorry, you can hear probably the video.
Wait.
Thank you, Gao!
GG!
I just noticed the achievement I got...
from... from getting killed by the pursuers called OOFAUCHMABONES.
Brad, thank you!
Wait.
Oh!
Mr. Gyura, thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, hold on.
Thank you, Mr. Gyura!
I see the Elk Owls is the opposite of the Nomai.
Instead of pressing forward and facing danger, they regress and hit in the past.
The DLC has a core message about fear and overcoming it to make progress.
Which is what you had to do as a player too.
Oh my gosh, so deep.
OOFAUCHMABONES.
Brad, I think it might take a while before your things come up.
So thank you!
Congrats on finishing Echoes.
It was a blast.
This and Doom really cheered me up these past two weeks.
Thanks for picking it up.
You really cooked.
I can't believe I... I can't believe you guys said you have to cook.
And it was to cook!
It was to... I actually had to cook!
I had to cook to be cooked.
You guys are secret geniuses maybe too.
You guys are maybe secret geniuses as well.
To uh...
To suggest that.
10 hour stream.
Just a bit of help.
It's almost 1am.
I have to take my cat to the vet at 8am.
I need to shower.
Brain cooked.
My brain is cooked.
And then...
I think tomorrow... I don't know how long Doom will take me.
But I'm on a bit of a time limit since I have something to do that night.
And uh...
And then...
Saturday.
Metal Gear.
Probably like 10 minutes trust.
Actually I watched a DeSino video.
I was like...
I watched a DeSino video about the BFG.
Which I've watched him before.
So if you're familiar with him.
That guy does like...
A bunch of...
A bunch of uh...
Uh...
Doom videos and stuff.
Um...
Goodnight men.
Goodnight everybody!
Thank you!
If you're heading out.
Um...
But...
I still don't understand the BFG.
Like I understand it but I don't understand it.
So I actually have no idea what to do tomorrow.
Probably will watch another uh...
Or watch a...
Like a...
What's it called?
A...
Play through and see what they do.
Have a great night!
You guys as well!
Hold on.
I kinda wanna keep listening to this.
Congrats and Goodnight men.
Thank you!
Hold on.
Sorry guys.
Gimme a second.
You're a...
Oh!
There it is!
I think.
Gimme a second.
One second.
Blah blah blah blah.
Thank you for all the superchats.
Thank you for...
Um...
All the doughnos!
Really.
Really...
Really, really, really, really, really, really, really appreciate it.
Thank you for the non-elp-elp.
Here we go.
Okay.
Um...
There's more to the Easter egg.
I have to look it up.
Thank you for the Endurance stream.
Thank you guys for...
If you watched it all day, or if you joined in the middle, or even if you just joined now, or even if you just watched at the very beginning.
I hope you guys had fun.
Sorry for the...
Sorry for my frustration in the middle.
But...
We persevered.
We persevered and we made it.
I skipped work for this?
No way.
I'm glad you got to play through the DLC.
Thanks for streaming it.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay.
I'm gonna go to sleep now.
And I suggest you guys as well!
And I'll see you guys tomorrow.
I have karaoke in the morning.
Morning?
I don't... Afternoon?
And um...
Yeah!
Excited.
I'll do karaoke for a little bit, and then I'll make a waiting room for Doom.
I don't know how long I'll do for karaoke.
As soon as I'm done, I'll make a waiting room for Doom.
And uh... Yeah.
Okay!
Thank you for the stream!
Thank you!
Thanks for letting me do the ending.
By just watching it.
I know some people are like, It doesn't feel the same.
Like I said, I've already done it before.
So...
You know, I'm not gonna get that feeling back.
Or whatever.
Okay.
I'm gonna quit stalling.
Thank you for the...
Thank you for the super chat.
What did it say?
Endurance stream with the Oshii was not to love.
Oh...
Okay.
Thank you everybody!
Have a good night!
See you guys tomorrow!
Bye bye!
I told
you I wouldn't do it today!
I said so!
Woo!
Yippee!
Oh my gosh,
you're gonna like it so much.
They're crazy.
Thanks for dropping by.
I appreciate it.
Okay, bye!